GOOD MORNING WE'RE GONNA START
TO COMMITTEE R. AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME
MEMBERS THAT ARE IN OTHER
COMMITTEES THAT NEED TO GET TO
OTHER HEARINGS- SO WE'LL BEGIN
BY WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE HEARING. BY VISITING TO
COMMIT THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE- A.
P. S. F. DOT A. S. S. B. M. B.
L. Y. DOT CA DOT GOP PLEASE NOTE
THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED COMMITTEES CONSIDERED
PUBLIC COMMENT A MAY BE READ
INTO THE RECORD ARE REPRINTED
ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE
HEARING FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON
THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE. ASSEMBLY
W. W. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV BACKSLASH TODAY'S EVENT.
DATA ROOM WILL BE OPEN FOR
TENNIS FOR THIS HEARING- ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING A
HEARING IS ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A
MASK AT ALL TIMES WHILE IN THE
BUILDING THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING BY
TELEPHONE WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO. THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE FOR UPDATES IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF HEARING
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN
THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME WE WILL
NOT PERMIT CONTACTED DISRUPTS-
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IN PEACE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS. PLEASE BE AWARE
THAT ARE VIOLATIONS OF THESE
RULES MAY BE SUBJECT TO BE
REMOVED OUR OTHER ENFORCEMENT.
SHOULDN'T PROCESS. ODDS WE DON'T
HAVE QUORUM WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
AS A SUB COMMITTEE I DO KNOW WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. WHO
IS WHO'S COMMITTEESMEETING
ACROSS THE ACROSS THE AISLE AND
AS ARGUED NORMAL PRACTICE WITH
OTHER WE COMMITTEE CHEERS WE
ALLOW. FOR TO GO OUT OF ORDER
BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS TO CHAIR MEETING. AND GIVE
TESTIMONY AT THE SAME TIME. SO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO TRACK DOWN OUR
WITNESSES BUT- DO WE DO WE START
TO FAST HOW DO WE START TO
FESTER NO NO I'M THERE'S NEVER
TOO FAST. OR TOO FAST- WE WILL
TRACK THEM DOWN WHILE I BEGIN
OKAY OKAY- OKAY. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN BURSE. I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR TIME IN
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA IS ONLY ONE
OF THREE STATES THAT REQUIRES
HEALTH PROVIDERS TO REPORT TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT IF THEY'RE
TREATING PATIENTS FOR A BROAD
RANGE OF VIOLENT PHYSICAL
INJURIES. EVEN IF THE PATIENT
DOES NOT WANT THE REPORT TO BE
MADE THE CURRENT STATUTE COVERS
A BROAD RANGE OF PHYSICAL
INJURIES AND THIS STATUTE IS
OVERWHELMINGLY IN EXCLUSIVELY
APPLIED TO SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT FEAR OF MANDATORY
REPORTING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAVE KEPT SURVIVORS FROM SEEKING
HEALTH CARE ENSURING INFORMATION
WITH THEIR HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
IN ADDITION SURVEYS HAVE SHOWN
THAT 51% OF SURVIVORS STATED
THAT MANDATORY REPORTING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT ME THEIR SITUATIONS
WORSE AND ANOTHER 32% STATED
THAT IT EITHER MADE THINGS WORSE
OR DID NOT HELP THEM AT ALL. AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY WILL
MODERNIZE CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL
MANDATING REPORTING. BY REMOVING
THE LEGISLATIVE MANDATE TO
REPORT. TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
OLY REQUIRING FIRE ARM
INJURIES. TO REPORT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THIS BILL WILL
INSTEAD MANDATE THAT HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. PROVIDE REFERRALS TO
COMMUNITY BASED A NATIONAL
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
ADVOCACY SERVICES. TO BE CLEAR
CHANGES TO THE STATUE WILL NOT
AFFECT MANDATED REPORTING WITH
REGARD TO CHILD ABUSE AND ELDER
ABUSE. STATUTES MOREOVER THIS
BILL DOES NOT TAKE AWAY THE
OPTION TO REPORT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. PATIENTS CAN STILL
MAKE REPORT ON FORSMAN ASK THEIR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS TO REPORT.
IF THAT IS WHAT THEY CHOOSE.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT ENSURING THAT
SURVIVORS HAVE THE AGENCY AND
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO BE
SAFE AND HEALTHY. I WANT TO
THANK OUR SPONSORS FUTURES
WITHOUT VIOLENCE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR. AND THE
UC IRVINE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE LAW
CLINIC. I WILL LET MY WITNESSES
ITSELF INTRODUCED AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES- DIVVIED UP ANYWAY RELY. I'M SURE JONES SAWYER. BUT TO
MY OTHER MY CONFRONTED THE- I'M
SURE JONES SAWYER SENIOR AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU MY
NAME IS DOCTOR LEE KIMBER I'M A
PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO AND A SAFETY NET
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER- WITH
TWENTY SIX YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
IMPLEMENTING AND EVALUATING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAMS IN
HEALTH CARE. I'M HERE TO SHARE
MY ASSESSMENT OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF AB TWO SEVEN NINE NO IN
IMPROVING THE SAFETY AND HEALTH
OF PEOPLE SURVIVING DOMESTIC AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA
I'LL HIGHLIGHT THREE ISSUES
FIRST MANDATORY REPORT TO
TURNER'S DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DV
SURVIVORS FROM SEEKING HEALTH
CARE AND DISCLOSING VIOLENCE IN
OUR STUDY IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. OF PEACE THANKS TO
MERGING SEA DEPARTMENT PATIENTS
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND OAKLAND WE
FOUND THAT OUR RESPONDENTS
STATED THAT ALMOST HALF OF THE
DV SURVIVORS THAT THEY KNEW YOU
WERE AFRAID TO SPEAK HEALTH CARE
AND THAT MANY OF THE FEARFUL
NEVER SOUGHT HEALTH CARE DUE TO
FEAR THE TOP TWO FEARS THAT THEY
NAMED WHERE THE DV SURVIVORS
FEAR THE DOCTOR ACCORDING TO THE
POLICE AND THE PERSON
PERPETRATING THE DV FINDING OUT
ABOUT THE DISCLOSURE. IN MY
PRACTICE WHEN I SHARED MY
REPORTING OBLIGATIONS WITH A
SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL ASSAULT SHE
REFUSED AN EXAMINATION NEVER
RETURNED TO OUR HEALTH CENTER
AGAIN. SECOND MANDATORY
REPORTING IS MOST OFTEN I
THEY'RE NOT HELPFUL OR EVEN
HARMFUL AND THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT MANDATORY REPORTING OF
INJURIES REDUCES VIOLENCE THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION AND
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
STRONGLY RECOMMEND AGAINST
HEALTH CARE MANDATORY REPORTING
LAWS THIRD THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM CAN IMPROVE THE SAFETY OF
SURVIVORS WITHOUT MANDATORY
REPORTING. IS CURRENTLY OTHER
STATES AND ON FOR AN INJURED
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN
RESPECT SURVIVOR AGENCY AND
SHARE SAFETY PROMOTING OPTIONS
AND REFERRALS COMPASSIONATELY
AND CONFIDENTIALLY A SURVIVOR
AND ONE OF OUR STUDY SHARED-
THEN THERE WAS MY DOCTOR WHO
CONNECTED ME WITH ADVOCATE IT
FELT LIKE THE DOCTORS WERE ALL
LISTENING AND TRY TO GET A S.
WHATEVER. WE NEEDED THAT'S WHY
SHE HAD THE ADVOCATE COME IN AND
TALK TO ME I FELT CARED FOR
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS PAT LEFT LOTUS AND I
OVERSEE INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SERVICES FOR
COMMUTE SOLUTIONS AND
MULTISERVICE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. I HAVE WORKED IN THE
ANTI GENDER BASED VIOLENCE FIELD
FOR ALMOST TWENTY YEARS AND HAVE
WITNESSED HOW MEDICAL MANDATED
REPORTING DETER SURVIVORS FROM
SEEKING MEDICAL CARE DUE TO FEAR
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT INVOLVEMENT.
THIS FEAR IS AMPLIFIED FOR
SURVIVORS WITHOUT LEGAL STATUS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS REMOVING
BARRIERS THAT HINDER SURVIVORS
FROM ACCESSING MEDICAL CARE.
THIS BILL NEITHER TAKES AWAY
SURVIVORS OPTION TO CALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT NOR DOES IT PROHIBIT
MEDICAL PROVIDERS FROM REPORTING
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. SURVIVORS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO REPORT ABUSE
CANDIDLY TO PER CONFIDENTIAL
PROVIDERS. LAST YEAR A REVIEW
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DANGER
ASSESSMENTS CONDUCTED BY
CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATES AND FOUND
THAT 42% OF VICTIMS SHARE THAT
THEY HAD BEEN STRANGLED BY THEIR
PARTNER OR EX PARTNER. I ALSO
REVIEWED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
POLICE REPORTS FROM THE SAME
TIME PERIOD AND THE PUT THAT
THEY SHOW THAT ROUGHLY 13% OF
VICTIMS REPORTED TO THE POLICE
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN STRANGLED BY
THEIR PARTNER OR EX PARTNER.
SOME SURVIVORS WILL EVEN REFUSE
CRITICAL MEDICAL CARE TO AVOID
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. A TWENTY TWO
YEAR OLD WOMAN WE WORKED WITH
WAS RAPED AND STRANGLED BY HER
STEPBROTHER. SHE URGENTLY NEEDED
MEDICAL CARE BUT FEAR POLICE
INVOLVEMENT. AFTER SEVERAL DAYS
OF DEALING WITH BREATHING ISSUES
THE SURVIVOR HAD NO CHOICE BUT
TO SEEK MEDICAL ATTENTION
DESPITE NOT WANTING THIS
INCIDENT REPORTED AND THE
AFTERMATH THAT CAME WITH IT.
THIS TYPE OF DELAYED MEDICAL
CARE CAN BE LIFE THREATNING. AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHT SEP TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY AIMS TO UPLIFT
SURVIVOR SAFETY METONYMY AN
AGENCY. THROUGH INCREASED ACCESS
TO MEDICAL CARE AND
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT. UPLIFTING
SURVIVORS REQUIRE SURVIVOR
CENTERED COLLABORATIVE
INTERSECTIONAL STRATEGIES THAT
PRIORITIZE SURVIVORS VOICE IN
CHOICE. AND EXTEND BEYOND A
CRIMINAL SYSTEM APPROACH. THESE
STRATEGIES INCLUDE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PRACTICES AND COMMUNITY
BASED ALTERNATIVES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERVENTIONS.
PLEASE SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY THANK YOU PROTECT. THANK
YOU RT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
COME TO THE MIKE. HELLO I AM
CAIT VENDOR TAG AND I'M A STAFF
MEMBER AT FUTURES WITHOUT
VIOLENCE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HELLO MANY SALLY A STAFF MEMBER
FUTURES WITHOUT VIOLENCE I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THINK THANK
YOU. I AM SHARING THE NON ANTI
TRAFFICKING AT- ATTORNEY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK A KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
GOING BACK AS FOR THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SHARE AND
CHER- JONES SAWYER THAT I HAVE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
SIGNATURES OF HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS IN SUPPORT. WELL- OUR
HELP IN IN PROVIDERS- NOTABLY-
JACQUELINE CAMPBELL WHO IS THE
INTERNATIONAL CARE DID YOU HAVE
A HARD WORK OKAY HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THE RECALL THE
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET IT INTO
THE RECORD. ANYTHING ELSE OKAY
ARE THERE IT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN. COULD YOU. CHOOSE
LET THEM HAVE A SEAT PLEASE.
YEAH. OKAY.
HEY YOU HAVE THE SAME FIVE
MINUTES YOU SPLIT IT UP ANYWAY
YOU WANT TO MINUTES TO
ADMINISTER PIECE OR WHICHEVER
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY MY NAME IS JOYCE BLUE AND
I'M IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
AS A SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE MYSELF WHO WENT TO THE
HOSPITAL MANY TIMES THROUGHOUT A
TEN YEAR MARRIAGE AS A RESULT OF
BEING ABUSED I HAD WOULD HAVE
WELCOMED HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
MAKING REPORT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING TO ME I FEEL THAT IF
THE REPORT HAD BEEN MADE THE
VERY FIRST TIME. I WENT TO THE
DOCTOR THAT MAYBE MY VIEWS OR
WHAT HAVE AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
HURTING ME IN FOR BREAKING THE
LAW. I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT IF
THE HEALTHCARE PROVIDER REPORTED
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. THE VERY
FIRST TIME I WENT TO THE
HOSPITAL WITH BROKEN BONES. AND
INTERNAL INJURIES IT WOULD HAVE
PREVENTED FURTHER ABUSED BY MY
HUSBAND SUCH AS BEING STRANGLED
SEVERAL TIMES ANTI BLACKED OUT
BROKEN JAW. RIBS AND BEING
ASSAULTED WHILE EIGHT MONTHS
PREGNANT AND OTHER TYPES OF
VICTIMIZATION WHICH EVENTUALLY
LED. AFTER TEN YEARS OF REVIEWS
LED TO MY VIEWS YOU'RE SHOOTING
ME WITH AN M. SIXTEEN ASSAULT
WEAPON WHICH HAD TWENTY ROUNDS
AND IT. AND HE DID THIS IN FRONT
OF OUR TWO SMALL CHILDREN THE
ONLY REASON WELL I'M HERE TODAY
IS BECAUSE THE GUN DOWN ON THE
THIRD ROUND AFTER GOING THROUGH
MY HAIR ON THE TOP OF MY HEAD. I
FIRMLY BELIEVE IF IT WAS PORTED
THE FIRST TIME I SOUGHT MEDICAL
CARE MAYBE THE ABUSE WOULD HAVE
BEEN FINALLY OVER FOR ME AND MY
CHILDREN HAD SEVEN DURING TEN
YEARS OF ABUSE. SINCE WORKING
WITH SURVIVORS FOR FORTY YEARS
NOW AS A PROFESSIONAL. I'VE
NEVER ONCE ENCOUNTERED A VICTIM
NOT WE NEED TO GET THE MEDICAL
TREATMENT THEY NEED IT OUT OF
FEAR IN. A REPORT BEING MADE TO
LOG BACK FORSMAN HAVE FACT IT
OFTEN TIME A VICTIM HAS BEEN TO
THE DOCTOR AS A RESULT OF BEING
ABUSED. LAW ENFORCEMENT OR CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND ADULT
PROTECTIVE SAID SIR THIS HAS
ALREADY BEEN INVOLVED IN THEIR
LIVES ADDITIONALLY IT HAS BEEN
MY EXPERIENCE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT TEND TO RESPOND
QUICKER. WHEN REPORTED BY A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER THEN IF IT
WAS REPORTED ON MY OWN AS A
SURVIVOR AND PROFESSIONAL WHO
HAS BEEN WORKING EVERY WITH
SURVIVORS IN THEIR STORE DAY. IT
IS MY EX THAT WHEN I HOW VAIDER
SO THEY NEED TO REPORT.
TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THE REPORT EVEN IF I WANTED TO.
I WAS SO PETRIFIED AND SCARED
BUT I WANTED SOMEONE ELSE TO DO
WHAT I COULD NOT DO. I PREFER
SOMEONE ELSE DOING IT BESIDES ME
BECAUSE IT WAS BAD ENOUGH
KNOWING. THAT I WAS GOING TO GET
BEAT UP AGAIN NO MATTER WHO IS
INVOLVED WHETHER IT WAS HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER. LAW ENFORCEMENT
FAMILY MEMBER OR NEIGHBOR. AT
LEAST THE BURDEN IS OFF OF ME.
WHEN A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
REPORTS TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. IT
FEELS LIKE THEY CARE AND THAT
THEY'RE ADVOCATING FOR MY SAFETY
AND THE SAFETY OF. MY CHILDREN.
IT ALSO SENDS THE MESSAGE THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS SERIOUS.
AND IT'S A CRIME. MOST VICTIMS
TEND TO MINIMIZE THE ABUSE. I
DON'T WANT TO LEAVE THE
RELATIONSHIP THEY JUST WANT THE
ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR TO STOP. MY
HELP BY HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
REPORTING IT MIGHT BE THE THING
THAT SAVES THAT VICTIM'S LIFE.
SOMEONE UP MAKING THAT REPORT
VERSUS THE VICTIM. IT REALLY IS
MORE THAN ABOUT REPORTING IT IS
ALSO ABOUT GETTING SURVIVORS
CONNECTED TO RESOURCES CREATED A
SAFETY PLAN FOR VICTIMS AND
THEIR CHILDREN. AND SEEING WHAT
CAN BE DONE. THERE'S ACCOUNTABLE
FOR HURTING SOMEONE AND FOR NOT
AND WE'RE BREAKING THE LAW BY
REPORTING AND PROSECUTING. IN
CONCLUSION JUST IMAGINE IF YOUR
SISTER. YOUR DAUGHTER YOUR
MOTHER YOUR GRANDMOTHER. ENTERED
THEIR MERGER ROOM BECAUSE SHE
WAS BEAT UP SHE WAS STABBED. AND
STRANGLED AND LEFT FOR DEAD YOU
WOULD WANT SOMEONE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HURTING THEM.
AND FOR BREAKING THE LAW. MAYBE
IF MORE PEOPLE REPORTED VERSUS
NO ONE REPORTED THEN MAYBE THERE
WOULD BE LESS VIOLENCE. YOU ALL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT HERE
RIGHT NOW TODAY AND THIS ROOM TO
SAVE LIVES AND PREVENT FURTHER
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN AND
CHILDREN. AND ISN'T THAT WHAT WE
ALL WANT TO DO. I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE DO NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AT THE LEAST PUT IT ON HOLD
UNTIL THERE CAN BE MORE
DISCUSSION. THAT INCLUDES
SURVIVORS AND WITH FACTUAL
INFORMATION I REMEMBER THIS. AS
YOU MAKE YOUR DECISION ON THIS
DANGEROUS BILL. IF NO ONE
REPORTS THEN THERE IS NO ONE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND YUR LOVE
ONE MIGHT BE THE NEXT TO GET
SHOT OUT WITH AN M. SIXTEEN. AND
THAT GUY JUST MIGHT NOT JAM
THANK YOU. THIRTY SECONDS I'LL
GIVE YOU A MINUTE HEY GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DOCTOR DUGAN
I'M ACTUALLY THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR OVER THE STATEWIDE
TRAINING- THE CONDUCT THESE
TYPES OF. UP AYE OPPOSED TO
MANDATED REPORTING REQUIREMENT
REMOVAL IN THIS BILL THE REASON
BEING WITH ALL OF MY YEARS OF
TRAINING EXPERIENCE IF THERE WAS
LEGITIMATE RESEARCH THAT SHOWED.
THAT OVERTURNING THIS BILL WOULD
LEAD TO INCREASE PATIENT SAFETY
AND ESCAPE FROM TV I WOULD BE IN
FULL SUPPORT. BUT THE EVIDENCE
DOES NOT SHOW THAT ACTUALLY THE
EVIDENCE THAT WAS RESEARCHED BY
THE SUPPORT SHOWS THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS OVERWHELMINGLY
AT A RATIO FORTY ONE SUPPORT
MANDATED REPORTING LAWS THAT WAS-IN THE- EVIDENCE THAT THEY
REFERENCED NOT MINE. AND SIDE
THAT'S WHY I'M OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL THE OTHER CONCERN I HAVE IS
WHAT ABOUT THE SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THEY PRESENT
TO THE E. OURS WITH NEARLY THE
SAME IDENTICAL INJURIES YET NO
ONE HAS TALKED ABOUT HOW THIS
WILL IMPACT TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS. SO MYOPINION. I
RECOMMEND THAT WE MOVED TO YOUR
BILL. WE WORK TOGETHER AS
SURVIVORS AS ADVOCATES AS
MEDICAL PROVIDERS INCLUDING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
FULL IMPACT AND RAMIFICATIONS OF
THIS LAW. BECAUSE I TELL YOU
MOST OF OUR STOCKED SOLD MASSIVE
AS HUMAN TRAFFICKING FORENSIC
EXAMS ARE TIED TO ONE ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE OF SIXTY ONE. AND I'M
CONCERNED WILL BE A GREAT UP
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS. THANK YOU. IT AND ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM YES SIR. MY NAME IS
PAUL DURENBERGER I AM A CITIZEN
AS SACRAMENTO- AND DIE- RUN THE
CAMPO PROGRAM FOR THE STOCK IN A
REGIONAL FAMILY JUST CENTER BUT
I'M HERE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER NETWORK WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN BUT WE WANT TO COME
TOGETHER THANK YOU NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU OKAY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN A ROOM
THERE IN OPPOSITION. READ NOT
GOING TO APPROACH IT WE'RE GOING
TO THE PHONES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO SAVE
TIME SO WE GET IT ALL DONE. AB
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN UP. AB
TWENTY ABSOLUTELY IF YOU WERE
SPEAKING IN. IF YOU'RE SPEAKING
IN FAVOR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING SIR MY NAME IS ERIC
MORE THAN IT THOUGHT WOULD BE A
LIVE REPORT THE MEDICAL THERE
WHERE COKE BEEN A STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY FOUR. MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MONEY TO SOME OF THEM
DIRECTOR STATE POLICY WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY THANK YOU. BY TWENTY
EIGHT. KIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTEEN. MORNING MR
MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S THE AND
PLEASE TALK WILL OF CLAREMONT UP
MON THESE REPORT BEACH UPLAND
STAND A UPPER INGLEWOOD ARE
REVERSE FORTUNE CITY ALL ON SPEC
COOPER AS WELL TO TELL THANK
THANK YOU SIR. MY THIRTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE CARE FOR
ME MEMBER I PURELY THE FAT
CALLING BEHALF OF DIEGO CA YES
APART SUMMER STEPHAN WE RESPECT
OPPOSE AB TWO SEVEN ZERO THANK
YOU. LINE FORTY. HI MY NAME IS
CLAIRE GALLON I WORK FOR FUTURES
WITHOUT VIOLENCE NINE SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY. THANK
YOU. NINE FORTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS A GROUP OF
VERA AND I WORK WITH THE
FINANCIAL SERVICE CENTER AND WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY. NINE FORTY FOUR.
HELLO MISTER CHEN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARK WITH THE GUN AND
I'M WITH THE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
NETWORK AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JAMES GALLAGHER CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE SCHOOL THAT'S
LOCKED IN THE STATE FILINGS
CLINIC WHERE COSPONSORED AT AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ENTER INTO
COURT. THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
LIBBY BENEDICT I'M WITH WOMEN
ARE LOOKING FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY THANK YOU
. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU WOULD NOT
BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE- YOU MAY CLOSE- THANK YOU I
WANT TO- APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR EXPERIENCE AND
YOUR STRENGTH AND ADVOCACY- AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT- AND YOUR TESTIMONY AS WELL
AND I WELCOME CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OPPOSITION I WANT TO CRAFT
SOMETHING THAT ULTIMATELY HELPS-
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS THAT IS
THE GOAL OF THE BILL- AND YOU
KNOW THIS BILL- YOU KNOW HAS A
HAS A LOT OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS ORGANIZATIONS
ADVOCATES MEDICAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND OTHERS WHO ARE. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AND SO I THINK
IT AT MINIMUM WARRANTS CONTINUE
CONVERSATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DOING THE RIGHT THING TO
HELP- YOU KNOW A VICTIMS OF
VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
I KNOW THIS STUFF ISN'T EASY
I'VE SAT ON THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE- I'VE BEEN BROUGHT TO
TEARS IN THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE
AS THE SPEED AS THE CHAIR KNOWS-
BECAUSE THESE ARE COMPLEX
PROBLEMS BUT I GIVE MY WORD THAT
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION I WILL CONTINUE TO.
AND TO- PEOPLE ATALL ON ALL
SIDES OF THIS VICTIMS AND
OTHERS. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CRAFT A BILL THAT ULTIMATELY
HELPS. AS MANY PEOPLE AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN AND FUNDAMENTALLY
WHAT THIS THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
DO IS TO GO FROM A- CRIMINAL
JUSTICE LAW ENFORCEMENT APPROACH
TO SOMETHING THAT REALLY
CENTERS. VICTIMS AGENCY AND
VICTIMS RIGHTS IN THE
CONVERSATION AS THE CENTERPIECE.
OF HOW WE ACTUALLY CRAFTED THIS
POLICY SO- AGAIN I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION I
WELCOME MORE CONVERSATION AND I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE BILL
BEFORE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE.
THOSE CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS AND
BUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SWAG TO BE A MOTION. WE
HAVE A FOUR ZERO AM STATUS
COURTNEY. SO WE WILL GET BACK TO
THIS BUT I WILL SAY THAT- I
BELIEVE YOU WILL. WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES TO MAKE SURE WE CRAFTED
IT DOES GO TO APPROPRIATIONS SIR
COULD BE QUITE A FEW CHANGES ARE
MADE AND I'VE BEEN AND I'M WHILE
YOU'RE HERE- I JUST WANT YOU
KNOW- YOUR TESTIMONY. I'VE BEEN
ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR TEN YEARS
IS PROBABLY ONE THE MOST
COMPELLING. ARGUMENTS I'VE EVER
HEARD IN THIS CHAMBER AND I AND
I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE- YOU
TOUCHED EVERYONE'S HEART.
RICHARD RICHARD TESTIMONY AND SO
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW IS NOT.
WHATEVER HAPPENED IS YOU WERE
HEARD. YOU WOULD DEFINITELY HURT
HERE TODAY IS ON THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. AND SO. WE HAVE TO
WAIT TO GET A CORPORATE OR
WEAKENED WE CAN MOVE ON THIS
THANK YOU PERFECT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BUT I CAN'T ANNOUNCE-
THERE BEEN TWO ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PULLED OFF CALENDAR. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY TWO
HOLDEN POLL BY AUTHOR. AND ITEM
NUMBER. FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE
FORTY FIVE. MURATSUCHI PULL BY
AUTHOR. AND- I DON'T SEE ANY
AUTHORS HERE. I'M LOOKING FOR MR
ARAMBULA. YOU DON'T CONSENT A
GOOD. ABOUT BAR QUE HAN. SHE'S
COMING AFTER A WHILE- I DO HAVE
TO HOLDEN BILLS. ONE SEVEN YEAH
TWO MORE LEFT EIGHT NINE- MISTER
MISTER MATHIS MR MCCARTY. MISTER
RODRIGUEZ- MR STONE IS IN
JUDICIARY RIGHT NOW. WHAT IF I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IN. THIRTY
SECONDS WE CAN GO TO RESPOND TO
OR MISTER BRYANT. AND IT'S
BOATED LOOKING AT SHUDDER I HAVE
TO GO NUMERICAL ORDER. I WAS
LOOKING AT THE CLOCK I REALIZE
IT DOESN'T MOVE SO- OKAY GO FOR
IT MISTER- MS BONTA IS FIRST.
AB TWENTY SIX I'M A TWENTY THREE
SIXTY ONE MIA BONTA JUVENILE
TRANSFERRED TO COURT OF CRIMINAL
JURISDICTION. GOOD MORNING YOU
READ. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HELP WITH THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE PAST DECADE
CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED
LEGISLATION MEANT TO REDUCE THE
TRANSFER OF JUVENILES TO ADULT
COURT. AND PROVIDE JUVENILES
OPPORTUNITY TO REHABILITATE
UNFORTUNATELY YOUTH OF COLOR
CONTINUE TO DISPROPORTIONATELY
THE VICTIMS OF STRUCTURAL RACISM
AND THE CUTS IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN 202096% OF
JUVENILE TRANSFERS TO ADULT
COURT. WHERE YOUTH OF COLOR MORE
SPECIFICALLY 71% WERE HISPANIC
AND TWENTY PERCENT WERE BLACK
THIS IS IN PART DUE TO THE LACK
OF GUIDANCE PROVIDED TO JUDGES
MAKING THIS CRITICAL DECISION
REGARDING JUVENILE TRANSFERS
CURRENTLY JUDGES ARE REQUIRED TO
WEIGH FIVE CRITERIA BEFORE
DECIDING IF YOU SHOULD BE
TRANSFERRED TO ADULT COURT. AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE IT WOULD
STRENGTHEN THE FIVE CRITERIA
ANALYSIS BY REQUIRING A JUDGE TO
MAKE AN AFFIRMATIVE FINDING THAT
A JUVENILE IS NOT AMENABLE TO
REHABILITATION IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. BEFORE MAKING A
MOTION TO TRANSFER THAT JUVENILE
TO ADULT COURT THAT FINDING WILL
HAVE TO BE SUPPORTED BY CLEAR
AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE AND
INCLUDE THE REASON SUPPORTING
THE COURT'S FINDING THAT THE
MINOR IS NOT AMENABLE TO
REHABILITATION WELL UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE JUVENILE
COURT. THANK YOU AND I'VE
WITNESSES HERE WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE JOHNSON LABEL WITH THE
PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER SYSTEM
A CO SPONSOR TO THE BILL AND
CANCER MENDOZA WITH THE ENTIRE
RECIDIVISM COALITION. THANK YOU.
FIVE MINUTES. THANK YOU UGH GOOD
MORNING SO THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT HAS CALLED THE
DECISION TO TRANSFER YOU FROM
JUVENILE COURT TO ADULT COURT.
THE WORST PUNISHMENT BUT THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM IS EMPOWERED TO
INFLICT. A YOUTH WHO WAS
TRANSFERRED TO ADULT COURT FACES
EXACTLY THE SAME PUNISHMENT AS
AN ADULT- COMMITTED THE SAME
CRIME UP TO LIFE IN PRISON. A
YOUTH WHO WAS TRANSFERRED WILL
BE INCARCERATED IN THE SYSTEM
THAT FOCUSES ON PUNISHMENT AND
NOT REHABILITATION. AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY ONE IS A MODEST
CHANGE TO CODIFY A PRINCIPLE
THAT MAY ALREADY SEEM OBVIOUS IF
A JUVENILE COURT JUDGE FINDS THE
TO USE IS AMENABLE TO
REHABILITATION. THE YOUTH SHOULD
STAY IN JUVENILE COURT.
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT STATED
OVER FIFTY YEARS AGO THAT THE
CRITICAL QUESTION AT A TRANSFER
HEARING IS THE MINERS AND MEAN
ABILITY TO TREATMENT IN JUVENILE
COURT. BUT OUR CURRENT STATUTES
DO NOT CLEARLY REFLECT THAT
PRINCIPLE. INSTEAD THE CURRENT
LAW PROVIDES NO GUIDANCE TO
JUDGES ABOUT HOW THEY SHOULD
WEIGH THE FIVE FACTORS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED IN THE TRUCK IN THIS
TRANSFER DECISION. THIS IS LED
TO SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES IN
JUDICIAL DECISION MAKING AND
IT'S CONTRIBUTED TO THE PROFOUND
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES
AMONG YOUTH WERE TRANSFERRED TO
ADULT COURT. IT ALSO RESULTS IN
YOU BEING TRANSFERRED TO ADULT
COURT EVEN IF THE JUVENILE JUDGE
CONCLUDES AFTER HEARING WITH
PRESENTATION OF EVIDENCE BY BOTH
PROSECUTION AND DEFENSE THAT THE
YOUTH IS AMENABLE TO
REHABILITATION IN JUVENILE COURT
. AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE WILL
ENSURE THAT YOU TWO ARE AMENABLE
TO REHABILITATION WILL REMAIN IN
JUVENILE COURT. WITHOUT
RESTRICTING IN ANY WAY A JUDGE'S
ABILITY TO TRANSFER A YOUTH WHO
IS NOT AMENABLE TO
REHABILITATION. I WANT TO
EXPRESS APPRECIATION TO
COMMITTEE COUNCIL AND TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL FOR SUGGESTING
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE ADOPTED
LAST WEEK TO CLARIFY THE
STANDARD FOR THIS JUDICIAL
DECISION. WE HOPE THESE
COMMONSENSE PRINCIPLES EARNED
THE SUPPORT OF THE COMMITTEE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU. HELLO
MY NAME IS KEN MENDOZA I AM INTO
ACTIVISTS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WITH THE HEBER BURNS
INSTITUTE AND ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY. WHEN I WAS JUST
FOURTEEN YEARS OF AGE I SPENT MY
FIRST NAME DEVON HALL WHEN I WAS
SEVENTEEN YEARS OF AGE I WAS IN
FRONT OF A JUDGE WHO HAD TO
DECIDE WHETHER I WOULD BE SENT
TO ADULT COURT TO SERVE EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE TO LIFE. PRISON
SENTENCE OR WHETHER I WILL BE
ALLOWED TO REMAIN IN JUVENILE
COURT. HOW TO HAD A DIFFERENT
JUDGE SUCH AS ONE WHO BELIEVE
THAT OUR KIDS WHO COMMIT SERIOUS
OFFENSES SHOULD BE SENT TO ADULT
COURT. I WILL BE IN PRISON RIGHT
NOW AND WILL NOT BE ABLE TO BE
RELEASED ON TO TWENTY THIRTY. OF
THAT WOULD BE A WASTE OF
POTENTIAL. MMHM FOR SORRY BUT
THE I'M I'M I'M IN MY SPEECH-
WHEN I WAS THE HOW TO HOW TO YOU
SO- IS THE OF THE G. THAT I WAS
IN FRONT OF THE SITE THAT TO
GIVE ME A CHANCE AND I WAS ABLE
TO TAKE A BUNCH OF THE
COUNSELING MENTORSHIP AND
EDUCATION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF.
YOUR DEPARTMENT JUST WANTED
JUSTICE HAD TO OFFER I WAS ABLE
TO EARN AN EARLY RELEASE IN A
FEW IN FEW YEARS SINCE THEN I
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DEDICATE MY
LIFE IN MENTORING OTHERS TO KEEP
THEM OUT OF THE SYSTEM I HAVE
DONE EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WITH THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. AS A MEMBER OF AN
STAFF WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION I WORKED ON MORE THAN
TWENTY LEGISATIVE BILLS- AND
MANY COUNTY INITIATIVES WHICH
HAVE POSITIVELY IMPACTED MANY
LIVES IN RETURN I IN TURN MAKING
OUR COMMUNITY SAFER I'M SORRY
IT'S HARD TO HEAR- DO I HAVE NOT
BE POSSIBLE IF THE COURTS WILL
HAVE NOT THEM INTO PRISON. NOT
THAT I AM A TWENTY OR TWENTY
EIGHT YEAR OLD GUY I RECOGNIZE
THAT AT THE AGE OF FIFTEEN I WAS
JUST A KID A TEENAGER IMPACTED
BY THE SEVERE TRAUMA THAT I HAD
AS A KID I AM GLAD THAT THE
JUDGE DIDN'T JUST THROW AWAY MY
LIFE I THINK MY LIFE DIDN'T
MATTER. MANY OF MY FRIENDS WERE
NOT SO LUCKY FOR EXAMPLE MY
FRIEND NELSON AROUND I'M IN THEM
IS MORE ON A TELEPHONE RECEIVE A
PRISON SENTENCE AND WAS JUST
REALLY SAID URKEL OR MICHEAL
ROMERO WHO I MET IN JUVENILE
HALL AND HAD RECENTLY. HAD BORN
DAUGHTER WHO RECEIVE A THIRTY
YEAR TO LIFE SENTENCE HE HAS
FINALLY RECONNECTED WITH
DAUGHTER WHO'S NOT A TEENAGER
THEY HAD JUDGES WHO TRANSFERRED
IN HOW TO ADULT COURT WHERE THEY
RECEIVE LENGTHY SENTENCES THEY
WERE KIDS JUST LIKE ME. ARE THEY
DO THEY WERE ABLE TO REMAIN IN
JUVENILE COURT COULD RECEIVE
ABILITY OF SERVICES AND NOW OUR
FUTURE LEADERS LIKE MY MEDICINE
THERE'S A MEMBERS IS STICKING TO
SHAUNA WHO WAS RELEASED AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND FROM THE
TODAY AND IS NOW A TWENTY ONE
YEAR OLD COMMISSION ABOUT THE L.
A. COUNTY OR MILDER MEANT TEAM-
Q. ONE THE CAME INTO WAS
RELEASED FROM THE A DAY. AND IS
IN KAPALI POINT IN PERSON LAW
DEGREE. I THINK IT IS BUT- PASS
THIS BILL SO THAT. CAN BE
REHABILITATED. IN THE JUVENILE.
SYSTEM IN NOT FROM TO ADORE
PRISON. TO BE. FOR DEBT. VICTIM
AT RISK OF SOURCE. AND CON TO
SERVE WITHOUT A- SERVICE AND-
THAT COULD HAVE HELPED. BECOME
THE- VERSIONS OF THEM. LET'S
KEEP THE ROAD TO. THE OPEN. AND
I.AND YES ON A BETWEEN THREE
SIX ONE AND I. FOR SAID IN A
LOT. IT IS A HUNDRED HE DID A
GREAT MR MENDOZA. SO AN- HERE IN
SUPPORT. AND WITH A THE ROOM. HI
FRED WILLIAMS ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU BUT YOU. BLESS
YOU. GOOD MORNING GOING BACK
ISRAEL BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT. THE MORNING
GREGORY FLAT WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HELLO CHLOE CAMPBELL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE PROJECT
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NOW
LISTEN TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OPES I'M SORRY THE
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE FOR SOME
REASON I GO TO THE PHONES TODAY
OUR EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR COULD
YOU OPEN UP THE PHONE FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS A MEASURE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCHTONE PHONE AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NINETEEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
MORE LINES IN Q. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE ASSIGNED THEM THEIR
LINE NUMBERS. GO NEXT TO LINE
FIFTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CLIFF COSTA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION IN PARTICULAR TO
JUVENILE COURT JUDGES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE-
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE COURTS. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU
WE NOW LISTEN TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. LOOKING INTO RUMORED
A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. CNN
WILL NOW GO TO LINE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. GERMAN WE HAVE
KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME FROM
THE PHONE LINES THANK YOU BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS MISTER
BRYANT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MISS BONTA THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE BILL IF YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR CO AUTHORS I'D BE
HAPPY TO JUMP ON MR MENDOZA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
BEEN RIDE WITH YOU FOR A LONG
LONG TIME AND I'M ALSO PROUD
THAT YOU'RE NOT INCARCERATED TO
THE TWENTY THIRD. THE COMMUNITY
HAS BEEN BETTER WITH YOUR IMPACT
AND I THINK THIS BILL IS A
SENSIBLE SMART STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND HAS MY FULL
SUPPORT. IF YOU'RE- GIVEN OUR
STATUS REPORT. JONES SAWYER HERE
LACKEY YOUR MERE BONTA YOUR
BRIAN. WORK SANTIAGO. SEYARTO
ORANGE PRESIDENT NOW BRING YOU
BACK TO IT ANY OTHER COMMENTS-
RESTORED. YEAH UNFORTUNATELY I
SEE THE FROM A LITTLE PER- I
THINK THAT- THIS IS A REAL BIG
EXAMPLE OF HOW THE FOCUS. ON
OFFENDERS ONLY IS NOT BALLOTS
WITH WITH VICTIMS. AND I'VE I
BELIEVE THAT MULTIPLE STANDARDS
ALREADY EXIST TO ENSURE THAT-
TRANSFERRING. MINERS TO ADULT
COURT IS NOT A CONVENIENT
PRACTICE- WE ONLY HAD THIRTY TWO
CONVICTIONS THE TWENTY TWENTY
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE. AND
I THINK THAT THERE ARE NONE I-
COMMEND THIS YOUNG MAN FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. AND I'M THANKFUL IN
HIS SITUATION THAT THINGS WORK
THE WAY THEY DID BUT I WOULD
JUST TELL YOU THAT- THERE ARE
SOME VERY VERY. DISHEARTENING
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT- I THINK THAT
WOULD BE RECOGNIZED
APPROPRIATELY THIS BILL
CONTINUES FORWARDS ALL HAVE TO
OPPOSE IT. THANK YOU MR LACKEY
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. THE NEW MAY
CLOSENESS RESPOND. THANK YOU OUR
KNOWLEDGE OF ADOLESCENT
NEUROSCIENCES DEMONSTRATED THE
DEFICIENCIES AND JUVENILE
DECISION MAKING CAPACITY WHILE
THEY'RE YOUNG BRANDS CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP AN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
SCIENCE CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
ADOPTED EVIDENCE BASED PROPOSALS
TO GIVE YOUTH WHO COMMIT CERTAIN
TO CERTAIN CRIME CRIMES A PATH
TO REHABILITATION AND THE SECOND
CHANCES THEY PREPARED TO REENTER
OUR SOCIETY AND A DOT ON ADULTS
A. B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE IS
A MODEST CHANGE THAT WILL ONLY
STRENGTHEN ALREADY EXISTING LAW.
TO ENSURE THE JUVENILES AMENABLE
TO REHABILITATION REMAIN IN
JUVENILE COURT I THINK MY
WITNESSES PARTICULAR MISTER
MENDOZA FOR SPEAKING TO WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE ONE OF THOSE SIXTY
AT THAT COULD HAVE POTENTIALLY
BEEN SWEPT UP. WITHOUT  CHANGE
IN LAW THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
AND I BELIEVE THE MOTION. CHECK
AND I BELIEVE THE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WERE WERE ALREADY
TAKEN STEPS TO REPORT THAT'S
DISPENSED WITH ARMCHAIRS
RECOMMENDED I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS- AS WAS MEADOWS
SAID I THINK WE- WE INCARCERATED
MORE WE SWUNG TOO FAR- IN A WAY
WHERE PUNISHMENT WAS. WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND NOW WE ARE
LEVELING THINGS- I DON'T THINK
WE'VE GONE TOO FAR TO THE LEFT
BROUGH WE'RE TRYING TO JUST
RIGHT TO SHIP RIGHT NOW. SO
RESEARCHERS RECOMMENDED AIBO. ON
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY. LACKEY NO
BONTA HI BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN HI
QUIRK. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
SEYARTO. THEY BILLS ARE CALLED
NEEDS ONE MORE. THANK YOU AND
NOW WE HAVE MR HOLDEN WHO I SEE
IS HERE. I BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE
ON CONSENT. AT TEN YOU HAVE TO
OTHERS. POST POLLS I'M SORRY
WHEN YOU PULLED INTO YOU'RE
GOING TO. PERCENT BRING AB- TWO
SIX FOUR FOUR EIGHT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN THREE WHICHEVER ONE YOU
WANT TO BEGIN WITH. OKAY IT'S
THE UP AGAIN WITH TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR. OKAY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE A FIRST
I'D LIKE TO STATE THAT I ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE CHAIR AND ITS
CONSULTANTS- ON THIS BILL AS WE
MOVE FORWARD BUT I DO APPRECIATE
THE- THE WORKING AND SUPPORT-
AND GUIDANCE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PROVIDE. A TO US TO THIS
POINT BUT TODAY I'M PRESENTING
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR THE
BILL THAT PROHIBITS LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS FROM USING
THREATS PHYSICAL HARM
OR PSYCHOLOGICAL MANIPULATION
INTERROGATION TACTICS WHEN
QUESTION OF YOUTH TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF AGE OR YOUNGER. MEMBERS
FOR NEARLY A YEAR MY OFFICE IS
WORKING LAW ENFORCEMENT POST
PUBLIC DEFENDERS VARIOUS
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
SPECIALIZING IN JUVENILE
JUSTICE. AND PUBLIC SAFETY
CONSULTANTS HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
AS WELL AS THE SENATE. TO PUT
FOR THOUGHTFUL LEGISLATION
SURROUNDING JUVENILE
INTERROGATIONS. AS I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE THERE CONTINUES TO
BE A GROWING BODY OF RESEARCH
THAT SUGGESTS THAT ONE FALSE
CONFESSIONS OR ONE OF THE
LEADING CAUSES OF WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS AND TO THE BRAIN IS
NOT FULLY DEVELOPED UNTIL THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE. WELL CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES THAT YOU SEVENTEEN
YEARS OF AGE OR YOUNGER TO
CONSULT WITH LEGAL COUNSEL
EXISTING LAW FAILS TO RECOGNIZE
THAT EVEN AN INFORMAL WAIVER OF
RIGHTS DOES NOT PROTECT YOU FROM
FALSELY IMPLICATING THEMSELVES
OR OTHERS AND SERIOUS CRIMES
WHEN AN INTERROGATION INVOLVES
COERCIVE MANIPULATIVE AND GIL
PRASOON LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TECHNIQUES IN ADDITION. TO
PROHIBITING THE USE OF AFTER
MENTION TACTICS AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR RECOGNIZES THAT THERE
ARE TIMES WHEN THESE LIMITATIONS
SHOULD NOT APPLY PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT IS NECESSARY. TO PROTECT
LIFE OR PROPERTY FROM IMMINENT
HARM. FINALLY IN WORKING WITH
THE COALITION OF LOS ANGELES AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTY PROBATION
UNIONS. I HAVE EXTENDED THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT PROBATION
OFFICERS NEED TO NOTIFY THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER WHEN A MINOR IS
TAKEN INTO CUSTODY AT A JUVENILE
HALL OR ANY OTHER PLACE OF
CONFINEMENT. IN CLOSING MEMBERS
I KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN SOME
CONCERN REGARDING THE
CLASSIFICATION OF A TWENTY FIVE
YEAR OLD AS A JUVENILE. HOWEVER
I JUST WANT TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
AB THIRTEEN OH EIGHT STONE.
WHICH NOW REQUIRES THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS TO CONDUCT YOUTH
OFFENDER PAROLE HEARINGS. FOR
OFFENDERS THAT WERE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF AGE OR YOUNGER AT THE
TIME OF THE OFFENSE. THAT BILL
RECOGNIZE THAT THE BRAIN IS NOT
FULLY DEVELOPED AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE. THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THE SAME ASSESSMENT
AND THEREFORE THESE INDIVIDUALS
SHOULD BE SHIELDED FROM IMPROPER
INTERROGATION METHODS AS WELL.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY BUT TO
ROLES WITH WILL WE ALSO HAVE.
NOTABLE WILLIE PELOTA- DRILLS
WITH WHO WAS WRONGLY WRONGFULLY
CONVICTED IN ILLINOIS' AS A
YOUTH AND NOW LIVES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN PASSING ILLINOIS' ANTI
DECEPTION LAW. AND RICHARD
ROCHER STAFF ATTORNEY FIRST
DISTRICT APPELLATE PROJECT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK YOU
ROUTE YOU CAN BEGIN WHATEVER YOU
READY FIVE MINUTES TOTAL ALL
RIGHT GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND EVERYONE ON THE COMMITTEE
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU GUYS
FOR HAVING ME AND GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY STORY-
AGAIN MY NAME IS TERRELL SWEPT-
AND I SPENT FIFTEEN AND A HALF
YEARS IN PRISON FOR A CRIME I
DID NOT COMMIT. HELLO MY CLOSER
I'M SORRY I SPENT FIFTEEN HAPPY
YEARS IN PRISON FOR A CRIME I
DID NOT COMMIT- BACK IN MARCH OF
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE I WAS A KID
IN SOUTH SIDE OF CHICAGO I WAS.
APPREHENDED TAKEN INTO CUSTODY
AND- THREATEN AND BASICALLY
PSYCHOLOGICALLY TORTURED INTO
SIGNING A CONFESSION. OF THE
SENATE CONFESSING TO A RAPE AND
THE MURDER OF SOMEONE WHOM I DID
NOT EVEN KNOW- GIVEN THE NATURE
OF THE OFFENSE THEY'RE RAPING
THEM IT WAS A RAPE OR SEXUAL
ASSAULT INVOLVED WE HAD
PRIMITIVE DNA TESTING. AND I WAS
I WAS EXCLUDED ALONG WITH MY
OTHER FOUR CO DEFENDANTS- WE ALL
SPENT A TOTAL OF MAYBE FORTY
SOMETHING YEARS IN PRISON TOTAL.
OF MAYBE FIFTY I BELIEVE TOTAL
FOR THIS. CRIME THAT WE DID NOT
COMMIT. MY STORY I MEAN I WAS A
KID- WAS ARRESTED YOU KNOW CALL
THE AUTHORITIES I HEARD THEY
WERE LOOKING FOR ME- GAVE THE
AUTHORITIES A CALL TOLD HIM
WHERE I WAS- WAS AT MY FATHER'S
HOUSE HAD THE OF. THE
AUTHORITIES COME VISIT ME- AND-
HAILED THEY THEY LAY SOME
PHOTOGRAPHS ON THE TABLE FOR
MEAN ACTUALLY DID I KNOW SOME
PEOPLE ON THESE PHOTOGRAPHS I
DID NOT KNOW THEM- ACTUALLY
ABOUT WILL BE WILLING TO COME TO
THE STATION I SAID YES. I DIDN'T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT- ACTS MY
FATHER IF THEY COULD BRING ME
THEY SAID. THEY SAID. IN A SAID
NO INITIALLY BUT THAT THAT MY
FATHER COULD CHORE BUT TRAIL
THEM THERE. AND THEY TOLD MY
FATHER THEY WOULD TAKE ME TO THE
POLICE STATION ONE FIFTY FIRST
AND WHEN WERE. I TOLD MY FATHER
HE WAS TAKING ME TO THE POLICE
STATION ONE THIRTY FOR THE LOW
AND TOOK ME TO A POLICE STATION
A FIFTY PERSON I WORK ON THE
SOUTH SIDE OF CHICAGO. AGAIN I
WAS TOLD THAT I WAS GONNA DIE IN
JAIL- I WAS NEVER GOING HOME. I
WOULD NEVER SEE MY FAMILY. AGAIN
AS A AS A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD KID
. YOU YOU PROCESS THAT RIGHT
THEY TELL YOU YOU'RE DYING IN
JAIL AND THEN H. O. U. AS DARK
AS ROOM PARDON MY FRENCH TO HAVE
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT RIGHT THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL TORTURE OF
BREAKING YOU DOWN AND THEN
OFFICER COME TO SAY HEY. I KNOW
YOU CAN DO IT THE OTHER GUY'S IS
SAYING YOU DID IT I MAKE YOU A
DEAL AND YOU CAN GO ON THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENED TO ME. THE NOW IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN THAT WAY I WAS I
WAS CONVICTED ON SOLELY ON THE
BASIS OF MY FALSE CONFESSION- IN
RECENT NINE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
I WAS RECENTLY EXONERATED. AND
SINCE THEN YOU KNOW I MEAN I CAN
GET MY TIME BACK YOU KNOW I CAN
GET MY FIFTEEN YEARS- BUT WHAT I
DO WANT TO DO IS STOP ANOTHER TO
WEAR ANOTHER TOUR ELSEWHERE WHEN
OTHER MICHAEL SAUNDERS ANOTHER
YOUNG MAN FROM EXPERIENCING THE
THINGS THAT WE WENT THROUGH FOR
SOMETHING THAT WE. WE DIDN'T GO
THROUGH I MEAN IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE DIDN'T DO- SO I'M- AS-
YOU KNOW AS- WAS STATED YOU KNOW
I WAS ABLE TO USE MY- YOU KNOW
TELL MY STORY. LAST YEAR IN
ILLINOIS WAS ABLE TO PASS THE
DECEPTION BILL. AND GET THAT
PASSED- TO THE FOOT YOU KNOW
IT'S TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWO
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO LIVE TO
KIDS TO GET. ANYTHING AREN'T WE
SHOULD HAVE TO LIE TO ANYONE- WE
HAVE SO MUCH TECHNOLOGY AND- SO
MANY THINGS THAT OUR HANDS THAT
WE COULD USE. THAT THESE TACTICS
THESE BARBARIC TACTICS I MEAN
SHOULD BE OUTLAWED. IT IS MY
MISSION AGAIN I'LL GO STATE TO
STATE OF I HAVE TO SHARE MY
STORY. BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE WITH
THERE'S NO REASON. FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO LIFE TO ANYONE TO
SOLVE CRIME. WE HAVE ENOUGH
TOOLS. WE HAVE AN UP THINGS AT
OUR DISPOSAL TO MAXIMIZE
EVERYTHING THAT WE NEED AND-
WANT I WANT TO. JUST TOUCH ON
SOMETHING REAL QUICK THAT MR
LACKEY SAID NOT TO. I'M YOU UP
YOU GOT BY ON. I'M PERSON
SPEAKING SO YOUR RAP UP
PARAMOUNT WHAT HE SAID ABOUT THE
- YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE
VICTIMS AS WELL. BECAUSE YOU'RE
LOCKING UP THE WRONG PEOPLE. YOU
OPENING UP THAT ONE FOR THEM AS
WELL AFTER FIFTEEN YEARS YOU
KNOW I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE VICTIM'S FAMILY MY FAMILY
EVERYONE THIS IS THE BIG DEAL.
THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE IN THE
HELP WE CAN HELP SO MANY
LIVESTOCK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME. THANK YOU THAT WAS
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WILL THE
PELOTA REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PROBATION
OFFICERS. ASK ME LOCALS SIX
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. AND THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY PROBATION OFFICES LOCAL.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND A I ASK
YOU A FEW STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. I DON'T NEED ANYTHING ELSE
MISS ARE THE AUTHOR I'M GONNA
COMMITTEE OUT THE FOR WORKING
WITH US. IN HE STATED OUR REASON
FOR SUPPORTING THE BILL THIS IS
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY AND IT WAS
NOTHING BETTER TODAY BUT TO BE
ABLE TO HEAR THIS YOUNG MAN.
TELL THE STORY WITHOUT WRONG
THINGS ARE HAPPENING TO PEOPLE
THAT LOOKS LIKE ME. SO WE ASK
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT. THIS BILL
WHEN THE BILL COMES UP THANK
YOU. MISS KARMA. YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE. HI THIS IS RICHARD
BROTHER ROGER. PRODUKTER YES- I
HAVE ONE MINUTE OKAY- I AM AN
APPELLATE ATTORNEY I'M CALLING
IN FROM IRELAND TODAY WERE PART
OWNERS GETTING MARRIED THAT MAY
SEEM STRANGE BUT MY CALLING LIKE
THE- IS BECAUSE I WITH THE
ATTORNEY FOR ALLIANZGI. I HAD TO
BE PRESENT TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR WHICH
MOST CRUCIALLY COOPER PROHIBITS
LAW ENFORCEMENT. USE OF
DECEPTION AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
MANIPULATIVE TACTICS KERNAN AND
KARAPETIAN YOU YOU HEARD FROM
CORRAL WE READ THE PAPERS WE
KNOW THAT ALL CONTESTANTS DO
OCCUR ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY
INVOLVE YOU. CASES LIKE THE
CENTRAL PARK FIVE ANOTHER HIGH
PROFILE EXONERATIONS RESULTING
FROM FALSE CONFESSIONS
INCREASINGLY REMINDED. OF. HELP
YOU. OUR OUR EXTRA VOTER TO
PSYCHOLOGICAL COOPER TECHNIQUE.
SOME OF THAT KNOW ABOUT THE
ALLIES U. K. MEANT THAT THANK IN
THE PUB SAFETY ANALYSIS.
INFRASTRUCTURE DENTIST EXPLAINS
DETAIL. HOW CYCLE MINUTES
TACTICS WENT ON. ARE AS COOL AT
THE DEGREE THE PROBLEM IS NOT
THE CAP TACK INSPECTED IF THE
GOAL IS. TO OKAY HE FELT AND
CRITICAL WORST OF TECHNIQUE ARE
TO AFFECT SO AFFECT THAT YOU CAN
IN DO CONFESS TO CRIME OR
IMPLICATE AND DESPITE BEING IN
HIGH IN A WE NEED A LICENSED IT
OF THE TECH CASE HUNDRED ALL OF
THE TECH WITH THE WILL BE. THIS
FENCIBLE DERIVED FROM CASE LAW
IT IS RECENTLY ENACTED ILLINOIS
WORKING THE ABOUT TWO THINGS
PROTECTING OUR PEOPLE WHO WORK
THE.
AND SECURES CONVICTION OF GUILTY
PERSON I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU ANY WITNESS
IN THE ROBERT IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. MARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MELISSA
O'CONNELL WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE PROJECT AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE LOYOLA
PROJECT FOR THE INNOCENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. A RED
WHIMS ACLU CAL ACTION IN SUPPORT
THANK. HOW WE CAN MELISSA
CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. GOING BACK IT'S
ALL BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT. THE MORNING
GREGORY FOR THAT WOULD INITIATE
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ANY TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINES WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND
JUST BECAUSE IN SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE NINETEEN.
IN MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. LINE SIXTY.
KIM LINDBERG FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NO OTHER LINES INTO
MISTER CHAIRMAN. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS. COURCELLES ALONE WE
HAVE A CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL FIRST
PEACE OFFICER CANDIDATES AND
PERSONS SERVING AS PEACE
OFFICERS ARE REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE INITIAL AND CONTINUING
EDUCATION ABOUT AND TRAINING
ABOUT MYRIAD TOPICS RELATED TO
THE LIVERY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
SERVICES. THE STANDARDS ARE
OVERSEEN BY POST COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING AND INSTEAD OF RELYING
ON POST STANDARDS AND GUIDELINES
DEVELOPED BY EXPERTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS BASED ON BEST
PRACTICE THIS BILL IMPOSES RIGID
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES FROM ONE
PERSPECTIVE AS TO HOW
INTERROGATIONS OF PERSONS AGED
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OR YOUNGER
SHOULD BE CONDUCTED. CERTAINLY
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE SITUATIONS
THAT PRESCRIBED BY THE PROPONENT
BUT I'M TRYING TO AVOID THOSE
THE BILL GOES TOO FAR- MANY OF
THE DEFINITIONS IN THE BILL ARE
UNCLEAR. AMBIGUOUS AND OTHERS
WILL PREVENT REASONABLE METHODS
OF INVESTIGATION. DOES QUOTE
UNQUOTE MAKING ACCUSATIONS
INCLUDE STATEMENTS RELATING
FACTS THAT ARE KNOWN TO BE TRUE
AND ARE NOT IN DISPUTE. CITING
EVIDENCE WOULD BE PRECLUDED IF
IT WERE DETERMINED THAT DOING SO
WAS QUOTE WOULD DEMONSTRATE THE
HOUSTON ALSO BE FUEL. IT'LL BE
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE WHAT'S
ALLOWABLE UNDER THIS BILL AND AS
A RESULT IT'S LIKELY IMPORTANT
INFORMATIONAL GO UNDISCOVERED OR
BE WITHHELD. IN VETOING SENATE
BILL FOUR NINETY FOUR LAST YEAR
THE GOVERNOR DIRECTED POST TO
DEVELOP TRAINING ON
INTERPERSONAL COMMUNICATION
SKILLS. AND ETHICAL SCIENCE
BASED INTERVIEWING SO FOR THAT
REASON AND THOSE PREVIOUSLY
STATED WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION THERE WERE VOTER
PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
. TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU CAN STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. HELLO FOR
THE LINES INTO MR CARE. THANK
YOU NOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MR BLACKETT. YEAH I
THINK THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS
VERY NOBLE AND I ADMIRE YOUNG
MAN. WHO CAME FORWARD AND I'M
VERY VERY SORRY THAT YOU HAD TO
PAY- A PRICE FOR SOMETHING YOU
DIDN'T DO. THAT'S COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE AND- IT SHOULD BE
REPUDIATED IN EVERY WAY HOWEVER
I ALSO THINK THAT. HAVING THEN
IN THE CAPACITY OF THESE
INTERROGATION CIRCUMSTANCES I
WILL TELL YOU THAT- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
MANY OF. THE OFFENDERS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERVIEW ARE VERY
AFRAID AND HAVE NO TRUST. A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SO SOME OF THE
TACTICS THAT ARE USED TO GET
PEOPLE TO NOT BE AFRAID. OF FALL
UNDER QUESTION AND I'D- I DO
THINK THAT IT IS IMPROPER.
PERSONALLY TO USE DECEPTION TO
TRY TO GET PEOPLE EVEN TO ADMIT
TO TRUTH BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT I DON'T THINK THE ENDS
JUSTIFIES THE MEANS- IN MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT I DO THINK
THAT THIS BILL UNFORTUNATELY
GOES TOO FAR. AND MAKE SOME
GENERALIZATIONS THAT I THINK ARE
UNREASONABLE TO THINK THAT. ALL
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE A DAHLE
JUDGEMENTAL THERE TWENTY SIX IS
TOO. UNREASONABLE I DON'T THINK
THAT'S A REASONABLE JUDGMENT I
KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME STUDIES
THAT SHOW THAT THERE'S SOME
DEVELOPMENTAL. CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT AREN'T REACHED UNTIL THAT
AGE HOWEVER I DO THINK THAT THE
BROAD POLICY OF NOT- RECOGNIZING
PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO USE ADULT
JUDGE UNTIL THEY'RE TWENTY SIX
IS UNREASONABLE- AND THAT'S JUST
OF. OPINION ON OF MINE BASED ON
EXPERIENCE. AND- RIGHT I THINK
THAT THERE ARE MANY MANY
COMMENDABLE PARTS OF THIS BILL
THAT- ARE. VERY SUPPORTABLE AND
I DO THINK THERE'S WORK TO BE
DONE. ON TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE
DON'T HAVE OUTCOMES LIKE THIS
POOR GENTLEMAN THAT CAME TO
TESTIFY TODAY BUT THIS BILL IS
NOT THE VEHICLE THAT- ADDRESSES
THE PROBLEMS APPROPRIATELY SO I
WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
UNFORTUNATELY BUT I WANT TO
EXPLAIN WHY. RESPOND TO. I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I
GREW UP IN NEW YORK CITY
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. WHEN THE
CENTRAL PARK FIVE WERE TAKEN
FROM US THEIR YOUTH WAS TAKEN
FROM US. AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY TO SHARE THE WAYS
IN WHICH OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. TOOK YOUR YOUTH AND YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY BE. A
YOUNG PERSON THERE IS A
PREPONDERANCE OF RESEARCH AND
EVIDENCE THAT DEMONSTRATES THAT
THE ADOLESCENT MINE IS ACTUALLY
STILL DEVELOPING UNTIL THEY'RE
TWENTY FIVE I ALSO HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH MANY
ADOLESCENTS. HAVE BEEN
QUESTIONED BY POLICE AND SEE THE
POWER DYNAMIC THAT HAPPENS- IN
THOSE IN THOSE SITUATIONS AND I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
FORWARD. THIS LEGISLATION LET
LEGISLATION WHICH WILL ALLOW
THAT INTERROGATION ROOM TO
ACTUALLY BE A PLACE WHERE. YOU
CAN BE PROTECTED AND HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE JUSTICE- IN
THOSE MOMENTS AS THEY ARE
DEALING WITH THAT AT A POWER
DYNAMIC- AND A SITUATIONAL
DYNAMIC IN TERMS OF THEIR OWN
DEVELOPMENTS THAT CAN BE LEVELED
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I WILL BE.
SUPPORTING THIS LEGISLATION.
YEAH COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
SURE YOU MAY CLOSE. AUTHORS
THANK YOU- I THINK THAT THE
TESTIMONY- PRETTY MUCH LAYS THE
PREDICATE FOR WHY IT'S NECESSARY
TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE AND TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS SCIENCE
THIS IS A SO OFTEN THAT I I'VE
BEEN COMMITTED INCIDENT HEARD
PRESENTATIONS ON BILLS IT SAID
WELL YOU KNOW THAT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I YOU JUST HAD SOME
DATA. TO SUPPORT WHY WE NEED TO
DO X. Y. AND Z. I DON'T THINK
THAT AS- NUMBER BONTA HAS
OUTLINED THERE'S BEEN A BILL
QUITE LIKE THIS IN TERMS OF DATA
THAT SUPPORTS SCIENTIFICALLY. V.
THE DEVELOPMENTAL STATUS OF A
YOUNG PERSON'S BRAIN AND NOT
JUST THE BRAIN WHICH IS HOW THEY
INTERACT IN SOCIETY AND HOW
THEIR MOTIONAL. DYNAMICS ARE
STILL COMING TOGETHER AND I
THINK THAT THAT. WE ALSO GONNA
TRY ON ALL THESE BILLS I TRY
VERY HARD TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
HOW. OF MUCH OF VALUE WORKING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND HOW I
WORK WITH THEM EARLY. AND AS WAS
PRESENTED OF THE PROVISION
OFFICERS RECOGNIZE THAT BUT THEY
WERE THE ONLY ONES THAT WE WERE
WORKING WITH WORK WITH ALL OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO TAKE INPUT
EARLY IN THIS BILL. AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE REFLECTING
SOME OF THE REAL CONCERNS THAT
THEY WERE DESCRIBING. AND AS IT
RELATES TO POST- TRAINING IS
ONGOING. AND WE WORK WITH POST
ON THIS BILL. SO THAT WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THE DYNAMICS OF HOW-
WITH THE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THE BILL AND WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT- THE
TRAINING CONTINUE TO REFLECT THE
NEW INFORMATION NEW SCIENCE A
NEW DIRECTION THAT WE THINK WE
NEED TO ADDRESS AND EMBRACE. IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND WHEN THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN AN ENVIRONMENT-
LIKE THIS THAT THEY ARE.
PROTECTED AND THAT- THEY'RE NOT
PUT IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY-
CAN SAY SOMETHING OR DO
SOMETHING THAT. WHAT HUNDRED OF
A CRIME TO THE DO. SO WELL OUR-
ASK RIVAL. THE MOTION MOTION
WITH THE BILL. SECOND YOU HAVE A
MOTION IS SECOND CALL FROM QUEST
. AN EIGHTY TWO SIX FORTY BASED
MEMBER HOLDEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY LACKEY NO BONTA.
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN I WORK.
SANTIAGO SEYARTO. THE MEASURES
LOCAL. THANK WITH WITH. OKAY IN
THE ROLE YOU MAY CONTINUE WITH
AB- TWO SEVEN SEVEN THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO- LET THE
COMMITTEE KNOW THAT I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THEIR
AMENDMENTS THAT I LIKE TO THINK
THAT YOU'RE IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND CONSULTANT FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF AND SUPPORTERS TO
ADDRESS. SOME OF THE CHAIRS
CONCERNS A TODAY I'M PRESENTED
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY THREE
THE BILL THEY WERE REQUIRE PEACE
OFFICER MAKING A TRAFFIC OR
PEDESTRIANS STOP TO STATE THE
REASON FOR THE STOP BEFORE
ASKING ANY QUESTIONS UNLESS THE
OFFICER REASONABLY BELIEVES.
THAT WITHHOLDING THE REASON FOR
THE STOP IS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
LIFE OR PROPERTY OR A THREAT.
MEMBERS FOR NEARLY A YEAR MY
OFFICE AGAIN HAS WORKED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT POST VARIOUS
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY CONSULTANTS HERE
IN THE SIMPLY AS WELL AS THE
SENATE. TO PUT FOR THOUGHTFUL
LEGISLATION SURROUNDING TRAFFIC
AND- PEDESTRIAN STOPS OVER THE
PAST YEAR THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS IN DEPTH REPORTS
SURROUNDING TRAFFIC STOPS TO
INCLUDE INVESTIGATIONS FROM THE
NEW YORK TIMES. THE LA TIMES. IN
A REPORT FROM THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE. THE COMMON THEME
SURROUNDING THESE REPORTS IS
THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR MORE SO FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE STOPPED THAN WHITE
INDIVIDUALS. WHAT IS MORE
TROUBLING IS THAT ACCORDING TO
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE
STOPS OF AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
INVOLVE A WEAPON THEN STOPS THE
WHITE INDIVIDUALS. WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. POST
IN AB AB TWO SEVENTY THREE
REQUIRES LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO DOCUMENT THE REASON
FOR THE STOP ON ANY CITATION OR
POLICE REPORT RESULTING FROM THE
STOP. IN TERMS OF EDUCATING THE
PUBLIC THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DMV TO INCLUDE INFORMATION
REGARDING THE DUTY TO OF A PEACE
OFFICER TO STATE THE REASON FOR
THE STOP IN THE DMV HANDBOOK AT
THE EARLIEST OPPORTUNITY. AS YOU
MAY RECALL THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED AND GOVERNOR ROWN
SIGNED MY BILL AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WHICH NOW REQUIRES A
DMV TO INCLUDE INFORMATION
REGARDING PERSONS CIVIL RIGHTS
DURING A STOP. INCLUDING THE
RIGHT TO FILE A COMPLAINT
AGAINST THE PEACE OFFICER.
FINALLY THIS BILL MAKES FAILURE
TO STATE THE REASON FOR THE STOP
PROJECT GROUNDS FOR STATUTORY
MOTION TO SUPPRESS. I AM AWARE
THAT THIS PARTICULAR PROVISION
OF THE BILL IS CAUSING SOME
CONCERN. FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PLEDGED TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM AS WELL AS THIS COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT. TO SEE IF WE CAN
FIND AN ALTERNATIVE WAY TO HOLD
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR FAILURE TO
DISCLOSE THE REASON FOR THE
STOP. IN CLOSING MEMBERS LIKE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS- TO FIND A SOLUTION
TO THIS TROUBLING PROBLEM. AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE I BELIEVE THAT
THE CONFRONTATION BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE PUBLIC BEGINS
BECAUSE PEOPLE OF COLOR BEING
ASKED TO SURRENDER THEIR CIVIL
RIGHTS AND DON'T EVEN KNOW WHY
THEY WERE BEING STOPPED. BUT
THEY ARE FORCED TO COMPLY.
SURELY THIS BODY CAN FIND A
SOLUTION TO THIS DILEMMA. THIS
BILL IS MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY KAITLIN DEAN HEY C. O. U.
CALIFORNIA ACTION LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE. AND CHRIS LAWSON
ADVOCATE COALITION FOR JUST AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AT&T
OPERATOR IF WE COULD- HELLO-
KALING DEAN FROM ACLU. THE
MORNING CARE NUMBERS CAME IN
BELOW LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
A STRONG MOVE CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SEVEN SEVEN THREE. IN THE
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO RECALL
REPORT RELEASED BY THE RACIAL
AND IDENTITY ADVISORY BOARD WE
COLLECTED AND ANALYZED STOCKTON
EIGHTEEN MARCOS AGENTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY. PLEASE AGENCIES OVER TWO
NINE MILLION STOCK. BLACK PEOPLE
WERE STOP FOR A REASON SUSPICION
MORE THAN ANY RACIAL IDENTITY
GROUP. OFFICERS THIRD THE POND
ON THE CURB IN EQUITY CAR.
IMPROPER AND REMOVE FROM THE-
MORE INTO THE PAPERS TO BLACK
INDIVIDUAL CRISTINA AS WHITE.
BLACK AND IN THE ONE ONE LIKE TO
HAVE YOU TO AGAINST THEM
COMPARED TO WHITE INTO THE-
THESE FINDINGS ARE TRUMP. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THEY CONSERVE WITH
THE RED RECORDS FROM YOU MY
UNCLE. AS WELL AS FOR THE
STANFORD OPENED PROJECT THE NEW
YORK. STANDING UNION. INSTEAD
ACTORS. IN MOST INSTANCES THE
CONGREGATE BETWEEN. ONE AND LOOK
. BEGINS WORKING OF COLOR ARE
NOT APPOINTED QUICKLY OF WHY
THEY WERE PULLED OVER OR STOPPED
FROM. THERE WERE AND. IN THE-
PEOPLE OF COLOR TO COMPLY WITH
THE SITUATION QUICKLY. SOMETHING
RESULT AND LYFT DR. STAND BLAND
PHILANDO. WHAT STOCK DANTE RIGHT
AND GRAY SHORT BOOK FOR ALL
BLACK AND STILL THEM DURING
ORDINARY STOPS THE VIOLATION
THAT DO NOT PLAY PUBLIC SAFETY.
IT IS WONDER THAT PEOPLE CAN
MURDER AT AND SHEER AFTER BEING
STOCK BY AN ALL. WHO CAN THEM OF
THE ON THE. I WOULD POLICE
OFFICER TO STATE THE REASON FOR
TRAFFIC CONTEST STOP AT THE TIME
OF THE STOCK BEFORE ASKING ANY.
COULD LITERALLY SAVE LIVES IF
BILL IS BECAUSE SENSE AND ONE OF
ITS FRANKLY LAW OVERDUE. I
RESPECTFULLY YOU TO EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN THREE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY WE'RE READY TO LISTEN
TO- CHRIS. LUNCHEON TWENTY CAN
YOU HEAR. YES YOU MAY. YOU OPEN
THE DOOR NOW YOU'RE GOING TO GET
. AND OUT OF THE WINDOW NOW WE
WILL BE SHOT. I'M GOING TO SHOOT
YOU WERE PART OF THAT DON'T YOU
WANT. I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU
WHY I PULLED YOU OVER. ALL YOU
OVER BECAUSE I CAN'T. GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE CHANCE TO SPEAK IT
URGES SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE MY NAME IS
CHRIS WATSON WITH THE COALITION
FOR JUST AND EQUITABLE
CALIFORNIA. THE STATEMENT I
THOUGHT OF MY TESTIMONY WITH OUR
STATE SPOKE ABOUT OF THE LAW IN
OF DURING TRAFFIC STOP THE FIRST
IT WAS SPOKEN SENATE VENUE AND
WERE. THE SECOND THE MARVIN BIRD
BEING THE J. HARTSFIELD AND
ALLOW TWO WAS BOTH TO MEET
TRAGICALLY THE VENUE MARVIN IN
GENERAL ALL KILLED BY THOSE
OFFICERS DURING STOPS I THINK MY
CONDOLENCE TO THEIR FOR. AND MAY
THEY REST IN PEACE ALL RIGHT BY
THE BLESSING THE GRACE OF GOD
I'M ALIVE TO DAY AS AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WITH A SENSE IMPORTANT
INSULATE IN THIS COUNTRY I KNOW
THAT AT ANY TIME I CAN BE
STOPPED WHILE DRIVING QUESTION
SIR I HAVE MY RIGHTS VIOLATED
WITH LITTLE EFFECTIVE RECOURSE.
IT WAS DONE TIME AND TIME AGAIN
TO MY ANSWERS BEFORE THE END OF
SLAVERY AND DURING JIM CROW AND
I KNOW THAT IT'S NOT JUST
BECAUSE I'M BLACK IF BECAUSE OF
WHAT BEING BLACK MEANS IN THIS
COUNTRY. BEING BLACK MEANS YOU
HAVE NO POWER AND NO RIGHT THAT
CAN'T BE VIOLATED. NOT BECAUSE
OF THE COLOROF MY SKIN ONLY BUT
BECAUSE OF MY CONNECTION TO
INSULATE ANCESTORS IN THIS
COUNTRY IN SHORT NOT BECAUSE OF
WHO I AM BUT BECAUSE OF WHAT
COME FROM. OF COURSE THOSE
OFFICER DIDN'T ASK IF I WAS THE
DESIGN OF US NAVY BEFORE THEY
STOP ME BUT DIDN'T HAVE TO BASED
ON MY BACK AGAIN AND IT NEARLY
MADE CONNECTION U. S. WITH.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE TOLD ME I
STOPPED YOU BECAUSE I CAN LOOK.
MARVIN AND J. WERE WERE FEATURED
IN EVERY NEW YORK TIMES THANK
ONE DAY TRAFFIC STOPS ACCORDING
TO THE PROSECUTORS THESE CASE K.
QUESTION WHETHER THE STOP WOULD
HAVE ENDED THEIR IF BOXER HAD
EXT TO THE- WHY WERE ORDERING
THEM TO THE CAR IN THE FIRST
PLACE AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN
WOULD REQUIRE A PEACE OFFICER
MAKING A TRAFFIC OR PEDESTRIAN
STOP BEFORE ASKING ANY QUESTIONS
THE STATE. THE REASON FOR THE
STOP THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THE OF THE TO DOCUMENT THE
REASON FOR THE STOP THIS IS
COMMON SENSE AND GOOD FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY MEMBERS. AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE IS COMMONSENSE AND
GO. FOR POP. SAFETY TO THE
RIGHT. TO DATE. YES ONE AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY. THANK THANK
YOU. K. YOU HAVE ANY OTHER ON
THE ROAD THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXT
OUR SO FOR THIS. PLEASE GO
FORWARD. MAR CHORE ON BEHALF OF
THE K. PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GREGORY PUT OUT WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOING BACK A CELL BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. OKAY DO WE HAVE- ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YOU
MAKE A FORWARD.
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN WRIST CORSAGE
ALONG BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
AGAIN- RESPECTFULLY BUT
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL WHEN A PEACE OFFICER
INITIATES A STOP THERE ARE MANY
VARIABLES THAT MUST BE
CONSIDERED AN INFORMATION THAT
SHOULD BE GATHERED TRAFFIC STOP
CAN BE AMONG THE MOST DANGEROUS
TYPES OF INTERACTIONS THAT PEACE
OFFICERS ENCOUNTER SOMETHING THE
CHERNOW'S OR WELL. AND OFTEN
MAKES SENSE FOR AN OFFICER TO
SEEK AND OBTAIN ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF A CONTACT THIS CAN
BE VITAL IN ASSESSING THE RISK
EMANATING FROM THE STOP AND
PEACE OFFICERS ARE TRAINED
DETERMINING RISKS SURROUNDING
THE TRAFFIC STOP IS A KEY
CONSIDERATION. THE BILL'S
LIMITATION IS SO STRICT IN FACT
. IT PROHIBITS AN OFFICER FOR
ASKING A PERSON'S IDENTIFICATION
OR EVEN ASKING A PERSON TO TURN
OFF THE VEHICLE'S IGNITION PRIOR
TO DISCLOSING THE REASON FOR THE
STOP. ANY QUESTION. OBTAINING
MORE INFORMATION FROM THE
SUBJECT THE STOP IS VITAL TO
PROTECTING EVERYONE'S SAFETY.
AND THE BILL'S EXCEPTION BASED
ON A QUOTE UNQUOTE IMMINENT
THREAT IS NOT ENOUGH TO ADDRESS
ALL THESE SITUATIONS THAT ARE
IMBUED WITH RISK. FURTHER THE
BILL'S PROVISION THAT A FAILURE
TO TELL THE PERSON THE REASON
FOR THE STOP BEFORE ASKING FOR-
ANY QUESTIONS IS GROUNDS FOR
FILING A MOTION TO SUPPRESS AND
COULD IT. COULD END UP
ULTIMATELY KEEPING CRUCIAL
INFORMATION FROM A JUDGE OR
JURY. IF THERE'S CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY DISCOVERED DURING THE
STOP. THE CONFESSION TO A
MURDER. GIVEN BY THE SUBJECT OF
A TRAFFIC STOP AFTER THE PERSON
HAS BEEN PROPERLY MORAN DIES.
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO A MOTION TO
SUPPRESS UNDER THIS BILL IF THE
PEACE OFFICER STARTED TO STOP
WITH THE QUESTION. ANY QUESTION.
BEFORE STATE REASON FOR THE STOP
. THIS LANGUAGE CREATES THE VERY
REAL POSSIBILITY OF VAST
MISCARRIAGES OF JUSTICE BASED ON
THE SIMPLE TIMING OF AN OFFICER
ASKING IF THEY MAY SEE THE
PERSON'S IDENTIFICATION BEFORE
TELLING THE PERSON WHY THEY WERE
STOPPED. WITH THIS BILL APPEARS
TO BE BASED ON THE NOTION THAT
THE CHRONOLOGICAL ORDER IN WHICH
THE INTERACTION DEVELOPS- WILL
CHANGE THINGS BUT THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE OF THAT. BUT THE
GUARANTEE THAT DOES EXIST IS IF
YOU ASK A PERSON AS AN OFFICER.
TO TURN THE RADIO DOWN OR TO
TURN OFF THE IGNITION OR TO ROLL
DOWN A WINDOW. BEFORE SAYING I
STOP YOU BECAUSE YOU HAVE A TAIL
LIGHT OUT. THAN ANY EVIDENCE
THAT'S DISCOVERED AFTER THAT
FACT. IS SUBJECT TO A MOTION TO
SUPPRESS AND MAY NOT ULTIMATELY
BE ALLOWED IN COURT IF THERE'S
OF PROCEEDING. AFTER THE FACT SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU KNOW VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHERS IN THE ROOM TO
ELECTRICS PRESSURE OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE OPERATOR CAN WE GO
TO THE PHONE LINES AND ASK FOR
ANYONE WHO HAS A SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO EXPRESS THAT
OPINION. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE NINETEEN. A GOOD MORNING
REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK. NINE SIXTY
NINE. OKAY YET THIS IS HENRY
WITHOUT SIMILAR SACRAMENTO.
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY. HI YEAH
HE COULD A RESIDENT WITH BROKEN
PRIVACY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY SAYING
NO FOR ENGAGEMENT YOU MAY CLOSER
. THANK YOU I CERTAINLY DO
APPRECIATE AGAIN THE COMMITTEE
WORKING WITH A SONG ON THIS BILL
I DO ALSO APPRECIATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT POST- CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL WHO WAS VERY
INTEGRAL IN TERMS OF LAYING OUT
THE STRUCTURE OF HOW WITH
TECHNICAL INPUT- TO THE BILL SO
WE WEREN'T FLYING SOLO- WE HAD-
PARTICIPATION ALONG THE WAY AND
CONTINUE TO REACH OUT AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE. CONVERSATIONS
BUT I GUESS AS I THINK ABOUT
WHAT WORKS IN THE REAL WORLD-
I'M DRIVING A CAR AND I SEE THE
LIGHTS AND I'M NEED TO PULL OVER
THE FIRST QUESTION IN MY MIND IS
WHY. WHY AM I BEING PULLED OVER
. AND SO I'M GONNA EXPECT WHEN
THE OFFICER APPROACHES- HI I'M
GOING TO NO I'M NOT STE THERE'S
ALWAYS SOME MARGIN OF FOLKS OUT
THERE WHO MAY DO SOMETHING A
LITTLE DIFFERENT BUT- I'M A LET
THE WINDOW DOWN. AND I'M
EXPECTING THE OFFICER TO TELL ME
WHY. I'VE BEEN PULLED OVER.
THAT'S THE FIRST THING I'M
LOOKING TO HEAR. AND SO I THINK
THAT WHEN WE WENT AND I THINK
THAT ON ALL OF THESE EFFORTS
HERE'S DESIGNED TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD TRUST BUILD. A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PUBLIC
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT IS
SUSTAINING. IT SORT OF TURNS THE
TIDE. I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU.
THAT HIGHWAY PATROLS LIKE THE
GOLD STANDARD. JUST IN TERMS OF
HOW JUST MY INTERACTION WITH
THEM IN RECENT TIMES. THAT THEY
PRETTY MUCH NINETY SOME ODD
PERCENT. ONCE THEY HAVE THAT
INITIAL ENCOUNTER THEY GIVE A
WARNING. AND THE PERSON DRIVES
OFF. AND SO AS I'M HEARING THEIR
STORY. I'M THINKING WELL OKAY IT
WORKS IT CAN WORK FOR ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WORKS FOR CHP. IT
WORK FOR EVERYONE. WE RECOGNIZE
A SAID IN MY STATEMENT THAT. THE
LANGUAGE AROUND- EVIDENCE BEING
SUPPRESSED WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THAT WITH NOWLEDGE THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME AREAS THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
WERE PREPARED TO DO THAT- BUT I
THINK IT'S A RIGHTEOUS BILL I
THINK IT INCLUDES BECAUSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS WITH US. EARLY
AT THE TABLE. THEIR FINGERPRINTS
THEIR THOUGHTS THEIR IMPRESSIONS
ARE ON THIS BILL. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR HOLDEN AYE AND I WOULD
JUST ADD REAL QUICKLY THAT- I
WAS TRAINED THAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO ADDRESS THE
PUBLIC AND- YOU MENTION AN
AGENCY I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THAT- THAT IS OUR STANDARD
HOWEVER I DO BELIEVE THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATE THIS POINT IS STILL
TOO RIGID. AND I THINK IT HAS
ASPECTS OF HER VERY VERY
SUPPORTABLE MOST OF IT IS VERY
SUPPORTABLE BUT I WISH THAT AND
I HOPE THAT AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD THAT THEY'LL BE SOME
CONTINUAL- WORK THAT I'LL GET TO
THE POINT WHERE I CAN SUPPORT OF
AT THIS POINT I'M NOT THERE SO.
WE HAVE A MOTION THE SECOND
MOVED BACK. OKAY WILL CALL FOR
THE- I AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN
THREE BY SEPTEMBER HOLDEN THEM
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER LACKEY. LACKEY NO BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN AYE WORK I
WORK I SANTIAGO. SEYARTO THE-
AT. BILLS IN CONGRESS TO MORE
REGULAR THANK YOU. YOU MIGHT SAY
MEMBER MATHIS. ONE OF THE BILL.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. H.
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN
I BELIEVE RIGHT AWAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- WE ARE HERE TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS KELSEY'S LAW. OR FIRST
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON FOR
JOINT AUTHORING AND JOINING ME
TODAY. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COOLEY
DAVIES FLORA LACK CERRADO AS
WELL AS SENATOR. GROF FOR CO
AUTHORING AND SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. THE BILL IS NAMED KELSEY
AFTER KELSEY WHO IS HERE TODAY
WITH HER MOTHER WHEN YOU BAKER.
SO POINTS OF CLARIFICATION ON
THIS BILL I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT. THAT WE DO CLARIFY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. AND SOME OF
THE CONTEXT. THAT WE HAVE THIS
BILLS DESIGNED TO PROTECT PEOPLE
LIKE KELSEY. FROM PHYSICAL AND
SEXUAL ABUSE. DURING A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION THE HEARSAY RULE.
STATES THAT A STATEMENT WHICH
WAS MADE OTHER THAN BY THE
WITNESS WHILE TESTIFYING AT A
HEARING IS INADMISSIBLE IN COURT
. CURRENTLY LAW ALSO ALLOWS THAT
IF THE VICTIM. AND ONLY THE
VICTIM OF CHILD ABUSE IS UNDER
TWELVE YEARS OF AGE THEY ARE
EXEMPTS FROM. THE HEARSAY RULE.
THIS BILL WOULD GRANT MINORS
WITH AN INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
WHO ARE THE VICTIM OF ABUSE
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN TO
ALSO BE EXEMPT FROM HERE SEVERAL. DEFINITION OF ABUSE. AGAIN FOR
THE SAKE OF CLARITY IN THE
HEARSAY EXEMPTION RELATES TO
CHILD ABUSE WHICH INCLUDES UNDER
PENAL CODE ONE ONE ONE SIX FIVE
POINT ONE. ONE PENETRATION
HOWEVER SLIGHTLY OF THE VAGINAL
OR OPENING OF ONE PERSON BY THE
**** OR ANOTHER PERSON'S.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS THE
EMISSION OF SEMEN TO SEXUAL
CONTACT BETWEEN THE GENITALS OR
IN A OPENING OF ONE PERSON IN
THE MOUTH OR TONGUE OF ANOTHER.
THREE INTRUSION BY ONE PERSON
INTO THE GENITALS. OR IN A
OPENING OF ANOTHER PERSON
INCLUDING THE USE OF AN OBJECT
FOR THIS PURPOSE EXCEPT THAT IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE ACTS PERFORMED
FOR A VALID MEDICAL PURPOSE FOR
THE INTENTIONAL TOUCHING OF
THEIR GENITALS. OR INTIMATE
PARTS INCLUDING THE BREAST
GENITALIA AREA. GROWING INNER
THIGHS AND BUTTOCKS OR THE
CLOTHING COVERING THEM OF A
CHILD OR OF THE PERPETRATOR BY
EACH CHILD FOR PURPOSES OF
SEXUAL AROUSAL. OR
GRATIFICATION. EXCEPT THAT IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE ACTS WHICH MAY
REASONABLY BE CONSTRUED TO BE
NORMAL CARETAKER
RESPONSIBILITIES INTERACTIONS
WITH OR DEMONSTRATIONS OF
AFFECTION FOR THE CHILD OR ACTS
PERFORMED FOR A VALID MEDICAL
PURPOSE. FIVE THE INTENTIONAL
MASTURBATION OF THE PERPETRATORS
D'ITALIA'S. IN THE PRESENCE OF A
CHILD. MEMBERS I AM
UNCOMFORTABLE EVEN READING THAT
. JUST THE READING THE SECTION
CODE. AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
WE CAN EXPECT A CHILD WITH AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY TO BE
CROSS EXAMINED OVER SUCH
HORRIFIC EVENTS. NOW LET'S LOOK
AT THE EVIDENCE. AND DATA FROM A
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REPORT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOUND
. THAT PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
WERE VICTIMS OF 26% OF ALL
NONFATAL VIOLENT CRIME WHILE
COUNTING FOR ABOUT 12% OF THE
POPULATION. THE RATE OF VIOLENT
VICTIMIZATION AGAINST PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES FORTY SIX
POINT TWO PER ONE THOUSAND AGE
TWELVE OR OLDER WAS ALMOST FOUR
TIMES THE RATE FOR PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES TWELVE POINT THREE
PER ONE THOUSAND. PERSONS WITH
COGNITIVE DISABILITIES HAD THE
HIGHEST RATE OF VIOLENT
VICTIMIZATION. EIGHTY THREE
POINT THREE PER ONE THOUSAND
AMONG THE DISABILITY TYPES
MEASURE. ONLY 9% OF RAPES OR
SEXUAL ASSAULTS AGAINST PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES WERE REPORTED
TO THE POLICE COMPARED 236% OF
THOSE AGAINST PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE COMMITTEE CONCERNS. IN MY
TEAM HAS BEEN WORKING. TRYING TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE WE'VE
EVEN TAKEN COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE OPPOSED THAT WERE
BROUGHT FORWARD BY ARCA TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS AND
I'M ALWAYS HAPPY TO REFUND ANY
CONCERNS OR AMENDMENTS MOVING
FORWARD THE AMENDMENT THAT IS IN
PRINT- WITH THE BILL THAT WE DID
TAKE FROM OUR COACHES FOR THE
RECORD- CHANGES. SECTION B. AND
WHAT THE STATUS IS OVER TWELVE
YEARS OF AGE AND THE COURT
DETERMINES THE VICTIM HAS EIGHT
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY. MEMBERS
WE HAVE GATHERED OVER. A HUNDRED
LETTERS IN SUPPORT. FROM
INDIVIDUALS FOR THIS MEASURE.
THIS MEASURES RECEIVE SUPPORT
FROM PORAC THE DA'S ARE CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY REGIONAL CENTER. IN
CONCLUSION. THE EXEMPTION OF THE
HEARSAY RULE GROUNDED BY AB
TWENTY SEVENTEEN- KELSEY'S LAW.
FOR THOSE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES TO DEVELOPS UPON
ESTABLISH PRE EXISTING LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS AND GRANTS THE
COURTS THE NECESSARY FLEXIBILITY
TO PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
AT RISK MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY.
THE CRIMINAL COURT PROCESS IS IN
PLACE TO PROTECT THOSE IN NEED
AND BY FAILING TO PASS AB TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE ARE FAILING THOSE
VICTIMS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES AND SHOWING THEM
THAT THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THOSE
DISABILITIES AND GRANTING THE
COURTS THE APPROPRIATE
DISCRETION FROM AB TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IS A CRUCIAL STEP TO
ADDRESSING A SYSTEMATIC ISSUE
AND STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA'S
COURT PROCEEDINGS. FOR THOSE
WITH DISABILITIES AB TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ALLOWS A MORE
INCLUSIVE FAIR AND EQUITABLE
APPROACH. FOR THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES TO BE ADOPTED THE
MEASURE ENSURES THAT THE
PERPETRATORS OF ABUSE ARE
BROUGHT TO JUSTICE IN THAT THOSE
VICTIMS WITH DISABILITIES ARE
NOT EXCLUDED OR OVERLOOKED. AS A
FATHER WITH A SON WITH ELECTION
BILL THESE. I KNOW FIRST HAND
THE DIFFICULTIES THAT INTERVALS
HAVE TO OVERCOME ON A DAILY
BASIS THE DAILY STRUGGLES THAT
THESE CHILDREN HAVE TO GO
THROUGH. IN MEMBERS I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY ON KELSEY'S LAW
AB. TEN SEVENTEEN. ON THE OTHER
HAND IT OVER TO MR GRAYSON AND
THEN TO MISS WHEN YOU BAKER THE
MOTHER OF KELSEY AND I BELIEVE
WE HAVE ERICA GONZALES WITH THE
DA ASSOCIATION ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND-
TWO MEMBERS THANK YOU- FOR THE
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THIS BILL
AND FOR STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON
IT. WHEN I HEARD ABOUT AB TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND WHAT IT DOES IT
TAPPED INTO A PASSION OF MINE.
AND IT WAS BECAME JUST A NATURAL
RESPONSE ON MY PART TO WANT TO
SUPPORT IT- TO THE EXTENT OF
BECOMING A JOINT AUTHOR. THE
REASON WHY IS BECAUSE THIS BILL
EXPANDS THE EXCEPTION OF THE
HEARSAY RULE FOR STATEMENTS THAT
ARE MADE BY A CHILD. UNDER
TWELVE YEARS OF AGE DESCRIBING
CHILD ABUSE AND AS UNCOMFORTABLE
AS THAT WAS TO HEAR THE LANGUAGE
FROM THE CODE SECTION. THAT'S
WHAT THEY WOULD BE EXPOSED TO
TO ALSO INCLUDE. A PERSON WITH
AN INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY UNDER
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN. WHEN
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES BECOME INVOLVED IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AS
VICTIMS SUSPECTS DEPENDENCE.
THEY DO FACE FEAR THEY FACE
PREJUDICE THEY ALSO FACE A LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING. IN FACT THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITH IDT ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO BE
VICTIMIZED. AT LEAST TWO TIMES
MORE LIKELY FOR VIOLENT CRIMES
IN FOUR TO TEN TIMES FOR ABUSE
AND OTHER CRIMES HOWEVER. THE
ADVERSARIAL NATURE OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM MAKES
MANY FOLKS LESS LIKELY TO SEEK
JUSTICE. AT LEAST ON THEIR OWN
BEHALF. PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
OR DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES HAVE
THE RIGHT TO JUSTICE THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO FAIR TREATMENT. TO
ALL AREAS IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND MUST BE
AFFORDED THE SUPPORTS. AND BUT
ATIONS REQUIRED TO MAKE JUSTICE
AND TO MAKE FAIR TREATMENT A
REALITY FOR THEM IN THEIR LIFE.
THIS IS A HUGE STEP FORWARD. IN
ENHANCING FAIRNESS IT'S A HUGE
STEP FORWARD IN PROTECTING
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES. AND BY ALLOWING
PEOPLE WITH I. D. D. UNDER
EIGHTEEN TO ALSO BE EXEMPT. FROM
THE HEARSAY RULE WE CAN MEET THE
NEEDS OF PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. AND
WE CAN ENSURE THAT ALL
INDIVIDUALS HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. IF YOU ARE
CLOSELY ENGAGED WITH THE IT D.
COMMUNITY. THEN IT WOULD BE EASY
FOR YOU TO CLEARLY UNDERSTAND
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL. HAVING
GROWN UP IN A HOME. WITH A
MEMBER OF THE IDT COMMUNITY HER
NAME IS SHERRY. ONE OF THE
SWEETEST MOST AWESOME PEOPLE I
KNOW. MY SISTER. AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE AT THE AGE OF THIRTY
. WOULD NOT HAVE QUALIFIED TO
HAVE THE MENTAL CAPACITY OF A
TWELVE YEAR OLD. SHE HAS DOWN
SYNDROME AND A MORE SEVERE WAY
BUT SHE HAS BEEN ON THE FLOOR
THIS BODY AND HAS MET SOME OF
YOU. AND ADVOCATED FOR US
SPECIAL OLYMPICS SHERRY WOULD
NOT HAVE THAT MENTAL CAPACITY TO
BE EXPOSED TO THAT KIND OF
LANGUAGE. IN A COURT OF LAW AS
TESTIFIED BY A COMMITTEE MEMBER
IN THIS COMMITTEE. EVEN AT THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE COGNITIVE
ABILITIES ARE STILL DEVELOPING.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD
CONSIDER FOR WHAT WE CALL IN
SOCIETY A NORMAL PERSON HOW MUCH
MORE IS IT LATER AND STRESSED
FOR SOMEONE OF THE IDT COMMUNITY
I PLEAD WITH 
THE TIME COMES. THAT YOU. THE
CHIU OF VOTING SO. IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BUT REALLY THE TO VOTE
IN SUPPORT OF MEMBERS OF THE IDT
COMMUNITY. THAT NEED YOUR
PROTECTION. COULD YOU GO PROCEED
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS- MY
NAME'S BAKER I'M HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVENTEEN KELSEY'S STARK. KELSEY. FOR SO LAST YEAR AND MORE. BUT
HUNDRED CAME TO ME AND WE HER.
EXIT LAW. CHIU UNDER THE CARE OF
THE AND ONE QUICK TOUCH PROBE
REPLETE. SHE'S TWENTY. AND BRICK
DIDN'T HER MENTAL. TO COPE UP
WITH THE DETAILS DID THE PLEA
OFFICER IN OUR CAR INTERVIEW. NO
WE SHE COULD T. V. THAT SHE
COULD HAVE MADE IT. LIKE IF
THERE'S NO WAY POSH AND THE
DETECTIVES ME WHAT SHE SAID I
THINK IT'S TO HEAR THE INTERVIEW
BUT IF IT BEEN WOULD HAVE BEEN A
TO BE USED IN THE COURT OF LAW
LIKE IT DEFINITELY WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN HER. FURTHER IF WE
WOULD'VE HAD ENOUGH PHYSICAL
EVIDENCE. BUT I DO THINK THAT
BEING THAT SHE IS TWENTY FIVE
AND MENTALLY SHE'S HM NEVER GROW
PAST BEING THE EIGHT YEAR OLD
AND SHE COLORS YOU COULD SPELL
CAT AND DOG.  MEAN THAT'S ABOUT
AS FAR AS SHE SHOULD UNDERSTAND
MONEY SO FOR YOU GUYS IF YOU
GUYS WOULD BE WILLING TO SUPPORT
THIS I MEAN I JUST COULDN'T SEE
PUTTING HER ON THE STAND EVEN IF
I KNOW IT WON'T HELP OUR CASE
AND I GET THAT. BUT IF I COULD
CHANGE IT FOR OTHER PEOPLE AND
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
WHAT WE HAVE. WITH I MEAN TO GO
TO HAPPY TRAILS IS LIKE A HORSE
RIGHT. PAYER I MEAN ANYTHING TO
HELP HER GET. THIS AND IS A MOM
. I FIT ROCK BOTTOM. A LOOK AT.
AND DO TO FIGURE OUT HOW I CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE I CAN'T HELP
HER KEEP HER PROTECTED OR LIKE
HOW GOING TO HELP OTHER PEOPLE I
MEAN ALL THE EARS I WORKED ON
THE AMBULANCE THAT'S WHAT I DID
I HELP PEOPLE I DIDN'T KNOW SO
THIS IS KIND OF ANOTHER BRANCH
LIKE HOW CAN I HELP OTHERS AND
KEEP THEM SAFE GIVE THEM SOME
SORT OF LIKE JUSTIFICATION AND
THE LEGAL SYSTEM. IT JUST I
WOULD HOPE THAT YOU GUYS WOULD
BOW I ON THIS AND JUST I DON'T
KNOW WHAT ELSE TO SAY I HAD A
WHOLE THING TYPED OUT AND I
DIDN'T GO OFF OF ANY OF. BUT YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH JIM THE
BILL. EIGHTY OP WE A LOT MORE.
ONE MORE WITNESS ERICA GONZALES. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU MY NAME IS ERICA
GONZALEZ I AM A SUPERVISING
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY WITH
THE TULARE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN THIS BILL
MAKES AN IMPORTANT CHANGE TO
ADMISSIBLE EVIDENCE IN COURT
CURRENTLY STATEMENTS MADE BY
VICTIMS UNDER TWELVE YEARS OF
AGE WHEN DESCRIBING ANY ACT OR
ATTEMPTED ACT OF CHILD ABUSE ARE
ADMISSIBLE IN COURT HOWEVER THIS
DOES NOT APPLY TO INDIVIDUALS
WITH INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WHO
MAY HAVE THE MENTAL CAPACITY. OF
A CHILD UNDER TWELVE YEARS OF
AGE THE CURRENT SYSTEM DOES NOT
PROVIDE ADEQUATE SUPPORT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WHO WILL LIKELY FACE THE SAME
CHALLENGES WHEN TESTIFYING IN
COURT ABOUT PHYSICAL OR SEXUAL
ABUSE THAT A CHILD UNDER TWELVE
YEARS OF AGE WOULD FACE IT IS
IMPORTANT WE RECOGNIZE THE
REASON SUCH STATEMENTS ARE
ADMISSIBLE IN COURT BY VICTIMS
UNDER TWELVE AND EXTEND THE SAME
PROTECTIONS TO VICTIMS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. ON BEHALF OF THE
TULARE OUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE
ASK THAT YOU STAND WITH VICTIMS
OF ABUSE AND SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY IN THE
ROOMTHAT WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT. NINE CATCH MY MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL I DID THANK YOU.
ANY OF WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YOU MAKE UP FOR. I SECOND THE
MOTION BY THE WAY. OPPOSITION
WEBER STATE.
MARCO GEORGIAN I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE TWENTY SEVENTH
AT- AS A PUBLIC DEFENDER OF OVER
THIRTY YEARS I HAVE THE NUMBER
OF CLIENTS WHO WERE.
DEVELOPMENTALLY DELAYED OR HAD
COGNITIVE ISSUES AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS YOU KNOW. WE
USED TO SAY AND FEEL ABOUT THEM
WAS THAT THEY WERE VERY
COOPERATIVE. AND WHAT THAT MEANT
WAS THAT IT IN A VERY BUSY
PUBLIC DEFENDER LIFE WITH A HUGE
CASELOAD. THAT MY CLIENTS WHO
ARE DEVELOPMENTALLY DELAYED
OFTEN JUST SAID YES TO WHATEVER
ASKED. WHETHER OR NOT THEY
UNDERSTOOD IT. AND MANY TIMES
FELT A NEED TO MASK THEIR
INABILITY TO COMPREHEND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING. AND. MY HEART GOES
OUT TO YOU HAVING YOU KNOW A
CHILD WHO SUFFERS FROM THIS BUT
I THINK THAT. THIS IS A PROBLEM
THAT MEANS THAT THE NEEDS AND
INTERESTS HAVE TO BE BALANCED.
AND THE CURRENT LAW DOES THAT-
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IS NOT NEEDED.
PRIOR INCONSISTENT STATEMENTS
CAN ALREADY BE ADMITTED. BY A
WITNESS IF THEY HAVE SAID
SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
THEY SAY IN COURT. AND THERE'S A
FUNDAMENTAL REASON THAT WE DON'T
ACCEPT HEARSAY IN CRIMINAL
TRIALS. AND IT'S BEEN SETTLED
LAW FOR AT LEAST A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY YEARS. AND THE ANALYSIS.
IT TALKS ABOUT AN EARLY CASE
MADDOX WHICH SAID THAT IT'S
FUNDAMENTAL TO BE ABLE TO ASK
YOUR ACCUSER QUESTIONS TO HAVE
THE JURY BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THEM
AND EVALUATE THEIR DEMEANOR. AND
TO MAKE DRAW THEIR OWN
CONCLUSIONS. AND THAT HERE SAY.
IS FUNDAMENTALLY UNRELIABLE AND
CAN LEAD TO- BE THE RESULT OF
SUGGESTED QUESTIONING OR
INTERVIEWING AND LEAD TO A
MISCARRIAGE OF JUSTICE. ALREADY
ASK ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THEIR
SPECIAL PROVISIONS AND COURT TO
PROTECT DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS ON JUDGES ARE
ADVISED IN THEIR TRAINING AND BY
LAW THEY MUST TAKE SPECIAL CARE
TO MAKE SURE THAT
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
WITNESSES WITH A SUBSTANTIAL
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT ARE
PROTECTED FROM UNDUE HARASSMENT
OR EMBARRASSMENT. REPETITIVE
UNNECESSARY QUESTIONING IS
PROHIBITED. AND THE JUDGE IS
SUPPOSED TO ENSURE THAT THE
FORMER THE QUESTIONS ARE
APPROPRIATE TO THE COGNITIVE
LEVEL OF THE WITNESS. IF
NECESSARY THE DA CAN APPLY FOR
IN ORDER TO ADMIT THE PRIOR
TESTIMONY FROM A PRELIMINARY
HEARING. IF THE COURT FINDS THAT
FURTHER TESTIMONY WOULD CAUSE
SUCH EMOTIONAL TRAUMA OR MAKE
THE VICTIM MEDICALLY UNABLE TO
TESTIFY. OR IF THE VICTIM IS
UNABLE TO TESTIFY AND I'M KIND
OF SHAKING BECAUSE THE DOOR THAT
THIS OPENS IS SO IMMENSE BECAUSE
BASICALLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOMEONE BEING CONVICTED OF A
CRIME. AND IT COULD RANGE FROM-
A MISDEMEANOR TO A CRIME THAT
WOULD PUT THEM AWAY FOR LIFE
WITHOUT THE WITNESS EVER COMING
TO COURT AND TESTIFYING. AND
THERE ARE REAL PEOPLE WHO ARE
HARM. I'M YOU HEARD EARLIER THIS
MORNING ABOUT- PEOPLE WHO WERE
HARMED THROUGH FALSE CONFECTIONS
. THERE ARE IN THE HORRIBLE
CASES ABOUT THE MEMBER ALLUDED
TO. ON. THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
WERE WRONGLY CONVICTED- AND ONE
OF THE MOST OF COURSE DRAMATIC
ONES FIRST FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR THROUGH NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
AT LEAST THIRTY DEFENDANTS WERE
CONVICTED OF CHILD SEX ABUSE AND
RELATED CHARGES AND SENTENCED TO
LONG PRISON TERMS IN A SERIES OF
INTERRELATED CASES AND KERN
COUNTY. OVER TIME TWENTY OF THE
DEFENDANTS WHO WERE SENTENCED TO
PRISON OR EXONERATED. THE
EARLIEST IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
AND THE MOST RECENT ONE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. AND MOST OF
THESE CASES. AND THESE ARE ABOUT
CHILDREN WHO ARE TESTIFIED THAT
THEY HAD BEEN ABUSED AND THEN
LATER RECANTED THEIR TESTIMONY.
AND THEY FOUND FROM THESE CASES
BUT THESE WERE THE PRODUCT OF
SUGGESTIVE QUESTIONING AND THIS
IS EXACTLY THE KIND OF SITUATION
THAT WOULD BE ALLOWED UNDER AB
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. SO IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE. YEAH I LET THE PROPONENTS
GO ALONG CHARLOTTE TO DEFENSE
COLOGNE. MORNING J. MEMBERS ARE
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF ACLU CAL
ACTION BY THE WHIMS BEEN A SEA
CAL ACTION WE HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE BILL INCLUDE FOR THE
GUARDRAILS AROUND THE COURT
DETERMINATION OF INDIVIDUAL HAVE
MAKES AN INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
WE DON'T WANT JUDGES TO BE IN
THE PLACE OF MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION SO SOLELY BY
THEMSELVES. WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THAT'S APPROPRIATE SO WE
LIKE TO SEE IN THE BILL JUST NO
GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE THAT THE
INTENDED-A GROUP OF POPULATION
IS- CORRECTLY DIAGNOSE AND
THAT'S DONE SO BY SOMEONE THAT
IS- PROFESSIONALLY CREATE ABLE
TO DIAGNOSE THE INDIVIDUAL IN
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS MADE BY AS
THE PDA SO AT THIS TIME WE MUST
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE REAL LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
OPPOSITION. HI GOOD MORNING
MISTER HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ALSO NOT
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. AT&T OPERATOR FOR THOSE WHO
LIKE TO EXPRESS EITHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION THIS IS THEIR
OPPORTUNITY WOULD LIKE TO HEAR.
IMAGE JOE IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAN EUROPE THIS TIME. SHARE
WHAT YOU HAVE TO RANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THEY MAY PERCEIVE AMO
START WITH MINE. THANK WILL
START ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE TERM MEMBER TREAT THE
ANDERSON BUT THE ARK IN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT TO THE LINE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS THE GREATER APPLE-
I'M FROM COLOR CALIFORNIA AND
I'M ACTUALLY WINDY BAKER AND
BAKER NEIGHBOR. I WHEN I FIRST
MET WINDY. SHE MOVED IN WITH HER
HUSBAND AND HER FAMILY AND SHE
TOLD ME ABOUT HER DAUGHTER
KELSEY ONE THING THAT ALWAYS
STUCK OUT BUT YOU ONLY ORDER
OPPOSITION I'M SORRY. ALL RIGHT
I SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE LINE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ABOUT. I WAS. THEY WILL GO TO
ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS VIVIAN THANK YOU HAVE
A BOARD MEMBER ON THE PATAKI BOB
HE SYNDROME FOUNDATION IT'S A
RARE GENETIC DISORDER- WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN
KELSEY'S LAW. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR HAVE NO ONE ELSE
CAN QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
. YES MISDIRECTED THIS IS A VERY
DELICATE ISSUE AND- I FIND THE-
THE OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS TO BE
NON COMPELLING- I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT YOU CONTINUE TO TRY TO
GET AS MUCH SUPPORT AS YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEIR
CONCERNS BUT- I I'VE- AS A
PERSON. IT HAS A DEGREE IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND STARTED
OFF AS A TEACHER WITH. FOR THAT
HAD LEARNING DISABILITIES I AM
VERY SENSITIVE. TO THE DELICATE
NATURE OF- TRAGEDIES THAT. THE
TAKE PLACE AND I THINK EVERYBODY
ON THIS COMMITTEE. WOULD- I FELT
THAT SAME FEELING. BUT I
APPRECIATE. THE ADVOCACY THAT
THIS BILL PROVIDES AND I
COMPLETELY SUPPORT IT AND- I'M
I'M THANKING YOU FOR ALLOWING US
TO ADDRESS IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND- MISS BONTA. OR MR BRIAN
. THANK YOU- IN MY MIND OUT TO
PARENTS WERE PHOSPHORUS FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS AND YOU FOR THE
MOST PART SPECIAL NEEDS FOSTER
PARENTS- TO MY ADD UP LITTLE
BROTHERS AND SPECIAL NEEDS ONE
WHO HAS TROUBLE PAUL THE ONE WHO
HAS SEVERE AUTISM. AND THIS IS A
VERY COMPLICATED BILL WITH
RIGHTEOUS INTENTIONS I THINK ANY
TIME YOU CREATE A HEARSAY
EXCEPTION IT. ALSO VIOLATES SIX
AMENDMENT PROTECTIONS IN THE
CONSTITUTION AND THAT'S VERY
TOUGH. THERE ARE SOME GUARDRAILS
ALREADY IN PLACE AND INCLUDING.
JURIES BEEN INSTRUCTED NOT TO
JUDGE THE CREDIBILITY OF A
WITNESS BASED SOLELY ON THEIR
DISABILITY. FOUND I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR. FOR
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE. AND I
THINK IT'S TIMELY THAT IT WAS
BROUGHT. THE SAME DAY AS-
ANOTHER BILL WE HEARD EARLIER.
WHERE TESTIMONY THAT'S GATHERED
IN THE EVIDENCE GATHERING
PROCESS CAN BE. SUGGESTED AND
THEN TO HAVE THAT LEGITIMIZED IN
COURT WITHOUT THE PRIMARY
WITNESS BEEN PRESENT IS TOUGH-
OVERALL I HOPE THAT IF THIS BILL
MOVES OR DOESN'T MOVE IT'S AN
ISSUE CONTINUE TO WORK ON WITH
THE OPPOSITION WITH THE FAMILIES
WERE IMPACTED AND AGAIN JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR. PROVIDING
YES BONTA. I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT AND I APPRECIATED
THAT TESTIMONY THAT THAT OF.
OPPOSITION PROVIDING THAT THE
CURRENT LAW ALSO ALLOWS THE
PROSECUTION TO APPLY FOR A COURT
ORDER TO TAPE THE PRELIMINARY
HEARING TESTIMONY. OF A
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED VICTIM
OF CERTAIN SEX OFFENSES. AND
THERE'S ALSO IN THERE THE
ABILITY FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO-
HAVE THEIR TEST AND FORMER
TESTIMONY AT TRIAL- IF THE COURT
SHOULD FIND A TO HAVE THAT
TESTIMONY T. SO I'M JUST OUT
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM THE
AUTHOR- JUST HOW THE INTENTION.
I HEARD THAT YOU TOOK AN
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE THE- HAVING
A PARALLEL WITH AT A COGNITIVE.
ABILITY INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
THAT- UP TO THE AGE OF TWELVE SO
I WANTED TO JUST HEAR A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THAT AS WELL-
BEFORE I DECIDE. THROUGH THE
CHAIR WE WANT MANAGING OUR IT IS
CLOSE THE CLOSEST FINE THANK YOU
- MISTER CORK. TO THE AND WHAT
WAS THE ARE I'M CAR OF HEARING
WHAT WAS YOUR THAT YOU WANT. HI-
WE WANTED IT CLARIFIED THE
GUARDRAILS AROUND THE COURT'S
DETERMINATION THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL HAS AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THAT'S DONE TO SOMEONE WHO
HAS A PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY TO
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION WE THINK
THAT THAT NEEDS TO BE CLARIFIED-
IN THE BILL. IN THE BUILDING
OKAY SO CLARIFICATION OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO HAVE A DISABILITY WELL
FOR THE COURT TO DETERMINE THAT
WE WOULDN'T OKAY JUDGE TO BE
MAKING THAT DECISION BASED ON A
CONVERSATION OF THAT NATURE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S-
CLARIFIED IN THE BUILDING. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER. YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- TO
ADDRESS THE AMENDMENTS FIRST-
BARCA IN IT AND THROUGH SOME OF
THE CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION
AND THINGS HAVING THE- AGE
SPECIFIED VERSUS HAVING- THE
VERBIAGE SAY- SOMEONE WITH AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY KIND OF
GOES TO THE POINTS OF
CLARIFICATION- THAT ACLU'S
ASKING FOR BECAUSE YOU WOULD
HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY THAT IS A
CONDITION THAT COULD VERIFY.
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL DOES INDEED
HAVE THE DISABILITY- SO THAT
AMENDMENT DOES KIND OF ADDRESS
THE ACLU'S POINT ON IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER AMENDMENTS I'M AGAIN
I'M ALWAYS HAPPY TO TAKE THEM
INTO WORK MOVING FORWARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS A JUST BILL
BECAUSE THERE THERE ARE VICTIMS
HERE THEY'RE FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS- TO ADDRESS THE POINTS-
MADE BY SOME THE OPPOSITION I
THINK IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND IMPERATIVE. OF US THAT WE
ADDRESS WHAT THE SIXTH AMENDMENT
- AND THE NEED TO FACE YOUR
ACCUSER MEANS IN THIS CASE AND
WHAT THE EXISTING HERE SAY ROLE
IS. THE SIXTH AMENDMENT AND ALL
CRIMINAL PROSECUTIONS THE
ACCUSED SHALL ENJOY THE RIGHT
TO. TO BE CONFRONTED WITH THE
WITNESSES AGAINST THEM. AGAIN IT
IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
REMEMBER WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND
WHAT IT DOES NOT DO. THE
VIOLATION UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
SIXTH AMENDMENT DOES NOT APPLY
TO CHILDREN UNDER TWELVE YEARS
OF AGE. SO WE ARE HAPPY TO BEND
AND TWEAK THESE ROLES. FOR
SOMEBODY WHO'S UNDER TWELVE. BUT
NOT FOR A CHILD WHO IS OVER
TWELVE. CHAU BEFORE CURRENTLY
GOING TO ACCEPT THAT A TWELVE
YEAR OLD WHO IS OF NORMAL
COGNITIVE ABILITY IT'S OKAY TO
APPLY HERE SEVERAL. BEFORE A
CHILD WHO IS THIRTEEN WITH AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY WE ARE
NOT GOING TO APPLY THE SAME RULE
. MEMBERS I DON'T SEE HOW THAT'S
JUST. AND HOW THAT'S FAIR
ESPECIALLY FOR SOMEBODY WHO
MIGHT BE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN WITH AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY. AS A FATHER. WITH
THE SUN WHO LIVES IN A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HOME I CANNOT
IMAGINE PUTTING HIM ON THE STAND
AND HAVING THEM CROSS EXAMINED.
BECAUSE I KNOW THE COGNITIVE
ABILITY ISSUE. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY AMENDMENTS. TO MAKE THIS THE
DISK CLERICALLY DEFINITIVE AS
POSSIBLE I ALWAYS HAVE BEEN AND
I'M COMPLETELY OPEN TO THAT
MOVING FORWARD. I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS VERY SPECIFIC
. THAT WE'RE DEALING THAT THAT
THERE'S EVIDENCE THERE TO SAY
THIS PERSON DOES HAVE AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY THAT WE
ARE FOLLOWING THE SAME ROLE THIS
IS APPLIED FOR TWELVE YEAR OLDS
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
IN YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU- MISTER GRAYSON I
THINK WOULD ALSO OPEN WITH ONLY
HE WAS ONLY ALLOWED TO PRESENT
NOT TO CLOSE OKAY- IT I THAT I
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT HEARING
FROM MR GRAYSON I HAD THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO GO TO AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO
HEAR ANY OTHER WITNESSES-
ANALOGY AND- MISTER CHAIR THE-
I'M ON A TIME. FOR TRYING TO GET
TO GET OUT OF HERE. AND SO I'M
GONNA MAKE THIS OFFER- THE
AUTHOR AND I. HAVE NOT AGREED ON
THIS. BUT I'M WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR. WORK WITH. THE
PEOPLE WERE SPONSORING AN
ADVOCATE SO WE BECAUSE I'M WHAT
I'M HEARING FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT THERE COULD BE SOME
AMENDMENTS TAKEN WHICH- WE'RE
NOT. WE COULDN'T GET TO THAT
BEFORE THIS WE NEEDED THIS THIS
HEARING TO GET TO WHERE PEOPLE
WERE WILLING TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
BUT THE OTHER THING IS TO HEAR
FROM BOTH SIDES TO UNDERSTAND
BOTH SIDES I THINK WE'RE NOW TO
POINT WE'RE HEARING BOTH SIDES I
DO NOT WANT TO LEAVE DISK.
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
THIS TO BE POLITICIZED. I WANT
US TO WORK ON THIS IN A FAIR WAY
. SO THAT WE CAN GET TO A
SOLUTION THAT WORKS FOR BOTH
SIDES. HEARSAY AND CRIMINALLY
SENDING PEOPLE OF COLOR TO JAIL
. ARE GIVING LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT ABILITY TO DO IT. REALLY IS
IMPORTANT TO ME AS IT IS A BLUE
ULTIMATELY IMPORTANT FOR YOU
WHICH I BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME
SAFEGUARDS FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE. DEMENTED BUT
DEVELOPMENTALLY. PROBLEMS THAT
THAT WE DO HAVE THAT IN IN IN
THE LAW RIGHT NOW IT WAS READ
BY. MISS BONTA. IT SEEMS I JUST
DON'T WANT THAT IGNORED. IF IT'S
NOT IF THAT NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED WHAT THAT GIVES
FAMILIES. HIS FAMILY SOME
ASSURANCES THAT THEIR FAMILIES
WON'T BE BE TRAUMATIZED IN COURT
WRITERS VIDEOTAPING OR WHATEVER
IF WE NEED TO CLARIFY THAT TO
PROTECT THEM. THEN WITH THE
EXISTING LAWS THAT WE HAVE AND
THEN I'M PERFECTLY WILLING TO DO
THAT I WOULD HOPE THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT LEAVE HERE. BECAUSE
ONCE YOU GET OUT OF HERE I HAVE
NO IDEA WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN BE
ABLE TO DO THAT AND THAT WE ASK
FOR RECONSIDERATION IF IT
DOESN'T GET OUT OF THIS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY CHAIRS- KALRA
RECOMMEND A NO VOTE. AND THEN.
WE'LL GO FROM THERE IF I MAY ASK
FOR. THE COMMITTEE TO TABLE. THE
BILL UNTIL THE FURTHER DAYS WE
CAN HAVE TIME TO WORK ON THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU SUGGEST
YEAH. SO I'M GOING TO. THE MOST
CONSECUTIVE BEST DOCTORAL. JONES
SAWYER UNFORTUNATELY
RESPECTFULLY- NO HI I APOLOGIZE
IN AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN MATHIS
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER
NO LACKEY LACKEY I BONTA. NO I
HOPE YOU DO ASK FOR
CONSIDERATION IT SHOULD NOT PATH
BONTA KNOW BRIAN. BRIAN NOT
VOTING QUIRK NO WORK NO SANTIAGO
SEYARTO HI THEY ARE TAUGHT BY
THAT MUCH I'M SORRY THAT MEASURE
FAILS MASS FOR RECONSIDERATION
RESEARCHER WITH THE THERE IS NO
OBJECTION AND YET UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT GRANTS YOU HAVE
RECONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. A
LITTLE. MISTER RODRIGUEZ I THINK
I SAW.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY ONE WHICH WOULD ALLOW
ARRESTING AGENCIES TO RECOVER
THE BOOKING BECAUSE OF
INDIVIDUALS ARRESTED FOR SEX
PURCHASING. CALIFORNIA AND THE
LAW SAYS REGION PARTICULAR HAS
THE HIGHEST RATE OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE NATION. THE
NUMBER OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASE
REPORTED IN CALIFORNIA INCREASED
62% BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. DESPITE THIS
SOME DISTRICT ATTORNEYS DO NOT
PROSECUTE INDIVIDUALS ARRESTED.
FOR THE ACT OF PURCHASING SEX IN
PLACES LIKE POMONA WHICH IS IN
MY DISTRICT. THIS REFUSAL TO
PROSECUTE HAS LED TO AN INCREASE
IN ILLEGAL PROSTITUTION AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THAT HAS BEEN
GOING ON FOR DECADES. AB TWENTY
OR FIFTY ONE OR CREATE A PENALTY
FOR INDIVIDUALS ARRESTED FOR SEX
PURCHASING CREATING A STRONGER
DETERRENT FOR SUCH BEHAVIOR. AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE PROVIDED
TOOL FOR ARRESTING AGENCIES TO
USE SHOULD THEY CHOOSE IN
ADDRESSING PROSTITUTION AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES. WITH ME
PROVIDE. IN PERSON TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE SERGEANT BRETT PAULSON. WITH
THE POMONA POLICE DEPARTMENT
THANK YOU. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
SIR GOOD MORNING THE MORNING'S
BRAD PAULSON I'M THE SERGEANT OF
THE QUALITY OF LIFE UNIT WITH
THE POMONA POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
WE ALSO REPRESENT THE SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION AND TRAFFICKING
TEAM. HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A
CRIME THAT INVOLVES COMPELLING-
COURSING A PERSON TO PROVIDE
LABOR SERVICES. OR TO ENGAGE IN
COMMERCIAL SEX ACTS THE COERCION
CAN BE SUBTLE OR OVERT PHYSICAL
OR PSYCHOLOGICAL AND MAY INVOLVE
THE USE OF VIOLENCE THREATS LIES
OR DEBT BONDAGE. EXPLOITATION OF
A MINOR FOR COMMERCIAL SEX HUMAN
TRAFFICKING REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER ANY FORM OF FORCE FRAUD
OR COERCION WAS USED. THE UNITED
STATES IS WIDELY REGARDED AS A
DESTINATION COUNTRY FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. THE REQUIRED SAID
ESTIMATED THAT 1-400-050-0217
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED VICTIMS
ARE TRAFFICKED INTO THE UNITED
STATES ANNUALLY. THIS DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE NUMBER OF VICTIMS
WERE TRAFFICKED WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES EACH YEAR.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HOTLINE
1-000-090-0409 CASES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING REPORT IN THE UNITED
STATES IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
. THE CARD TO THE HOTLINE
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
SITES OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
THE UNITED STATES. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ONE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX CASES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING REPORTING
CALIFORNIA. OF THOSE ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
WERE SEX TRAFFICKING CASES.
THERE IS NO SINGLE PROFILE OF A
TRAFFICKING VICTIM VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING INCLUDE NOT
ONLY MEN AND WOMEN LOWERED INTO
FORCED LABOR BY THE PROMISE OF A
BETTER LIFE UNITED STATES. BUT
ALSO BOYS AND GIRLS WERE BORN
AND RAISED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS COME FROM A
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS IN TERMS OF
RACE COLOR NATIONAL ORIGIN
DISABILITY. RELIGION AGE GENDER
SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY. SOCIO ECONOMIC STATUS
EDUCATION LEVEL AND CITIZENSHIP
CITIZENSHIP STATUS. BUT ONE
CHARACTERISTIC THAT THEY USUALLY
SHARE IT IS SOME FORM OF
VULNERABILITY. TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS ARE OFTEN ISOLATED FROM
THEIR FAMILIES AND SOCIAL
NETWORKS AND IN SOME CASES ARE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR COUNTRY OF
ORIGIN NATIVE LANGUAGE AND
CULTURE. MANY DOMESTIC VICTIMS
OF SEX TRAFFICKING ARE RUNAWAY
OR HOMELESS YOUTH AND OR COME
FROM BACKGROUNDS OF SEXUAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE AND SAYS
POVERTY OR ADDICTION. AUTHORS
EXPLOIT THESE VULNERABILITIES
PROMISING THE VICTIMS LOVE A
GOOD JOB OR A MORE STABLE LIFE.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS AMONG THE
WORLD'S FASTEST GROWING CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE AND IS ESTIMATED TO
BE A ONE HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR GLOBAL INDUSTRY.
IS A FORM OF MODERN DAY SLAVERY
THAT PROFITS FROM THE
EXPLOITATION OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. HUMAN
TRAFFICKING STRIPS VICTIMS OF
THEIR FREEDOM AND VIOLATES OUR
NATION'S PROMISE THAT EVERY
PERSON IN THE UNITED STATES IS
GUARANTEED BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS.
THE INTERNATIONAL LABOR
ORGANIZATION ESTIMATES THAT
THERE ARE MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR
POINT NINE MILLION HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS WORLDWIDE
ANYTIME THIS INCLUDES FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION. THE VICTIMS OF SEX
TRAFFICKING ARE OFTEN YOUNG
GIRLS AND WOMEN WHO MAKE UP AN
ESTIMATED NINETY NINE POINT 4%
OF SEX TRAFFICKING VICTIMS.
RECENT YEARS TRANSNATIONAL
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
AFFILIATED DOMESTIC GANGS HAVE
EXPANDED FROM DRUG AND FIREARM
TRAFFICKING TO THE TRAFFICKING
OF HUMAN BEINGS. IN THE PAST THE
U. S. DEPARTMENT OF STATE IS
ESTIMATED THAT FOURTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED VICTIMS ARE
TRAFFICKED INTO THE NIGHT STATES
EACH YEAR. THIS FIGURE DOES NOT
INCLUDE VICTIMS ARE TRAFFICKED
WITHIN THE COUNTRY EACH YEAR
CALIFORNIA POPULOUS BORDER STATE
WITH A SIGNIFICANT IMMIGRANT.
POPULATION HAS THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IS ONE OF THE
NATION'S TOP DESTINATION STATES
FOR TRAFFICKING HUMAN BEINGS.
THE PERPETRATORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HAVE BECOME MORE
SOPHISTICATED ORGANIZED
REQUIRING EQUALLY SOPHISTICATED
RESPONSE FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND ITS PARTNERS TO DISRUPT AND
DISMANTLE THEIR NETWORKS. STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN STEPS TO
FIGHT HUMAN TRAFFICKING SUCH AS
THE PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL
ELEVEN NINETY THREE SENATE BILL
TWO TWENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO SIXTY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR. AND SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTY. PROSTITUTION IS OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS THE OLDEST
PROFESSION THE WORLD AND IS
OFTEN ARE HONESTLY LABELED A
VICTIMLESS CRIME. IN OVER TWENTY
YEARS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
MAJORITY OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
SPENT INVESTIGATING PROSTITUTION
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING RELATED
CRIMES. I CANNOT REMEMBER A
SINGLE VICTIM THAT HAS EVER TOLD
ME THEY WERE ENGAGED IN A TRADE
BY CHOICE. THE MAJORITY OF
SHARED STORIES OF BEING COERCED
INTO LIFESTYLES A MINOR BY A
TRAFFICKER WHO PROVIDED A FALSE
SENSE OF LOVE AND SECURITY AT A
TIME THEY WERE MOST VULNERABLE.
MOST EXPRESSED FEELING TRAPPED
AND UNABLE TO LEAVE THE TRADE AS
THEY HAD NOWHERE ELSE TO GO THE
NO OTHER MEANS OF FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. LIVING ON THE STREETS
MOVING FROM MOTEL TO MOTEL AND
CITY TO CITY IS NOT A CHOICE.
SEX WORK LIKE ANY OTHER INDUSTRY
IS BASED ON THE SIMPLE BUSINESS
MODEL OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND. THE
HIGHER THE DEMAND THE MORE
INCENTIVE TO RECRUIT NEW WORKERS
BY SEX TRAFFICKERS. AB TWENTY
ONE FIFTY ONE AIMS TO REDUCE THE
DEMAND BY INCREASING THE
FINANCIAL PENALTIES SEX
PURCHASERS TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
VICTIMIZATION OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS. WELL I
CANNOT SPEAK FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I CAN
CONFIRM THAT THE MAJORITY OF SEX
PURCHASERS ARRESTED IN THE CITY
OF HOMEOWNER ARE NOT FROM OUR
COMMUNITY. THESE PREDATORS COME
FROM ALL OVER THE REGION PLACING
STRAIN ON PUBLIC SERVICES AND
DRASTICALLY IMPACTING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE OF OUR RESIDENTS
AND BUSINESS OWNERS. AS MANY
ELECTED PROSECUTORS ACROSS THE
NATION SEEK ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE PROVIDES A
DETERRENT TO SEX PURCHASERS
WATER FOLLOWING THIS MODEL.
BASED ON THE AVERAGE TIME TO RIP
PROCESS IN A REST OF THE SIX
PURCHASER. WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT TWO ONE
HOURS. THE AVERAGE AMOUNT OF
POLICE OFFICERS HOURLY PAY RATE
THE ANTICIPATED FIND WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO DOLLARS AND FORTY CENTS.
WELL THIS DOES NOT COVER THE
IMMEDIATE COSTS OF THE OFFICER
WHAT IT DOES COVER THE MEDIA
COST OF DOCTORS TIME IT IN NO
WAY TRULY COVERS THE FULL COST
OF THE ENTIRE INVESTIGATION. THE
INTENT BEHIND AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY ONE IS NOT TO INCENTIVIZE
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO FOCUS
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS ON A
SPECIFIC CRIME. BUT RATHER TO
OFFER YOU TURNED TO SEX
PURCHASERS. MODELED AFTER
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT CODE FIFTY
THREE ONE FIFTY PASSED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE WHICH
ALLOWS FOR RECOVERY FROM RICH
RESPONSE. TO AN ACCIDENT RELATED
TO A DRIVER FOUND TO BE UNDER
THE INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL.
BOOKING COSTS INCURRED BY OR
IMPOSED UPON THE ARRESTING
AGENCY CAN BE RECOVERED. THESE
FEES WILL GO BACK TO THE GENERAL
FUND OF THE GOVERNING BODY
HAVING JURISDICTION OVER CITY
AGENCY TO BE UTILIZED AS SEEN
FIT BY ELECTED OFFICIALS.
PROGRAMS TO INCLUDE PROVIDING
YOUTH ASSISTANCE DEVELOPMENT AND
SUPPORT ANTI HUMAN TRAFFICKING
EDUCATIONAL CAMPAIGNS. AND
SUPPORT OF OUR NON OUR COMMUNITY
NONPROFIT PARTNERS ARE JUST A
FEW OPTIONS RAPPER PLEASE YES
SIR. SINCE THE ELECTION OF
GEORGE OF LOS ANGELES IDA GEORGE
GAS CONE THE CITY HONEST IN A
DRASTIC INCREASE IN THE
PROSTITUTION ACTIVITY. MORE
SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN VICTIMS COMING INTO%
CALIFORNIA FROM OTHER STATES. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE CONTACTED
THIRTY VICTIMS FROM THE STATE OF
TEXAS ALONE. IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS PRIOR WE HAD ONLY
CONTACTED NINE. WE'VE
ENCOUNTERED VICTIMS FROM NEARLY
ALL FIFTY STATES OVER THE PAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGAIN THE DEMAND
IN CALIFORNIA IS HIGH IN PART
DUE TO A LACK OF DETERRENCE. I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE TO HELP
FIGHT AGAINST HUMAN TRAFFICKING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
WITNESSES. TO MOVE THE BILL.
SECOND WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
REMEMBERS COURCELLES ALONG
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING TERM
MEMBERS AT ONE FOUR BOND ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ONTARIO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WHEN I
WROTE TO THE PHONE LINES
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AB TWENTY
ONE FIFTY ONE TICKET. TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE SIXTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. MY
NAME IS JOHN MEMBERS RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND
REPRESENTING POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. ARMONK CORONA
HOMEOWNER CULTURALLY THE BEACH
UP SANTA ANA BURBANK RIVERSIDE
ARE. INGLEWOOD FULLER CHEN AND
COVER SO ON SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS THIS IS US STAR JULIUS
ACT REPRESENT SURE SHOT AND I
GUESS IN SOME IN THE COUNTRY
CANCERS APARTMENT IN SUPPORT.
LINE. SIXTY FOUR. THE MILITARY
MERECE ON BEHALF OF THE ONTARIO
POLICE DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. NOW WE
HEAR FROM WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
AGAIN YEP FIVE MINUTES.
THANK A CREAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE WHICH WOULD
MOVE THE STATE BACKWARDS BY
IMPOSING NEW RACIALLY DISPARATE
FEES AND HARMING SEX WORKERS AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRAFFICKED. AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE WILL CREATE
MORE DANGEROUS WORKING
CONDITIONS FOR PEOPLE ENGAGED IN
SEX TRADES. AS AMNESTY
INTERNATIONAL HAS NOTED
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INTENTION
LAWS AGAINST BUYING FACT OFTEN
MEAN THAT SEX WORKERS HAVE TO
TAKE MORE RISKS TO PROTECT
BUYERS FROM DETECTION BY POLICE
. SIMILAR LAWS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE PUSH SEX WORKERS
TO OPERATE UNDER RISKIER
CONDITIONS WITH HARMFUL
IMPLICATIONS FOR THEIR HEALTH.
INCLUDING A DECREASE IN CONDOM
USE AND INCREASED DRUG AND
ALCOHOL USE DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDAL THOUGHTS AND VIOLENCE
AGAINST SEX WORKERS. HAS ONE SEX
WORKER PUT IT EVER SINCE THE LAW
CHANGED THE WORST CRIMES ATTACKS
RAPES AND ROBBERIES HAVE
INCREASED. ADDITIONALLY AN
ARREST FOR LOITERING WITH INTENT
IS COMPLETELY SUBJECTIVE RELYING
ON A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. TO
INTO IT THAT A PERSON HAS SUCH
INTENT BASED ON NOT OFFICERS
BIAS EASE. BETWEEN JANUARY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND SEPTEMBER
TWENTY NINETEEN LATINOS MADE UP
SEVENTY POINT 5% OF THOSE
CHARGED UNDER SIX FORTY SEVEN
BEATS AN LA. INDICATING RACIAL
BIAS IN WHO IS PERCEIVED BY
POLICE AS A CLIENT OF SEX
WORKERS. THE PROVISION OF THIS
BILL CREATE HARMFUL FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES THAT WILL ONLY
INTENSIFY THE CURRENT RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN POLICING AND
ARREST RATES. AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY ONE WHAT ALSO CREATE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES FOR
ARRESTING A PERSON EVEN IF THE
CHARGES ARE DROPPED OR THE
PERSON NOT FOUND NOT GUILTY. THE
ARRESTING AGENCY WOULD GET TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH THE FEE WOULD
BE. AND IF THE PERSON ARRESTED
HAS THE MONEY TIME AND ABILITY
TO CHALLENGE THE FEE THAT SEEM
AGENCY WOULD ALSO GET TO DECIDE
THE OUTCOME OF THE CHALLENGE. AS
A MEMBER OF THE DEBT FREE
JUSTICE COALITION WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY FOUGHT FOR
MEANINGFUL RELIEF FROM OVERLY
BURDENSOME AND PROGRESSIVE FINES
AND FEES IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE
WOULD BE A STEP BACKWARDS ON THE
PROGRESS CALIFORNIA HAS MADE.
AND WOULD HARM SEX WORKERS AND
PEOPLE TRAFFICKED. FOR THESE
REASONS ACLU CALIFORNIA OPPOSES
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE. THANK
YOU MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF
THE CAN YOU MOVE THAT MICROPHONE
OKAY CERTAINLY THANK YOU. MARGO
GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION A RESPECTFULLY WE
OPPOSE THE BILL- AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY ONE WELL NOT JUST HER SEX
TRAFFICKING. ON THE AUTHOR IS
QUOTED IN THE ANALYSIS OF
STATING CURRENT PUNISHMENTS HAVE
BEEN THE HAVE NOT BEEN EFFECTIVE
IN REDUCING SEX PURCHASING AND
TRAFFICKING. AND CURRENT
PUNISHMENT RUNS THE GAMUT NOW
FROM SIX MONTHS THAT AND COUNTY
JAIL TO LIFE IN PRISON SO
BOOKING FEES ARE NOT GOING TO
END ON. SEX TRAFFICKING OR- ON
PROSTITUTION HOWEVER ONE THING
TO BEAR IN MIND IS THAT PEOPLE
THAT THESE FEES WILL AFFECT OUR
AS- THE ACLU STATED ARE POOR
PEOPLE BECAUSE- RICH PEOPLE WHO
ARE PURCHASE SEX DO IT ON THE
INTERNET- THEY BELONG TO CLUBS
THEY'RE NOT PICKING PEOPLE UP ON
STREET. AND AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE FIFTY ONE WILL IMPOVERISH
MORE CALIFORNIANS OF JUST TWO
YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BOOKING FEES DO
MORE HARM THAN GOOD. AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE THE COMMITTEE ON THE
BUDGETS TWENTY TWENTY BILL
ABOLISHING BOOKING FEES THE
LEGISLATIVE FINDINGS STATED
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF
CALIFORNIANS IN JAIL OR INDIGENT
- INCARCERATED PEOPLE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK OR
LATIN NEXT. THE AVERAGE DEBT
INCURRED FOR RESPONDENTS AND
CARD FOR COURT ORDERED FINES AND
FEES WAS ROUGHLY EQUAL TO THE
ANNUAL INCOME FOR RESPONDENTS IN
THIS SURVEY BY ELLA BAKER CENTER
. A NATIONAL SURVEY OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FOUND THAT
FAMILIES OFTEN BEAR THE BRUNT OF
FEES THE BURDEN AND THAT 83% OF
THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PAYING THESE COSTS ARE WOMEN. SO
THIS WILL NOT HELP WOMEN WHO ARE
SEX TRAFFICKED. FEES AND ARE IN
FINES ARE OFTEN ASSIGNED TO
PEOPLE WHO SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD
TO PAY THEM THEY MAKE POOR
PEOPLE THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES POOR. CRIMINAL
JUSTICE FEES HAVE NO FORMAL
PUNITIVE OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
FUNCTION. THIS IS AGAIN THE
LEGISLATIVE FINDING FROM THE
BUDGET BILL JUST TWO YEARS AGO.
THEY LIMIT ACCESS TO EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
BENEFITS AND THEY CREATE
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO
SUCCESSFUL RE ENTRY. MOREOVER
COUNTIES AND MUNICIPALITIES
CAN'T COLLECT THE FEES IN THE
FIRST PLACE THEY SPEND MORE
MONEY TRYING TO COLLECT THEM
THAN THEY EVER GET BACK. SO FOR
ALL OF THOSE REASONS WITH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON A B. TWENTY ONE FIFTY
ONE THANK YOU- ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM. IN OPPOSITION. WHEN
BACK IS FOR ELEVATOR CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS IN OPPOSITION. ALY
SLACK I AM ALSO- IN STRONG
OPPOSITION- I DON'T SACRAMENTO
THANK YOU. BUT NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
AND- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE
RODRIGUEZ. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP. THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. YES
WITH THE COURT- SO THE LAST IN
PERSON DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION. WE
HAVE A DEMONSTRATION BY A BUNCH
OF YOUNG WOMEN SAME SEX WORK IS
REAL WORK AND ASKING FOR CHANGES
IN THESE LAWS EIGHT YEARS AGO
AFTER HEARING WHEN I WAS CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE ENGAGED IN. SEX WORK WHO
WANT TO BE ENGAGED IN SEX WORK
SOMETIMES STILL YOU KNOW I'VE
TALKED TO THEM THOSE SAY THIS IS
MEMBER WE HAVE THE KEY WITNESS
SAYING THAT THIS IS SOMETHING I
WILL DO MY ENTIRE LIFE AND SHE
WAS ALREADY IN HER FORTIES. OR
MAYBE FIFTIES. I DON'T KNOW IF
THE CHAIRMAN REMEMBER THAT BUT-
REALLY THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THIS
YOUR VOLUNTARY NOW WHAT YOUR
WITNESS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ TALKED ABOUT WAS SEX
TRAFFICKING WHICH- EVERYONE OF
US IS AGAINST. BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS LAWS ABOUT THIS LAWS
ABOUT- PROSTITUTION OR SEX
WORKERS I PREFER TO CALL IT
GENERALLY- THE BEST WAY TO
PREVENT HUMAN TRAFFICKING WOULD
BE TO LEGALIZE SEX WORK. THEN
YOU WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
AS THEY DO IN CERTAIN COUNTIES
IN NEVADA OF BOTH TESTING THE
YOUNG WOMEN FOR- SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WERE DOING THIS
VOLUNTARILY. THAT'S THE WAY TO
PREVENT SEX TRAFFICKING SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I CAN'T SUPPORT
YOUR BILL AT THIS TIME I WOULD
PREFER A DIFFERENT APPROACH.
WHERE WE WOULD IN FACT LEGALIZE
SEX WORK BUT PREVENT- HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FOR SEX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MISTER BRIAN- THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM I HAVE WITH THE
BILL IS JUST THE CONSISTENCY
WITH THE IF CONVICTED THIS ISN'T
IT IT WILL BE ALLOWING FOR THE
BOOKING FEES TO THEN STILL BEING
COLLECTED AND RETAINED
REGARDLESS OF CONVICTION STATUS
OR ACQUITTAL OR HAVING THE
CHARGES DROPPED DUE TO LACK OF
EVIDENCE SEEMS- BEYONC UNITIVE
AND SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO ROLL BACK FOR SEVERAL
YEARS THOSE KINDS OF FINES AND
FEES AND SO. WITH THAT A
CONSISTENCY IT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING I CAN'T. SUPPORT TODAY
. THANK YOU ANY OTHER. YOU YOU
MAY CLOSE MISTER ROGERS. WHAT
WHAT THAT SAID OUR- REALLY LIKE
TO INVITE THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND- FOLKS IN THIS
ROOM TO SEE WHERE PROSTITUTION
HAS DONE TO. MY DISTRICT AND
CITY OF POMONA OF HAS DEVASTATED
THIS COMMUNITY SPECIAL LONG THE
BUSINESS FRONT WERE A LOT OF
THIS HAS BEEN DONE FOR DECADES
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE GOING AWAY
IF ANYTHING IT'S GOTTEN WORSE
BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC. IF THIS
ISN'T THE RIGHT WAY TO APPROACH
IT. I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH
ANYBODY HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
IN THIS ROOM TO SEE HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS THIS. LEGALIZING IT IS A
WHOLE DIFFERENT SUBJECT I DON'T
KNOW HAS ITS OWN ISSUES WELL BUT
THE FACT THAT- IT'S DEVASTATING
TO MY COMMUNITY IN THE RESOURCE
IS TAKEN FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
TAKE HIM OUT. OFF THE STREETS TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES IS
DEVASTATING SO WITH THAT SAID I
RESPECT US FOR I WROTE IN HOPES
THAT YOU CAN HELP ME- DRESSED AS
A BIGGER ONCE AGAIN. A HUGE
IMPACT. DE AND UPON RUN
COMMITTEES THANK YOU. IN THEN I
WANT TO THANK YOU. AN INMATE
EVEN TO YOU UP ON IT IT'S THIS
BILL DOESN'T GET OUT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. TASHA BOERNER HORVATH-
PROBABLY BRING IN A BILL. THAT
ON THIS PARTICULAR SUBJECT WE
WILL ALSO PROVIDE- SOME BUDGET
FUNDING. TO HELP. WITH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING- I OFFERED IT TO
OTHER MEMBERS. OF THE ASSEMBLY
THEY ALTERED DIAL. UP I HOPE
THAT YOU'RE SINCERE IN WANTING
TO WORK WITH- THE DISTINGUISHED
SIMPLY WOMAN BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS THE FIRST THIS WOULD BE
THE FIRST BILL THAT NOT ONLY
ADDRESSES IT FROM A- FROM A
LEGAL STANDPOINT WITH WITH
POLICIES. AND PROCEDURES BUT
ALSO PUT SOME MONEY BEHIND IT- I
WILL TELL YOU DOESN'T GO AS FAR
AS WHAT MR CORK WOULD LIKE TO DO
BUT IT DIDN'T. I THINK IT'S
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE AND BOOKABLE
ADDRESS- A LOT OF YOUR CONCERNS
AS AND LET'S IF IT DOESN'T MAKE
IT OUT HERE LET'S LET'S REALLY
HAVE DEBT SERVICE CONVERSATION
AND- HOPE YOU TALK TO THEASSEMBLY WOMAN UP AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT IF THIS IS
SOMETHING YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH YOU WANT TO JOIN- BUT I
ALSO OFFER. YOUR STEAM- WITNESS
IF HE WANTS TO ALSO PARTICIPATE
I THINK THIS WOULD BE GREAT- SO
UNFORTUNATELY I'D HAVE TO DISENO
BOAT- AND- CALDERON. ON A BILL
TWENTY ONE P. ONE BY I'M A
MEMBER RICHARD GET THE MOTION
DUE PASS TO BE APPROPRIATION
COMMITTEE. JONES SAWYER
RESPECTFULLY NOW JONES SAWYER NO
LACKEY. LACKEY I BONTA. BRIAN
RYAN NO QUIRK NO WORK NO
SANTIAGO. SEYARTO HI THEY ARE
TOO HIGH. A MEASURE FAILS. AB SO
YOU'RE ASKING FOR
RECONSIDERATION THAT'S GONNA
RECONSIDERATION THERE'S NO
OBJECTION WE WILL GRANT
RECONSIDERATION BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT THANK YOU KNOW FOLLOW
QUOTE ASSEMBLY MEMBER PORTHOLE
LIKE THIS ONE THANK YOU. M.
REBECCA ASSEMBLY WOMAN REBEKAH
BAUR QUE HAN. WE HAVE TO BUILD
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOUR PATIENCE FINALLY WERE ABLE
TO- COMMITTEE UPSTAIRS. WHICH
WILL REACH DO YOU WANT TO DO
FIRST I WILL START WITH THE AB
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE IF THAT'S
OKAY. OKAY. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY TO GO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO START BY
ACTUALLY THINKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR HARD WORK. ON ALL
THREE OF MY BILLS INCLUDING AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FOUR WHICH
THERE ARE HARD WORK WAS ABLE TO
GET IN CONSENT WHICH I KNOW IS
BIG HELP TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY-
BUT RIGHT NOW I'M PRESENTING AB
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE. A BILL THAT
STRENGTHENS CRIMINAL FINES
AGAINST CORPORATIONS WHO ARE
CONVICTED OF STARTING WILDFIRES
DUE TO A LACK OF EDUCATION
ABATEMENT. AROUND POWER LINES.
IN CALIFORNIA NO INDIVIDUALS
INCARCERATED WHEN A CORPORATION
IS FOUND GUILTY OF CRIMES IN
WHICH THE PENALTY WOULD BE JAIL
OR PRISON. THE PENALTIES
AVAILABLE ARE FISCAL. IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE CAMPFIRE STARTED WHEN
UNMAINTAINED ELECTRICAL
EQUIPMENT FAILED SPARKING ON
MAIN TAIN VEGETATION BELOW THE
POWER LINES CAUSING A FIRE THAT
DESTROYED AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY
AND TOOK THE LIVES EIGHTY FOUR
INDIVIDUALS. WITH ONLY FINANCIAL
PENALTIES AVAILABLE BUTTE COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE MICHAEL
DEEMS IMPOSED THE HARSHEST
PENALTY ALLOWED UNDER CURRENT
LAW AGAINST PG&E WHICH AMOUNTED
TO THREE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS. THE EQUIVALENT OF THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
LIFE LOST. YOU CAN'T PUT AN
AMOUNT OF MONEY ON A LIFE LOST
BUT THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
JUSTICE TO ME. THIS IS A
CORPORATION BEING SLAPPED ON ITS
WRIST WITH A MINIMAL FINE THE
COURT'S HANDS ARE TIED TO THE
LOW MAXIMUM FINES UNDER CURRENT
LAW. IN JUDGE ALSUP'S FINAL
COMMENTS ON THE EXPIRATION OF P.
GENIES PROBATION IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR HE SAID. IN PROBATION
WITH THE GOAL OF REHABILITATION
IN MIND WE ALWAYS PREFER THAT
THE CRIMINAL OFFENDERS LEARN TO
ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. SADLY DURING THE FIVE
YEARS OF PROBATION PG&E HAS
REFUSED TO ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY
. FOR ITS ACTIONS UNTIL CONVENE
I AM INTEREST TO DO SO DURING
THE FIVE YEAR PROBATION FOR THAT
GAS PIPELINE EXPLOSION IN SAN
BRUNO WHICHKILLED EIGHT PEOPLE
P. GENIES MALFEASANCE AT THIRTY
ONE WILDFIRES BURNED NEARLY ONE
AND A HALF MILLION ACRES BURNED
ALMOST TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
STRUCTURES AND KILLED ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
CALIFORNIANS. ACTIONS SPEAK
LOUDER SOME LOUDER THAN WORDS
AND THE ACTIONS TO BE CLEAR THAT
THE OMPANY IS USING PROFITS
OVER THE SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE PROVIDES THE COURT WITH
ADDITIONAL TOOLS BY INCREASING
FINANCIAL PENALTIES FOR THOSE
FOUND CRIMINALLY GUILTY FOR
FIRES CAUSED BY THEIR FAILURE TO
ABATE VEGETATION AROUND THE
POWERLINES AND I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THE LEGISLATION IS
NARROWLY FOCUSED TO SAY THAT IT
HAS TO BE THE PRIMARY BECAUSE
OF. THE NEGLIGENCE OF THE
FAILURE TO OBEY IT HAS TO BE THE
PRIMARY CAUSE WITH ME TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE VEIL IS
FORMER CPUC COMMISSIONER
PROFESSOR CATHERINE SANDOVAL AND
BY PHONE WE HAVE ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY PAT COLLINS
WITH THE NAPA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AUDIBLE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS KATHERINE
SANDOVAL AND I'M A LAW PROFESSOR
AT TEN AT TEN A CAR UNIVERSITY
WHERE I'M A TENURED PROFESSOR. I
TEACH ENERGY LAWS RULES
COMMUNICATIONS LAW I'M A FORMER
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. AND I ALSO
HAD THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING AS
AND MAKE US PRO BONO. PG&E
RATEPAYERS IN P. GENIES FEDERAL
CRIMINAL PROBATION- IS WHICH
JUST CONCLUDED IN JANUARY. SO I
AM HONORED TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF. AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE AND THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR INTRODUCING IT. SO
THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE.
CRIMINAL PENALTIES ON UTILITIES
THAT RECKLESSLY CAUSE WILDFIRES
DUE TO CRIMINAL CRIMINAL
NEGLIGENCE AND WILLFUL NEGLECT
OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. SO AS
WAS MENTIONED THIS BILL IS
NEEDED TO PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY.
SAVE LIVES PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ALSO FORESTALL
CLIMATE CHANGE BECAUSE IT
INCREASINGLY THERE'S EVIDENCE
THAT WILDFIRES- PRODUCE
TREMENDOUS- PARTICULATES WHICH
ARE NOT ONLY HARMFUL TO HUMAN
HEALTH BUT ALSO SPUR CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND SELL THE CALIFORNIA
HAS SUFFERED MANY UTILITY
BECAUSE WILDFIRES INCLUDING
WILDFIRES DURING P. GENIES
CRIMINAL PROBATION. I SAID THE
FIRST WHAT ROLE OF FEDERAL
CRIMINAL PROBATION IS COMMITTED
NO MORE CRIMES AND YET PG&E
REFUSED TO PLEAD GUILTY EVEN
WHEN THEY WERE UNDER INDICTMENT
FOR ADDITIONAL CRIMES DURING
THEIR FEDERAL CRIMINAL PROBATION
. AND DURING THEIR PROBATION
PG&E WAS CONVICTED OF UNLAWFUL
FIRE START WHICH IS PENAL CODE
FOR FIFTY TWO WHICH IS ONE OF
THE TRIGGERS IN THIS BILL AS
WELL AS- EIGHTY FOUR COUNTS OF
INVOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER FOR THE
CAMPFIRE. PG&E IS ALSO CURRENTLY
UNDER INDICTMENT- IN CINEMA
COUNTY FOR THE KINCAID FIRE AND
IN SHASTA COUNTY FOR THOSE AUG
FIRE AND SADLY IT FOR THIS LOG
FIRE THEY'RE ALSO FOR
ALLEGATIONS OF INVOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER DUE TO P. GENIES
CONTACT. SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO
DETER OF. CRIMINAL CONDUCT AND
IT APPLIES PENALTIES AND
ENHANCES THE PENALTIES TO
CRIMINALLY RECKLESS CONDUCT. SO
FOR ME I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT THIS
BILL DOES AND THE JURISDICTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WHICH I'VE
HAD THE HONOR OF SERVING ON. SO
THE CPUC HAS NO POWER TO ENFORCE
THE CRIMINAL LAW. THE CPSC
ENFORCES THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE AND ITS OWN RULES
ORDERS AND DECISIONS. WITH THE
CPUC DOESN'T CONDUCT CRIMINAL
HEARINGS ITS JUDGES ARE NOT
DESIGNED TO DO THAT IT'S
EVIDENCE THAT- GATHERING IS NOT
DESIGNED TO DO THAT THEY HAVE NO
CRIMINAL ENFORCEMENT POWER. SO
THIS BILL WOULD ONLY APPLY WHERE
THERE HAS BEEN A CRIMINAL
INDICTMENT AND CONVICTION. SO
IT'S ALSO WORTH EMPHASIZING THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE STANDARDS
BETWEEN CRIMINAL LAW AND AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
CODE. SO FOUR CPUC VIOLATIONS
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT EVEN FOR
FINDING OF NEGLIGENCE LET ALONE
RECKLESSNESS AND NEVER
REQUIREMENT FOR A FINDING OF
CRIMINAL NEGLIGENCE. ON THE
OTHER HAND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
CONVICTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA PENAL
CODE FOR FIFTY TWO UNLAWFUL FIRE
START TO BASICALLY UNINTENTIONAL
ARSON. AND THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR CRIMINAL
RECKLESSNESS TO BE FOUND TO HAS
A WELL YES THANK YOU HAVE
ANOTHER WITNESS TO THANK YOU-
ALL CODES UP AS WELL AS A
REQUIREMENT FOR CRIMINAL
NEGLIGENCE WITH REGARD TO THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE. SO IN
CLOSING THIS BILL IS NOT
DUPLICATIVE THERE ARE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF LAWS BOTH CRIMINAL LAWS
THAT APPLY TO ORDINARY PEOPLE AS
WELL AS TO CORPORATIONS THAT
CAUSE FIRES THROUGH CRIMINAL
WANTON NECKLACE NEGLIGENCE. AND
THIS IS A TARGETED INAPPROPRIATE
BUILD THAT WOULD HELP TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FROM
CRIMINAL CONDUCT BY UTILITIES
THANK YOU. I FOR MISC COLLINS BY
TELL. TO DISTRICT ATTORNEY AT
THE NAPA COUNTY. AT&T OPERATOR.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE LOCATOR
LINE. WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE
MISS COLLINS CONNECTED ON THAT
ISLAND LIFE. OKAY WELL. GO AHEAD
AND SEE IF YOU CAN FIND A WILL
GO TO WITNESSES SUPPORT IN A ROW
. CNN CAN YOU AT LEAST GO TO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT BETTER ON
THE PHONE. EVERYONE CAN YOU- CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES NAME AN ORGAN
OKAY GREAT THANK- THIS IS PAT
CALLING FROM A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN THE NAPA COUNTY-
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION SECTION
. I THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY THIS
MORNING- I WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING IMPORTANT GAP IN
WELFARE PROTECTION AND
ENFORCEMENT. IT HAD SIGNIFICANT
FINES IN THE PRIMARY ACT OF
RECKLESSNESS THE CAUSE OF THE
FIRE IS A FAILURE TO CLEAR
HOUSES TREES AND VEGETATION
BROWN POWERFUL THE LINES. AND
BEYOND ADDING APPROPRIATE
PUNISHMENT FOR THE RECKLESSLY
START FIRES. THE POSSIBILITY OF
SUCH FINES WILL ENCOURAGE
COMPLIANCE WITH VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WHICH- WILL HELP
PREVENT WILDFIRES AND FUTURE. I
THINK THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM
OF THIS BILL ATTEMPTS IN PART TO
ADDRESS HIGHLIGHTED BY JUDGE
ALSO TO COMMENT. ON THE
EXPIRATION OF PG&E PROBATION.
AND STATED THAT WE REMAIN
pPG&E WILDFIRES BECAUSE FOR
DECADES IT NEGLECTED ITS DUTIES
CONCERNING HAZARDOUS TREE
REMOVAL OF VEGETATION CLEARANCE.
EVEN THOUGH SUCH DUTIES WERE
REQUIRED BY THE PUBLIC RESOURCES
CODE. IN TIMES TO COLLECT LEAD
HAZARD TREES FALLING ON
DISTRIBUTION LINES SPARKING
WILDFIRES. DURING ITS CRIMINAL
PROBATION ALL OR VIRTUALLY ALL
THE WHILE FIRE STARTED BY PG&E
DISTRIBUTION LINES HAVE INVOLVED
HAZARD TREES. I THINK THAT THE
ACK OF ADEQUATE PENALTIES FOR
CRIMINAL CONDUCT EXPLAINS AT
LEAST IN PART. WHAT THE PROBLEM
OF FAILURE TO CLEAR HAZARDOUS
TREES AND VEGETATION HAS
PERSISTED FOR SO LONG. CURRENTLY
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE SECTIONS.
FOUR TWO NINE ZERO FOUR TWO NINE
THREE ARE PUNISHABLE
MISDEMEANORS THE MAXIMUM FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. A FELONY
VIOLATION OF PENAL CODE SECTION
FOUR FIVE TWO WHICH REQUIRES
RECKLESS RECKLESSLY CAUSING A
FIRE THAT BURNS INHABITED
STRUCTURES OR CAUSES GREAT
BODILY INJURY CARRIED A MAXIMUM
FINE OF TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THAT'S ALL THE PUNISHMENT TO
GUILTY CORPORATION SUFFER
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GO TO JAIL.
THANK YOU COULD LEAD TO CRIMINAL
FIND ADDED BY THIS. YEAH I AM
I'M DOING IT RIGHT NOW. OKAY SO
IT ADDS. THE REFLECTS
SERIOUSNESS THE CONDUCT IT WILL
HELP. WITH DETERRENCE IT WILL
HELP TO PREVENT WILDFIRES IN
FUTURE. SO FOR THAT REASON WE
ASK YOU TO PASS A BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. AND ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AT&T
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY FOUR GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CAN PHONE STONE ADVOCATING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
THAT THE FUNDS ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GET YOUR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE AND YOU AT THIS TIME
AND NOW WE LISTEN TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. IN THE ROOM. AB
BRANDON FEEDBACK FOR PG&E N.
ADAM SMITH SAID S. C. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. DURING THE PERSON
GRAHA HELLO. THANK YOU CHAIR
ADAM SMITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON RESPECTFULLY OPPOSING AB
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE THIS BILL
IGNORES THE AND UNNECESSARILY
DUPLICATES EXISTING ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS AND AGGRESSIVE SAFETY
COMMITMENTS AND ARE WHILE FOR
MITIGATION PLAN IT ALSO
DISREGARD SAFETY RELATED FINDS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
RECENTLY INCREASED WE BELIEVE
THAT THE BILL ALSO UNDERCUTS THE
SIGNIFICANT RECENT ACTIONS TAKEN
BY THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE
TO STABILIZE THE FINANCIAL
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIA WESTERN
UTILITIES. WE WOULD ARGUE THT
THE EXISTING ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS ARE NOT BROKEN AB
TWENTY THREE WOULD COMPLICATE
AND DUPLICATE EXISTING UTILITY
SAFETY ENFORCEMENT PROCESSES AND
PENALTIES WHICH HAVE BEEN
UTILIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
ISSUE FINES INTO THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS P. JEANNIE WHO WILL
SPEAK NEXT YOU COULD ASK THEM
ABOUT THIS HAS RECENTLY BEEN
FINED OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
TO SUGGEST IF AN INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY CAN BE FINED TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THE INCENTIVES FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH A UTILITY
MEDICATION PLANS IS ALREADY
THERE. WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD. REMIND
ITSELF AND TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT
THE RECENT SIGNIFICANT PENALTY
INCREASES THAT WERE PASSED IN SB
NINE A ONE. NO AFTER IF YOU TAKE
A LOOK. AT SB NINE ONE PASSED
BACK IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
INCREASE THE FINES FROM FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER OFFENSE.
AND IF A VIOLATION IS OF A
CONTINUING NATURE EACH DAY IS A
SEPARATE AND DISTINCT DIFFERENCE
WE THINK THAT FURTHER
CRIMINALIZATION OF VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING THE CREATION OF
MULTIPLE VENUES WHETHER IT'S THE
COURTS AND NOT THE PC. FROM
FORCING THE SAME OBLIGATIONS IS
UNNECESSARY. AND FINALLY WE
WOULD ARGUE THAT THE BILL
UNDERMINES EXTENSIVE EFFORTS TO
STABILIZE INVESTOR CONFIDENCE IN
CALIFORNIA UTILITIES. AS WE SAID
IN A BEFORE IN WERE UNDERMINING
THE RECENT WILDFIRE PACKAGE. SB
NINE A ONE AB TEN FIFTY FOUR
WITH THIS BILL THE LEGISLATURE
PASSES BILLS THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
THEM. TO TRY TO ENCOURAGE THE
UTILITIES FINANCIAL STABILITY
AND VIABILITY IN THE FUTURE. BY
PLACING EXCESSIVE UNNECESSARY
PENALTIES ON UTILITY VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES. THE STATE
WOULD ONCE AGAIN PUT IOUS AT
RISK OF LOSING INVESTOR
CONFIDENCE AND AS WE KNOW
THROUGH THE SB NINE A ONE MAYBE
TEN FIFTY FOUR DISCUSSIONS. WHEN
INVESTOR CONFIDENCE OUR ROADS.
HAT LEADS TO RATE INCREASES FOR
OUR CUSTOMERS IF TO THE COST OF
BORROWING. INCREASE THOSE GET
PASSED ON TO OUR CUSTOMERS WHEN
WE DO GO OUT FOR WORK. SO WE
THINK THAT THERE'S A STRONG
ROBUST FRAMEWORK. EVERY
INCENTIVE IN THE WORLD WHICH
COULD INCLUDE YOU KNOW FINES UP
TO INTO THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR THE UTILITIES DO THE RIGHT%
THING TO PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY
WE- APPLAUDED THE LEGISLATURES.
IN A YOU KNOW. BILLS ENCOURAGING
UTILITY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT. WE SUPPORTED SB NINE
OH ONE WE SUPPORT OF AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR BUT WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL TODAY AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO DO AS WELL. THANK YOU- SPREAD
ANY BACK PACIFIC GAS LIKE THE
AMERICAN I'M NOT FIRST TIME
DOING THIS- WE AGREE WITH ALL
THE CALLS WERE WITH THERE'S NO
OF ABILITY HOLD US FINANCIAL FOR
ANY OF OUR THURS NO SHORT OF
ABILITIES TO COME AT CHARGERS
WITH COLONEL CONNECTIONS- WE ARE
SUBJECT ADVERSE COMBINATIONS OF
ANY FIRE WE STARTED TO ANY
LIABILITY THAT IS SOMETHING WE
ARE CAPABLE FOR AND WE BELIEVE
THAT VICTIMS SHOULD BE
COMPENSATED DIRECTLY. THIS BILL
DOESN'T QUITE DO THAT IT
INCREASES FINES FOR CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS WHICH DON'T
NECESSARILY GO DIRECTLY TO
VICTIMS OR THE AT. ARMS FOR WHAT
WE DO. WHEN WE PAY FOR COUNTIES
REFUSE. THOSE PENALTIES ARE NOT
RECOVERABLE REPAIRS ARE MORE
STRICTLY BY SHAREHOLDERS. THOSE
FINES ARE GENERALLY COMBINATION
OF OFFSETS TO REPAIR
CONTRIBUTIONS THEY'RE- USUALLY
SOMETIMES DIRECTED INTO UPGRADE
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH WE ARE
ALL IN THE BENEFICIAL INTEREST
OF. AND THERE'S ADDITIONAL-
PAYMENTS BACK TO GENERAL FUND TO
BENEFIT THE STATE FOR COSTS OF
FIGHTING FIRES ONE THING I WOULD
LIKE TO FLAG IS. THE PC HAS
EXTENSIVE FINING AUTHORITY AS
DISCUSSED BY ADAM BUT- THAT
EXCLUSIVELY APPLIES TO PC
REGULATED ENTITIES THE BILL
BEFORE YOU WOULD LOOK AND PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE SECTION FORTY TWO
NINETY TWO AND FORTY NINETY
THREE. WHICH DON'T. WHICH
DOESN'T JUST APPLY TO LOCAL
CORPORATIONS PUBLIC UTILITIES.
PRIVATE LINES INCLUDING THE- THE
FIRE WAS STARTED BY PRIVATE
INFRASTRUCTURE. TRAVEL
GOVERNMENT'S REMOTE MICRO GRANTS
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES HOSPITALS
COMMITTEE COLLEGES INDUSTRIAL
ACTOR CUSTOMERS AND THE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES. THEY
ALL OF. MAINTAIN- OUT GOING FOR
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED FOLD THAT
WOULD BE. TO INCREASED CRIMINAL
FIVE FOR. CORTICAL THE DEATH OF
RECKLESS. ONLY INCLUDE.
KNOWLEDGE AND A DECISION TO NOT
TREAT IT. THERE ARE PLENTY OF
REASONS- IN EXISTING LAW WITH
REGULATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF WHY WE CAN'T
ALWAYS TREAT EVERY VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ISSUE WE ARE FACING
WE HAVE. A BACKLOG OF EDUCATE
MANAGERS WE ALL MET THAT WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER.
TO ADDRESS THAT AS ADAM
MENTIONED ANY TIME WE HAVE OUR-
WORST CREDIT RATING IT JUST
MEANS WE HAVE TO SPEND MORE
CUSTOMER DOLLARS. TO GO OUT AND
WORK ON THAT BACKLOG. BUT WE DO
FACE ISSUES INCLUDING FOR
ALAMEDA COUNTY THERE'S A LOT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- WHERE THEY
WILL WITHHOLD THE CRUSHER
PERMITS DUE TO OUR- WE HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION WHERE THEY
WOULD LIKE US TO RE PLANTED TREE
EVERYWHERE WE CUT IT OUT OF
TREES DUE TO ALAMEDA COUNTY
ORDINANCE. HE IS THE AUTHORITIES
PRETTY CLEAR THAT IT SUPERSEDES.
THE GOVERNMENT BUT WE STILL
CAN'T RECEIVING PRESSURE PERMITS
FROM THE COUNTY. THOSE ISSUES
ARE PERVASIVE ACROSS MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. WE FACE ISSUES FROM
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS ENVIRONMENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DISAGREE WITH
OUR DETERMINATION IS TO CUT DOWN
TREES. THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE
SECTIONS ARE MINIMUM STANDARDS
ANYTHING ABOVE THAT WE RELY ON.
RESTER PRESSURE FORSTER'S
ARBORISTS ACTUAL EXPERTS TO
DETERMINE WHICH TREES WE SHOULD
TREAT. THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
PRODUCTION PROBABLY NOT BE
LITIGATED IN CRIMINAL COURT- WE
ALSO. EVEN STATUTE HAS A-
CONFLICT WHERE WE ARE REQUIRED
TO GO ON A PRIVATE PRIVATE LAND.
WHERE REQUIRED WE ARE ALLOWED TO
TRESPASS TO LAND BUT IF WE GO
AHEAD AND CUT DOWN THE TREE OR
TRIM THE TREE WITHOUT CONSENT OF
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNER THEY CAN
SUE US FOR TRESPASS. AND FOR
DAMAGES THE PROPERTY FOR THE
VALUE TO TREAT THAT'S SOMETHING
WE ARE SPONSORING A BILL TO.
REMOVE ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
WOULD ONLY INCREASE OUR-
CONTRACTORS INSURANCE AMOUNTS
BECAUSE THEY WOULD BE FACING
MORE LIABILITY BECAUSE THEY ARE
ALSO HELD JOINTLY LIABLE WITH US
WHENEVER THEIR WORK DOESN'T
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE ISSUE. WE
HAVE A SHORTAGE OF CONTRACTING
CREWS AS OUR FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS- SO
I THINK IT'S SUMMARY WE WOULD
ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
THE ACTUAL FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES OF
WHY WE CAN'T. NECESSARILY ALWAYS
COMPLY WITH OUR BUDGET
MANAGEMENT REQUIREMENTS
SOMETHING WE'RE COMMITTED TO IT
SOMETHING WE PUT IN OUR WATER
MITIGATION PLANS SOME WEIRD
STRICTLY REGULATED BY. THE PC
AND THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INSTRUCTOR SAFETY THAT'S
RECENTLY ESTABLISHED AND WE ARE
UNDERGROUNDING TEN THOUSAND
MILES NEXT DECADE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO TO AVOID THE ENDLESS CYCLE
BATCH MANAGEMENT. WHICH IF YOU
COUNTRY INTEREST BACK WE ARE
COMMITTED TO GETTING AWAY FROM
THAT ISSUE BUT THAT'S NOT
PRODUCTIVE WITH THIS BILL SO
WE'D ASK FOR SUPPORT THAT. THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN A ROW. HELLO NIKOLINA NONE
THIS GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FIRST
AND YOUR GAS AND ELECTRIC ALSO
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THERE ON THE PHONE
LINE. SPEAKING OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. TWO
GERMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP.
J. THEN WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS CAN MISTER CLARK- A
TWO PAGE IN A OF WHO HAS THE
BILL- DEALING WITH- ACCESS
ACCESS TO TREES. IT'S ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR OKAY. THANK YOU
HOW ARE I'LL TALK MY LIKE AUTHOR
- I THINK THAT IS THE APPROACH
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE IT EASIER
TO TAKE THE STREET DOWN THAT I'M
ASHAMED THAT ALAMEDA COUNTY IS
MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT- I
THINK THAT IS THE APPROACH WE
SHOULDTAKE. I HAVE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE FOR TEN YEARS. AND I
HAVE NOT VOTED FOR ANY BILLS
THAT INCREASE PENALTIES. I VOTED
FOR BILLS THAT WOULD MAKE IT
EASIER TO CATCH THE BAD GUY TO
REFORM THE BAD GUY- THAT'S MY
PREFERRED APPROACH AND I'LL BE
ASKING TO BECOME A CO AUTHOR AND
BILL THANK YOU. IT WAS JUST HERE
TO. THANK YOU- THERE ARE A FEW
POINTS THAT WERE MADE THERE
MALCOLM- ELABORATE ON- NUMBER
ONE THE COSTS FOR THINGS LIKE
THIS JUST GET PASSED ALONG TO
CUSTOMERS WE'VE ALREADY BEEN HIT
YES THEY DO THERE THERE ALONG
EIGHT EIGHT AT THE END OF THE
DAY IF THEY'RE COSTS EXCEED WHAT
THEY'RE BEING ABLE TO CHARGE
CUSTOMERS FOR- THEY GO TO THE P.
YOU SEE AS YOU KNOW. AND AND
THOSE FOLKS- WILL WILL PASS
THOSE ELECTRIC RATES ALONG TO
US- I'VE SEEN MY BILL INCREASE
TEN FOLD SINCE THE LAST FEW
YEARS- JUST DUE TO THE INCREASED
COSTS FOR THE CHILES. THE BIGGER
ISSUE HERE IS THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT- THE UTILITY
COMPANIES DO NOT DO NOT CREATE
AN OVER VEGETATION OF CALIFORNIA
ARE LAWS DO OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
LAW EFFORTS DO ALL OF THOSE DO.
AND FOR US TO SAY THAT THEY ARE
SOLELY RESPONSIBLE FOR- D.
IGNITION- YEAH OU KNOW THERE A
LOT OF IGNITION SOURCES OUT
THERE BUT WE DON'T SU MOTHER
NATURE BECAUSE SHE SENDS DOWN A
LIGHTNING STRIKE DURING A LIGHT
DRY LIGHTNING STORM. AND A LOT
OF FIRES ARE STARTED LIKE THAT.
THE UNDERLYING CAUSE OF ALL OF
IT IS OUR VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
IN CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN NEGLECTED
FOR A HUNDRED YEARS AND WE ARE
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE AND CATCHING
UP WITH THAT. AND WE HAVE
CREATED BARRIERS TO PEOPLE
INCLUDING THE UTILITY COMPANIES
TO CLEARING THEIR BRUSH. IF IT'S
PRIVATELY OWNED AS IT IS STATED
BEFORE I CAN'T EVEN GET SOMEBODY
WHEN I WAS DOING BRUSH CLEARANCE
INSPECTIONS FOR THE COUNTY I
COULDN'T GO ON PRIVATE PEOPLE'S
PROPERTY ADD TO GO LOOK AT. FOR
IT THEIR PROPERTY FROM ANOTHER
HILL AND THEN SEND THEM A NOTICE
SAY HEY YOU REALLY NEED TO TRIM
THIS DOWN- BUT- YOU KNOW AT THE
END OF THE DAY. WE HAVE LAWS
THAT PROTECT PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS FROM HAVING. SOMEBODY
ELSE COME ONTO THEIR PROPERTY
AND REMOVE BRUSH. AND SO UNTIL
WE ADDRESS THE BIGGER ISSUE
WHICH IS OUR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
REGULATIONS AND LAWS THAT
PREVENT US FROM DOING A BETTER
JOB AT THAT WE CAN'T PINPOINT
EVERYTHING ON. ON ONE WANTED ME
TO UTILITY COMPANIES OR DID
MANUFACTURERS OF BRAKES ON
TRUCKS THAT PULL OVER TO THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD WITH HOT BREAKS
AND LIGHT FIRES THAT WAY. OR
MOTHER NATURE AND HER LIGHTNING
STRIKES OR SOMEBODY'S IN THEIR
BACKYARD WITH ELECTRIC GENERATOR
OR SOMEBODY OUT DOING SOME BRUSH
CLEARANCE WHO ACTUALLY HAD TO
STONE WITH THEIR- BRUSH
CLEARANCE MATERIAL AND CREATE TO
SPARK WHICH SENDS OFF A FIRE. SO
BRUSH CLEARANCE IS THE WARY WHAT
HOWARD GO AND BRUSH MANAGEMENT
AND- FEEL MANAGEMENT IS HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET OUT OF THIS.
NOT BY CREATING MORE MECHANISMS
TO OR THAT YOU HAVE COSTS THAT
ARE PASSED ALONG TO WHO US THE
RATEPAYERS. AND AND I JUST I
THINK THERE IS ENOUGH- BOOTED OF
MEASURES IN PLACE. WE'VE WE TALK
OVER AND OVER ABOUT YOU KNOW
THESE THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT-
THEY'RE NOT EFFECTIVE. WHEN AND
DOING MORE IS NOT GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE BUT THEN IN THIS SPACE
WERE SAYING OH NO WE CAN DO MORE
MORE IN IT SOMEHOW GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE. WHAT'S GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE IT'S GETTING A HANDLE
ON OUR FUEL MANAGEMENT. AND
WE'RE NOT DOING THE THINGS WE
NEED TO DO. POLICY WISE AS A
STATE AND AS A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO. TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE A REAL IMPACT ON THIS WE
NEED ELECTRICITY. WE'RE TRYING
TO BE TOTALLY DEPENDENT ON
LECTURE CITY. SO THE ONLY WAY TO
LIMON EIGHT THAT IS TO ELIMINATE
ELECTRICITY AND WE'RE NOT GOING
TO DO THAT. SO. MEASURES
PROJECTED TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
BUT THAT'S THAT'S NOT THE
PROBLEM THE PROBLEM IS YOU
MANAGEMENT AND THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
THE BILL MISTER BRIAN I. YES WE
TALK A LOT ABOUT THE FACT THAT
FINES AND FEES AN ADDITIONAL
PENALTIES HARD BLACK BROWN POOR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND WE GET A
LOT OF PUSH BACK FROM THE SAME
FOLKS WHO USE THAT THEN LOGIC
NOT TO APPLY TO CORPORATE
UTILITY ENTITIES. AND THAT'S-
THAT I'M DUMBFOUNDED- BY THAT
ABILITY TO APPLY THAT LOGIC IN
CERTAIN CASES AND NOT APPLIED IN
OTHER CASES OF COURSE THERE ARE
A LOT OF THINGS WE NEED TO DO
WITH BRUSH MANAGEMENT AND MAKING
SURE- THAT FIRES AREN'T STARTED
IN THAT WE CAN STILL HAVE
SUCCESSFUL UTILITIES THAT DON'T
INCREASE THE RATES ON
INDIVIDUALS- ALL OF THAT IS
IMPORTANT BUT I DON'T SEE THAT
THIS BILL IS IN VIOLATION OF
THAT- GIVEN THAT IT ONLY. ADDS
ARE AUTHORIZES THIS FINE IF
CONVICTED OF A MISDEMEANOR OR
FELONY VIOLATION FOR STARTING A
FIRE. WHICH IS A- WILDLY COMMON
OCCURRENCE AND FAR TOO COMMON
OCCURS AND SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
. THANK YOU IN YOUR WAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FOR THE DISCUSSION- I LIVE IN P.
JEANNIE TERRITORY ON THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE. I
DON'T SLEEP WHEN IT'S WINDY I
SET UP WAITING. BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT I'M AT RISK BECAUSE OF THE
FAILURE TO MAINTAIN THESE LINES
TO DO THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
AND YES OUR UTILITY RATES ARE
TOO HIGH THERE TOO HIGH BECAUSE
FOR TOO LONG UTILITIES BEEN
PUTTING INVESTORS FIRST. AND NOT
OUR STATE. AND ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
WE DIDN'T NEED AN AUDIT THE
AUDIT THE CAME OUT LAST WEEK TO
TELL US THE WCT ISN'T DOING
THEIR JOB. TO HOLD UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE WE SEE IT
WHEN OUR STATE BURNS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR AT THE HANDS OF
UTILITIES. BUT NOW WE HAVE THE
AUDIT TO TELL US WHAT WE ALREADY
KNEW. AND SO IT IS INCUMBENT
UPON US. TO DO WHAT IT TAKES TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITY SAFE. SAFE
FROM THE THREATS TODAY WHEN THE
WIND BLOWS AND THEIR FAILURE
STARTS A FIRE IN COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE. AND FROM THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE YES THIS IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST CONTRIBUTORS TO CLIMATE
CHANGE RIGHT NOW. SO FOR NOW AND
MY KIDS FUTURE WE NEED BE
DOUBLING DOWN IN MAKING SURE
THAT EVERY SINGLE FORM IN THIS
STATE HAS THE ABILITY TO HOLD.
THESE COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE AND
YOU KNOW WHAT. WE THINK THIS A
LOT IN THIS COMMITTEE I USED TO
SIT ON THIS COMMITTEE. IF YOU'RE
NOT DOING ANYTHING WRONG YOU'VE
GOT NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT. GO
DO YOUR JOB. AND THEN THESE
FINES WILL NEVER COME TO PASS.
BUT THAT ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU
IN IT THIS IS A- BUT A TOUGH
ONE- AND IN FACT- I USED. GIVE
ME THAT I HAD A LOT OF JOBS
BEFORE I GOT THIS JOBBUT I USED
TO BE DIRECTOR REAL ESTATE AND I
JUST REMEMBER THE VEGETATION
THAT. DEPARTMENT WATER POWER.
NEEDED TO CLEAR. AND I REMEMBER
ACTUARIAL. GOING THROUGH A
SCENARIO OF. WHAT WOULD IT COST
FOR A LAWSUIT VERSUS. DURING THE
ACTUAL CLEANUP IN MANAGING THE
VEGETATION AND READ WOULD HAVE
LAWYERS AN ACTUARIAL SAY IT'S
CHEAPER TO JUST NOT DO ANYTHING
AT TAKE THE LAWSUIT. THEN BUT
NOBODY EVER TALKED ABOUT THE
LIFE STEP COULD BE LOST OR
WHATNOT WE WOULD BANKRUPT
DEPARTMENT WATER POWER AND IT
JUST DROVE ME ABSOLUTELY CRAZY
AS A- AS A PUBLIC SERVANT THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING WE NEEDED TO
DO. SO I GENUINE BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED. TO RELAX REALLY MAKE
UTILITY VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY. IS TO
BE A PRIORITY NOT ONLY FOR
UTILITIES COMPANIES. BUT IT
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY FOR US AND
- EVEN IF IN THE END OF THIS.
DRIVES PEOPLE CRAZY EVEN IF IT
MEANS WE NEED TO ALSO. FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO PUT MONEY TOWARDS
THAT BECAUSE IN THE IN THE BIG
PICTURE IS- IT HURTS EVERYONE I
WISH I WISH WE HAD MORE TIME TO
WORK ON THIS I THINK WE COULD IF
WE WERE TO TAKE THIS ON TO A NEW
HOST UTILITIES IF I WERE TO GET
OUT HERE. YOUR NEW NCM. BECAUSE
IT DOES NEED MORE MORE
DISCUSSION. IN THE AUTHOR NEEDS
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE AN OPEN
DIALOGUE. WITH THE WITH THE
ENERGY COMPANIES- AND I THINK
BECAUSE OF THE FIRES AND IF
YOU'RE IN HI EVERYBODY WAS
TRYING TO BLAME SOMEONE IT JUST
GOT IT WE JUST I WAS HERE WHEN
WE HAD THOSE DISCUSSIONS IT JUST
NEVER GOT TO- WELL I THINK SO
MEMBERS ON THIS COMMITTEE HAS
SAID ACTUALLY CARE IN A PROBLEM.
AND IN MAKING THAT AN EMPHASIS-
INSTEAD OF JUST SAYING IT'S NOT
MY JOB TO SOMEBODY ELSE'S JOB-
WHEN IN FACT IT'S ALL OF OUR
JOBS UP TO GET THIS DONE BECAUSE
AT THE END OF THE DAY- FREE LOSE
ONE LIFE. BEHIND THIS IS JUST
ONE LIFE TO ME AND THAT SHOULD
BE THE GOAL SPECIAL ON WHEN HAVE
US TALKING ABOUT BIG TERMS ALL
THE TIME THIS S SOMETHING WE
COULD WE COULD ACTUALLY WORK
TOGETHER TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
VICTIMS- I WILL BE VOTING FOR
TODAY AND IF WE WERE. TO MAKE IT
THROUGH- I I'LL BE ACTED.
WORKING WITH THE CHARITY TELL
THESE- RESERVING MY VOTE IF IT
MAKES IT TO THE FLOOR- ON WHAT
I'M GOING TO DO BECAUSE THAT I
MAY MAY NOT VOTE FOR IT WHEN IT
GETS TO THE FLOOR BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T HAVE. ENOUGH IN NEAR
ABOUT UTILITY VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT I THINK THIS BILL
COULD GET THERE HI HERE TO OTHER
BILLS MOVING ALONG AND- AND MAY
WE COULD COLLAPSE SIMILAR READ
THEY NEED TO BE IN CONCERT WE
SHOULD NOT BE DOING SEPARATELY.
AND SO WITH THAT- I'VE MAKE THE
MOTION. ON AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE BY SEVEN MEMBER BARRICADE
HAND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER IRAQI BLACKIE NO BONTA.
BRIAN BRIAN I WORK. QUIRK NO
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I SEYARTO NO
SEYARTO NO PICTURES IT MEASURES
UP NO DETAILS. THE FIVE VOTES TO
GET IT OUT SANTA MONICA. BURKE
SAID NO- CREDIT- SO THEN I MOVED
FOR RECONSIDERATION SIR YES.
THERE'S NO OBJECTION WILL BE
GRANTED RECONSIDERATION BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. I AM NOT ON
THE COMMITTEE ANYMORE I FORGOT.
IT'S STILL FIVE OF. JUST LAST
MEMBERS I THINK GREAT MMHM YEAH-
BUT IT STAYS THE SAME EVEN OVER
SEVEN STATE THE NUMBER- OKAY
WITH NUMBER NGUYEN AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT ITEM NUMBER FOUR
YOU'VE BEEN OUT ELECTRONIC
MONITORING. SEVERAS TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR I HAVE THE WRONG
NUMBER IN FRONT OF ME THANK YOU
MISTER. I HAVE HELP. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF ON TO AB
TWENTY SIX C. NINETY SEVEN
NUMBER BECAUSE MANY GET WRONG
AND AT PRESENTING A BILL THAT
ENSURES- EQUITY FOR YOUTH IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM BY
ALLOWING THEM TO RECEIVE CUSTODY
CREDITS TOWARD THEIR SENTENCES
WHEN PLACED ON ELECTRIC MONITORS
A MONUMENTAL SHIFT IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS UNDER
WAY AS WE ALL KNOW INSPIRED BY
THE WIDE RECOGNITION THAT
INCARCERATION IS NOT THE
SOLUTION TO YOUTH CRIME. AS WE
MOVE AWAY FROM INCARCERATION
ELECTRONIC MONITORING HAS GAINED
WIDESPREAD SUPPORT AS AN
ALTERNATIVE FOR YOUTH OFFENDERS
IN CALIFORNIA OVER 90% OF
COUNTIES USES TECHNOLOGY
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND YOUTH
ARE PLACED ON ELECTRIC MONITORS
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS HOWEVER
UNLIKE ADULTS THESE YOUTH CAN
REMAIN ON ANKLE MONITORS FOR
MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS WITHOUT
EARNING ANY CUSTODY CREDITS.
OWNER REPEAT THAT THE JUVENILES
ARE NOT GIVEN CREDIT BUT ADULTS
ARE. CURRENTLY BY LAW JUDGES
MAKE UP YOUTH ON ANKLE MONITORS
AND PROBATION INDEFINITELY. THE
UNMITIGATED USES OF ELECTRONIC
MONITORING FOR LOVE RESULTS IN
DETERIORATION IN MENTAL HEALTH
PERSONAL WELL BEING AND
RECIDIVISM. ELECTRONIC
MONITORING ITS EFFECTS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
INFLICTED UPON YOU THE COLOR.
THIS BILL WILL REMEDY THIS BY
REQUIRING A JUDICIAL REVIEW FOR
YOUTH PLACED ON ELECTRONIC
MONITORS FOR PERIOD LONGER THAN
THIRTY DAYS AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT WILL ALSO REQUIRE LONG
OVERDUE DATA COLLECTION TO
MEASURE WHETHER ELECTRONIC
MONITORS FURTHER REHABILITATIVE
GOALS. SO WE ARE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THE CHAIR ALWAYS ASKS FOR
WHICH IS MORE DATA TO MAKE
DECISIONS AROUND OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WORKS. TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WE HEAR STORIES ABOUT
YOUTH BEING CURSED RATED DUE TO
TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY EIGHT WILL PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED OVERSIGHT ON THE
USAGE OF THESE ELECTRONIC
MONITORS AND THIS PERPETUAL
CYCLE. WITH ME TODAY AND SUPPORT
OUR LAURA ARROYO PRESIDENT OF
THE PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER
CENTER AND IT'S ALSO POLICY
COORDINATOR AT FRESH LIFELINES
FOR YOU I'M- SORRY. THANK YOU.
IN MY SIXTEEN YEARS AS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN ALAMEDA COUNTY I
HANDLED EVERY TYPE OF CASE AND
I'VE SEEN IT ALL. BUT LET ME
TELL YOU ABOUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT GOT TO ME THE MOST. I'VE
ONLY CRIED IN COURT ON THE
RECORD TWICE IN MY CAREER AND
ONE OF THEM WAS SURROUNDING. THE
INJUSTICE OF ELECTRONIC
MONITORING AND YOUTH OF COLOR. I
REPRESENTED A YOUNG MAN NAMED
DARIAN WHO HAD STOLEN A PACKAGE
FROM THE DOORSTEP. LIKE MANY
AFRICAN AMERICAN YOUTH HE WAS
NOT GIVEN A WARNING AND SENT
HOME HE WAS HANDCUFFED AND TAKEN
TO JUVENILE HALL. WHEN HE
APPEARED IN COURT WITH ME
BECAUSE HE APPEARED IN CUSTODY
THE JUDGE WAS ONLY WILLING TO
RELEASE HIM WITH AN ELECTRONIC
MONITOR. WHEN HE APPEARED FOR
PROGRESS REPORTS TO TAKE THE
MONITOR OFF THE JUDGE WOULD
ALWAYS FIND A REASON TO EXTEND
THE TIME ON MONITORING. I DON'T
LIKE YOUR ATTITUDE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MORE DAYS- JUST GET THE
SEASON TO BEES THEN I'LL-
CONSIDER TAKING YOU OFF OR- IF
YOU WOULD JUST FOLLOW THE RULES
PERFECTLY THEN I WOULD CONSIDER
TAKING YOU OFF I'LL SEE YOU
AGAIN IN SIXTY DAYS. AFTER TEN
MONTHS OF BEING TOLD NO WE BOTH
CRIED. THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE
RULES ARE NOT WRITTEN FOR THE
ADOLESCENT BRAIN THEY DON'T
ALLOW TEENAGERS TO GO OUT AND
HANG OUT WITH THEIR FRIENDS OR
GO PLAY BASKETBALL AT THE PARK.
AND SO KIDS VIOLATE AND THEY
ROTATE IN AND OUT OF CUSTODY
EACH TIME MISSING SCHOOL AND
GETTING FURTHER AND FURTHER
BEHIND AND STARTING TO TAKE ON
THE PERSONA AND THE IDENTITY AND
THE STIGMA OF CRIMINAL. SOME SAY
GPS OF ALL OF ITS PROBLEMS IS A
IS BETTER THAN JAIL. BUT BETTER
THAN JAIL IS A PRETTY LOW BAR
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT KIDS.
THIS BILL WILL FIND WAYS TO
CLEAN UP THE PROBLEMS WITH GPS
TO MAKE IT A MORE PRECISE AND
EFFECTIVE INTERVENTION FOR
YOUTH. FIRST IT WILL PROVIDE
CUSTODY CREDITS CURRENTLY ADULTS
GET TO CUSTODY CREDITS FOR EVERY
DAY THERE ON THE MONITOR THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE THAT YOU'D GET
ONE DAY OF CUSTODY CREDIT FOR
EVERY DAY THERE ON THE MONITOR.
SECOND IT WILL REQUIRE COURTS TO
HOLD THIRTY DAY REVIEWS WHICH
WILL ENCOURAGE COURTS TO EXPLORE
OTHER OPTIONS SUCH AS MENTORS
RATHER THE MONITORS. THIRD
PREVENTING LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
RECORDING AN EAVESDROPPING
CONVERSATIONS WILL PREVENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM LISTENING TO
CONVERSATIONS THEY SHOULDN'T BE
LISTENING TO. LIKE WHEN KIDS ARE
TALKING TO THEIR PARENTS OR
THEIR ATTORNEYS. AND FOURTH DATA
COLLECTION WILL ALLOW US TO
IDENTIFY PATTERNS OF
DISCRIMINATION AND ALSO TO
ASSESS WHETHER THE MONITORS ARE
CAUSING POOR OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE HI I'M TWENTY
SIX FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. YES NEXT. I GET
AFTERNOON OR MORNING ALMOST
AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS NIKOS JESS
ON THE YOUTH VOICE POLICY CODE
FOR FRESH I FUNDS FOR YOUTH- THE
YOUTH SERVING ORGANIZATION IN
THE BAY AREA WORKING WITH
FORMERLY AND CURRENTLY.
INCARCERATED YOUTH AND SYSTEM
IMPACTED FOLKS- IN ADDITION TO
BEING HERE ADVOCATING FOR THE
YOUTH THAT I WORK WITH- ALSO
HERE'S A FORMING CLOSER TO
PERSON. WHO HAS BEEN A JUVENILE
HALL AND ON HIM P. AS SOMEONE
HAS BEEN ON EMP I CAN TELL YOU
IT'S NOT CONDUCIVE TO
REHABILITATION- AND IS NOT AN
ALTERNATIVE TO INCARCERATION BUT
JUST ANOTHER FORM OF
INCARCERATION. INSTEAD OF BEING
LOCKED UP IN A JUVENILE HALL
YOU'RE NOT LOCKED UP INSIDE OF
YOUR HOME- THE ARBITRARY RULES
THAT THEY ARE PLACED ON YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON EMP ALLOW
FOR. YOUNG FOLKS TO GO THROUGH
CYCLES OF INCARCERATION WHERE
THEY'RE THEY'RE ON EMP FOR LET'S
SAY. THERE THE DAY THEY START
OFF AT NINETY DAYS ON EMP THEY
VIOLATE THEY GO INSIDE JUVENILE
HALL THEY COME BACK OUT AND THEY
CONTINUE THE CYCLE WHICH- WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE NINETY DAYS AND
IT TURNS INTO A YEAR- I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
. THESE ARE KIDS- N. AS WE'VE
SEEN FROM THE PANDEMIC AS ADULTS
RIGHT LIKE WE'VE WE'VE ALL HAD A
HARD TIME BEING IN OUR HOMES-
IT'S BEEN HARD FROM FOREST BE
ISOLATED FROM MY FRIENDS FROM MY
FAMILY TO BE AWAY FROM THE
THINGS THAT THAT MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES HOLE. BY- AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO BOOT TO
REMEMBER THAT A LOT OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON HIM P. ARE
PROBABLY NOT LIVING IN IN THE
HOMES THAT ARE IS NICE IS ALL OF
YOURS RIGHT- THIS GAVE FROM THE
HOME IS SOMETIMES THE- THE ONLY
A SKATED THEY HAVE FROM ABUSIVE
SITUATIONS- FROM NEGLECT. MAYBE
IT'S THE ONLY FORM OF
ENTERTAINMENT I- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO TREAT KIDS
LIKE KIDS AND GIVE THEM
OPPORTUNITIES. AND I THINK IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO GIVE YOUNG
PEOPLE THE SAME RIGHTS TAT
ADULTS HAVE RIGHT. THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO GET TIME SERVED
CREDIT FOR BEING ON EMP- THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO. BE PROVIDED
WITH THE BEST POSSIBLE CARE. ON
THE DESERVE OPPORTUNITY TO EXIT
THE PUNITIVE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND CONTINUE WITH THEIR
LIVES- SO I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU AND THEIR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. HI
FRETILIN'S A SAY YOU CAN ACTION
IN SUPPORT. MARGO GEORGE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. TEN MINUTES ANTI RESERVATION
COALITION SUPPORTING. GO TO
PHONE LINES INTO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ABC TWENTY SIX THIS
WEEK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
PARDON ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT. HELLO I THINK
THEY PUT INTO THE WRONG- BILL I
WAS CALLING IN ON AB. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. IN JUDICIARY. YEAH
I WOULD BE JUDICIARY WHERE THEY
ALSO SAID. THERE ARE DIFFERENT
CODE NUMBER THEN CLICK THIS IS I
CALLED THE JUDICIARY AND THEN
I'VE BEEN ON HOLD AN ENGLISH
NUMBER. I'M SORRY- I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU GO TO THE WEBSITE. OF THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE FOR JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IT YOU SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GET IN. THAT WHICH IS WHAT I
DID OKAY- ALL RIGHT AND HOW DO
YOU GET AN ACCIDENT PRONE TO.
THE BOOK ONLINE NINETEEN. I
REALLY HATE THAT NINETEEN ABOUT
NINETEEN IT DROPPED BOTH YOU
WILL GOOD LINE NINETY TWO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. IT WAS CALIFORNIA
. WHEN THE WATER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT. BY. NINETY ONE.
PRINGLE WORKING WITH THE CENTER
ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT. BY
NINETEEN. REBECA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. LINE. TWENTY BY TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. LINE
TWENTY HAS DROPPED OUT OF QUEUE
YOU MAY PROCEED THERE ARE NO FOR
THE LINES IN Q. THESE IS THE-
NORMAL COST THERE WERE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. CNN IN
A ROW ANY WITNESSES ON EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY GLAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. HI HI THIS IS JADI WITH
THAT OAKLAND PRIVACY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO ENSURE WE
HAVE KNOWING QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME THE PREMEDICAL MIDI ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SEEING NONE
YOU MAY CLOSE BACK CLASS FOR AN
AYE VOTE JURORS RECOMMEND AND I-
NEED ANY EMOTION. FROM THE
SECOND CALL THE ROLL CHAIRED
RECOMMENDING NINE. ON AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY EIGHT BY THE MEMBER
BARRICADE HAND THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER HI A LACKEY. LACKEY NOT
BOATING BONTA BRIAN BRIAN I WORK
I WORK I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I SAY
ARE TO SAY OUR TURN NOW. THE
MEASURE CALLED NEEDS ONE MORE UP
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS.
TEMPORARILY COME BACK AT. ONE
THIRTY. WE HAVE THREE MORE ITEMS
. COULD YOU TAKE VOTES ON-
THINGS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN- CHECK
OUT FOR THE ABSENT HERE SURE GO
AHEAD. I KNOW I'M NOT A. HUNDRED
THAT THAT.
PLEASE WAIT. FIVE
BUT- THE GERMAN I CAN SAY THAT-
HER NAME. SACRAMENTO YEAH. THE
CHAIR SEVENTEEN THAT WE FINE
YEAH CLOSED. OKAY UNLESS FOR
FORGIVENESS INSTEAD PERMISSION
AND ONE ON THE SOME OF THESE
MEASURES. IF NOT THEN IT YES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK.
WHERE COMMITTEES OF COMMITTEES
BACK IN ORDER. WE HAVE THREE
MORE ITEMS- ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY TWO MCCARTY
ID NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY SEVEN STONE. AN ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN. B TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FOUR BRIAN MISTER BRYANT
IS HERE SO LET'S HEAR FROM HIM
NOW. SURVIVOR SUPPORT AND HARM
PREVENTION PILOT PROGRAM ACT.
K. YOU HAVE A WITNESS C. LOOKING
FOR YOU'RE LOOKING BACK ON
MAKING SURE THE WITNESS SPOKE
WITH HIS BEEN ON SINCE ABOUT
NINE THIS MORNING SO WE'RE OKAY
SAID IF THE LAW- I THE WAY. PHIL
CONTROVERSY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR I AM MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FOR A BILL THAT WOULD CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR SURVIVORS OF CRIME.
THAT IS AUTONOMOUS FROM LONG
FIRST FORSMAN. CURRENTLY
SURPRISE A CRIME MAY RECEIVE
VICTIM SERVICES RESOURCES LIKE.
CRIME RELATED CRISIS COUNTY
EMERGENCY SERVICES ASSISTANCE
WITH RESTITUTION COMPENSATION
CLAIMS BUT ONLY IF THEY
COOPERATE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND IN MANY INSTANCES THAT MEANS
OPENING A CASE AGAINST THE
DEFENDANT. THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
CURRENT SYSTEM IS THAT TYING THE
SERVICES FOR SURVIVORS OF CRIME
TO CONTACT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAN BE A DAUNTING BARRIER FOR
PEOPLE STRUGGLING WITH TRAUMA.
IN FACT LESS THAN A THIRD OF
CRIME SURVIVORS REPORTED
RECEIVING HELP. ONE RECENT
SURVEY BY THE NATIONAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOTLINE REVEALED THAT
80% OF SURVIVOR SURVEYED
REPORTED FEELING SOMEWHAT OR
EXTREMELY AFRAID TO CALL THE
POLICE. AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FOUR CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM IN
FIVE COUNTIES INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES AND ALAMEDA COUNTY. TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT SERVICES TO ALL
SURVIVORS OF CRIME. REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THEY'RE WILLING TO
OPEN A CASE THAT MAY EXPOSE
THEMSELVES OR THEIR LOVED ONES
TO PROSECUTION OF CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION. COUNTY SHOWS
ALMOST ALISON OFFICE OF SURVIVOR
SUPPORT HARM REDUCTION THAT IS
INDEPENDENT AND AUTONOMOUS FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THE
OFFICE WILL ACCEPT WALKEN'S.
SELF REFERRALS ARE FROZEN COURTS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
SCHOOL SMALL BUSINESSES PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE PROSECUTORS
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. AND OTHERS. THESE
OFFICES WILL SAYS SURVIVORS NEED
TO PROVIDE SERVICES INCLUDING
HEALTH SERVICES AS WELL AS
HEALING SUPPORT FOR INDIVIDUALS
EXPOSED TO VIOLENCE ABUSE. OR
HARMFUL INTERACTIONS. IT WILL
ALSO PROVIDE HOUSING RESOURCES
SERVICES AND SUPPORT FOR VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS INCLUDING
PROCESSING CLAIMS WITH THE
STATE'S VICTIMS COMPENSATION
FUND. YOU LIVE IN THESE SERVICES
ARE CRITICAL. SURVIVORS ARE
VULNERABLE IN SEEKING RESOURCES
. TO GET TEST MORE TODAY I'M
JOINED BY TRACY STAFFORD A
FORMER SPOKESPERSON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND DARCIE
GREEN FROM THE ESSIE JUSTICE
GROUP. BOTH BY PHONE BY EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR COULD YOU BRING. ME
STAFFORD AND- MS GREEN IN.
LUCIO DARCY GREEN AND YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE SCREEN YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS DOROTHY GREEN AND I
AM AND AS HE JUST DISCRIMINATORY
AND LEADER AS HE DOESN'T GIVE
THE NATIONAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT HARNESSES THE
COLLECTIVE POWER OF WOMEN AND
GENDER NONCONFORMING PEOPLE BUT
INCARCERATED LOVED ONES TO END
MASS INCARCERATION HARM TO WOMEN
AND COMMUNITIES AND WE ARE PROUD
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FOR THE PART OF THE CARE
FOR COLLISION CALIFORNIA
COLLISION. WE ARE ONE OF THE
WOMEN AND THE ONE INCH BLACK
WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED
BOB WHAT. I SURVIVORS DOMESTIC
BY. TWO WASN'T ABLE TO ACCESS
ANY VICTIMS. SERVICES BE
SELECTED BECAUSE OF THE ACTIONS
OF THE POLICE. I KNOW FIRST HAND
BUT YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FOUR IS CRUCIAL TO
ENSURING THAT COMMON FORMS TO
BUY THEIR SERVICES ARE MADE
COMPLETELY ACCEPTABLE TO ALL.
UNFORTUNATELY THE POLICE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE VIOLENCE I
EXPERIENCED. OUR NOT A VIABLE
RESOURCE YOU NEED BECAUSE OF
THEIR ACTIONS THAT DAY. IN FACT
THEY WERE DIRECTOR YOUR KEY
EXPECTING VICTIM SERVICES. AND I
WASN'T THE PERSON WHO CONTACTED
THE POLICE AND THE POLICE ASK NO
QUESTIONS AT THE SCENE I WAS
INCORRECT READING THE PERSON TO
CAUSE HARM. THANKFULLY AFTER
GETTING THE FACT TO MY ATTORNEY.
THE DA DID NOT PICK UP MY KIDS.
BUT THAT ALSO MEANT THERE WAS NO
WAY FOR ME TO FORMALLY REVIEW
THAT I WAS THE PERPETRATOR SH
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL SIX MONTHS
LATER IN FAMILY COURT WHERE I
WAS FIGHTING FOR CUSTODY OF MY
SON. THAT I WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE AT
THE TICKET IN MY CASE. DURING
THOSE SIX MONTHS. I WAS
INELIGIBLE TO ACCESS MANY OF THE
TRADITIONAL ROUTE. THAT
SERVICES. PROVIDER SERVICES
BECAUSE OF THE STRICT RULES OF
SOME COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND TWENTIETH
OFFICES THAT HAVE. TO HAVE
AROUND SERVING ONLY THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN FORMALLY TRAINED AS
VICTOR MONTHLY SUPPORT DURING
COURT. HAVING ACCESS TO ANY.
SURVIVORS SUPPORT SERVICES WOULD
HAVE REDUCE THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING I EXPERIENCED. I HAD
TO NAVIGATE MY SITUATION WITHOUT
THE SUPPORT OF TRADITIONAL
VICTIM SERVICES. FOR LEGAL
GOVERNMENT. SYSTEM THAT COULD
HAVE HELPED ME. I HAD I BEEN. TO
ADD. THE SERVICES IN THE- A LOT
FOURTH IT WOULD SAVED ME FORTY.
DOLLARS I. WHEN COMPANIES OF
BAIL ATTORNEY. AND OTHER NEEDS
TO THE STATE OF MY FAMILY MYSELF
. ADDITIONAL THE HARM AND I
THOUGHT. I CERTAINLY WOULDN'T
BEEN AT. HAD I HAD A BILL LIKE
IN PLACE. DURING THE PROCESS OF
SEEKING SURVIVORS QUICKER THE
YOU TEND TO THINK. THAT IF
YOU'RE NOT L. TO RECEIVE THESE
SERVICES. AND MAYBE NO ONE
CARES. YOU START TO THINK THAT
MAYBE NO ONE CARES ABOUT THE
ABOUT HEALING TRAUMA OR
SUPPORTING SURVIVORS. AND THERE
IS THERE'S A FEELING THAT IF YOU
DON'T THAT THE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA THAT EXIST MAYBE YOU
DON'T BELONG. HE STARTED TELLING
ME TO INCREASE ISOLATION BILLION
LIKE YOU'RE A DIFFERENT CLASS OF
SURVIVOR AND THAT YOUR
EXPERIENCE YOUR TRAUMA IN YOUR
TEEN. MAY BE DENIED OR
INVALIDATED BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HAVE PROOF OF THE PROOF THAT IT
OCCURRED. AND UNFORTUNATELY MY
CASE IS NOWHERE NEAR YOU. A
LARGE NUMBER OF WOMEN WITH
INCARCERATED LOVED ONES AND
WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN SYSTEM
IMPACTED ARE ALSO VICTIMS OF
HARM. EITHER NOT BINARY
IDENTITIES. THE NUMBER OF THEM
THE NUMBER INCREASES EVEN MORE
FOR INCARCERATED WOMEN WITH A
VAST MAJORITY HAVE BEEN VICTIMS
OF VIOLENCE PRIOR TO THEIR
INCARCERATION. INCLUDING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RAPE. SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND CHILD ABUSE. THE
WAITER WHICH WOMEN ARE
EXPERIENCING HARMON VIOLENCE
WHILE ALSO EXPERIENCING STATE
VIOLENCE DOING KERR GETTING
CRACKED REYES NICARAGUAN. RESULT
IN INCREASED ISOLATION ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION AND HEIGHTENED
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL TRAUMA. AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR WOULD
REMOVE THE BARRIERS I THINK IN
ACCESSING SERVICES BY
ESTABLISHING PILOT PROGRAMS IN
FIVE COUNTY. STATE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT SERVICES TO ALL
SURVIVORS INDEPENDENT ALONG
FORTUNATE. BUT MY KIDS
SPECIFICALLY THIS WOULD HAVE
CHANGED EVERYTHING I WOULD NOT
HAVE THAT MADE A DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT I SHOULD BE
CREDITED FOR MYSELF. ARE
CRIMINALIZED. MIGHT AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED LOVED ONE. I AM NOT
ALONE IN THE INTERNAL CONFLICT
EXPERIENCED. AND HAVING TO MAKE
THAT DECISION. 80% OF SURVIVORS
REPORT FEELING SOMEWHAT WORK SHE
NEEDS FOR YOU TO CALL THE
POLICE. STATION I KNOW I
CERTAINLY BUT- MORE SPECIFICALLY
WOMEN WITH INCARCERATED LOVED
ONES ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF COLOR.
YOU KNOW THE HARM POLICE
INVOLVEMENT BECAUSE THIS TO
OURSELVES AND OUR FAMILIES.
INCLUDING AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FOUR WITH ESTABLISH A
FOUNDATION. FOR HOW TO ADDRESS
HARMON VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THAT RESPOND BY
NEEDING PEOPLE'S NEEDS INSTEAD
OF RESPONDING TO THE THREE
MINUTES AGO. OR DOING
CORPORATION. I URGE YOUR VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FOUR. PLEASE HELP US TO
TRANSFORM THE LIVES AND
EXPERIENCES OF ALL SURVIVORS
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. HAT'S WHAT THE- AFTER. YES
HELLO GOOD ACT. OUR BRAINS
TRYING TO STAFFORD AND JOB I
HAVE TO BUY CHILD ABUSE SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND I'M ALSO A THIRD
GENERATION DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR I TRAVELED TO OTHER
COUNTRIES LIKE THE TIME THAT THE
FOLKS PERCENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP ENDED VIOLENCE AND
HAVE WORKED WITH THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OFFICE ON
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN AND I'VE
ALSO- WORKED QUITE A BIT WITH
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE ON THE
PROSECUTION OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. I PROVIDED DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TO NEARLY IMPACTED-
DETERMINES AS WELL AS THOSE ON
PAROLE AND BE INCARCERATED I
THEREFORE I DEFINITELY. HAVE A
FIRST HAND. I IT'S CLEAR WHEN
YOU STAND. DESPERATELY FOR COMP
- WRAPAROUND AND- I SERVICES FOR
VICTIMS AFTER DECADES AND I'VE
CREATED LEGISLATORS WITH
PROSECUTORS AND ADVOCATES.
SHOULD FOCUS ON THE TRUTH AND
THAT THE TRUTH THAT VICTIMS AND
PERPETRATORS ARE OFTEN
WEDNESDAY. MIGHT WORK WITH
INMATES I REALIZE THAT MOST HAD
A VERY SIMILAR STORY TO MY OWN-
WE HAVE A DISTORTED- BURST IN
OUR VIEW OF HUMAN INTERACTION- I
REALITY- WITHIN WHICH IS GREAT
PAINT OUR OWN SPARE. AND PTSD
WERE PRETTY MUCH- NORMALIZED IN
MY LIFE AND THAT THAT THAT MANY
OTHERS- THE CYCLE OF VIOLENCE
CONTINUES TO GROW GENERATION.
AFTER GENERATION. A CALL TO OUR
PROPERTY NOT IN A TWO FIVE
THIRTY AGAIN TO IN THIS BY.
QUICKER BY X. AND SUSTAINABLE
TRY INFORM SERVICES. WITHIN A
NEW. IN BY WHICH IS KEY ARE A
DIFFERENT. THE FACT THAT POLICE
INTERVENTION CAN BE A BARRIER TO
ACCESSING NEEDED SERVICES AND
ACTUALLY ADD TO THE TURMOIL AT
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER MENTIONED.
AND IN MY CASE- BEING A BLACK
WOMAN AND- IT WAS REALLY JUST
BOUGHT THAT I WOULD CALL THE
POLICE ON A BLACK MANAGE THAT.
ALMOST COST ME MY LIFE. AND I
WILL. CLOSE BY JUST SAYING YOU
KNOW WHEN I ESCAPED. THAT A
DECENT RELATIONSHIP ALL I WANTED
WAS BETTER FOR MY DAUGHTER I
DIDN'T WANT TO DEAL WITH COOLEY
I DIDN'T WANT TO DEAL WITH COURT
I DO TWENTY THREE XP THEY SHOULD
HAVE MY DAUGHTER BE SAFE. I
REMEMBER LOOKING INTO HER EYES
YOU KNOW AGAIN THREE YEAR OLD AS
SHE WATCHED THE ABUSE THAT I WAS
SUFFERING. AND IN HER FACE I
SAW. WHAT LOOKED LIKE ANNOYANCE
RATHER THAN FEAR. AND SHE WAS
WATCHING HE WITH ME BASICALLY ME
WATCHING MY MOTHER BE BEATEN SHE
WAS MY MOTHER WATCHING MY
GRANDMOTHER BE ABUSE. NO IN THAT
MOMENT I DECIDED THAT THIS COULD
NOT BE YOU KNOW HER NORMAL BUT I
WAS NOT GOING TO TREAT CONTINUE
THAT CYCLE AND ACTUALLY HE'S NOW
THIRTY FOUR AND WE BROKE INTO IT
AND- THAT OF MY DAUGHTERS HAVE
EXPERIENCED IT TO THIS POINT.
AND AND ASKING THAT YOU HELP US
TO TRANSFORM THE LIVES OF THOSE
WHO HAD BEEN HELD CAPTIVE BY
GENERATIONAL TRAUMA AS WELL AS
THE VICTIMS. THAT ARE BEHIND
BARS SO PLEASE SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FOUR FOR ALL VICTIMS
THANK YOU. ARE THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM ED IN
SUPPORT. NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON GREGORY FELT IN A
JUST SINCE SUPPORT THANK. MARCO
CHARGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE EXCEPT. PORT AT&T
OPERATE LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCHTONE KEYPAD.
AND WE WILL SCORE LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHT THAT'S ONE
ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON YOU GOT A LATE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND ADVOCACY
FOR DIGNITY AND POWER NOW. WILL
PONDER A LOT OF SENSE THAT IN
STRONG SUPPORT ALSO A SURVIVOR
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT. WE DO A FEW MORE THAT
IS QUEUED UP WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SEVEN ONE
ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
LISA GOMEZ ON BEHALF OF AT THE
TICKET BOOTH. JOHN THE PART.
WILL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIVE ONE ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JENNY ROMERO
WITH DIGNITY AND POWER NOW IN
THE CHARACTERS CALIFORNIA
COALITION CALLING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AB TWENTY. FOUR. AND
WITH THAT WE HAVE EXHAUSTED Q.
THANK YOU NOW PROPOSITION. WITH
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION C.
NINE IN ROME- IT INTEROPERATE OR
OPEN UP LINES FOR A WITNESSES
OPPOSITION NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
THERE'S NO ONE COMING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. PLEASE BONTA
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK IT'S A VERY GOOD
DEMONSTRATION OF WHAT IT MEANS
TO HAVE A PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH
TO ENSURING THAT OUR SURVIVORS
GET THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
AND- AND I'M THANKFUL TO BE CO
AUTHOR WITH THE ON. THANK YOU
ANY MISTER LUCKY. YEAH I. I HAVE
TO UNFORTUNATELY NOT BE IN A
POSITION OF SUPPORT ON THIS
PARTICULAR APPROACH TO-
IDENTIFIED PROBLEMS I BELIEVE
THAT THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
FUND IS ALREADY IN. JEOPARDY OF
INSOLVENCY. AND EXPANDING THE
DEFINITION OF VICTIMS. IS
EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC I DON'T
THINK THAT MOST PEOPLE WHEN I
THINK OF VICTIMS WOULD. WOULD
LIKE TO HOUSING FOR SEX WORKERS
AS A COMPENSATION. FOR
VICTIMHOOD I GET A FEELING TO
THAT AS YOU DESCRIBED THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL THAT IT'S- THE
ANTI LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND I
THINK WE NEED TO BUILD THAT
TRUST NOT A ROAD AND THIS SEEMS
LIKE IT'S- MOVING INTHE WRONG
DIRECTION SO I WON'T BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU- YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU- APPRECIATE ALL
THE COMMENTS I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY VICTIMS OF TRAUMA AND
VIOLENCE- I'VE COME ACROSS WHO
WERE UNABLE TO RECEIVE SERVICES
ARE. AS A TOOL OF LEVERAGE FOR
PROSECUTORS TO GET CONVICTIONS
IS HARMFUL TO VICTIMS. AND I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR US TO
EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF VICTIM
TO ANYBODY WHO'S HARMED BY
VIOLENCE OR TRAUMA- THE IDEA
THAT THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
FUND- MAYBE BECOMING INSOLVENT
MIGHT BE A QUESTION ABOUT A
BUDGETARY PRIORITIES. WHICH I'M
HAPPY TO EXPLORE- WITH THE VICE
CHAIR AS WELL. BUT THIS PILOT
PROGRAM I THINK IT'S SMART IT'S
REASONABLE- IT ADDRESSES A MAJOR
CONCERN THAT PEOPLE HAVE WHEN
SEEKING OUT HELP. IT'S TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE CAN I GET HELP
WITHOUT FURTHER TRUMP POSITION
AND STIGMATIZATION AND RIGHT NOW
IT'S NOT IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES UNTIL PILOTING THIS AND
FIVE. COUNTS GATHERING DATA NEXT
THE EFFICACY THIS WAS SURVIVORS
ARE CALLING ON US TO DO WITH
WHAT THEY'VE CALLED MY OFFICE TO
DO AND I'M PROUD OFF OF THIS
BILL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU AND WE DO NEED TO TRY
OF. HAVE A MEDICAL. SERVICES
APPROACH RIGHT I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BORCHERS
RECOMMENDED I. IS THERE A MOTION
. SO MOVED SECOND. AND OKAY
HELLO ON AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FOUR BY SEVEN MEMBER BRIAN THE
MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER IRAQI LACKEY NO BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN I. WORK
SANTIAGO THEY ARE TO LOOK AT
MEASURES ON CALL. SHORTER OUR
LAST TWO H. MR MCCARTY INVESTORS
DOWN I HAVE MISTER MCCARTY FIRST
MUCH YOU NEED TO BE SOMEWHERE
MISTER STONE AS CHAIR GEN. OKAY
MISTER CAR IS GRACIOUS ALLOWING
YOU TO GO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN THIS MCCARTY. REYES SO
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN
ADDRESSES FOLKS WHO ARE ON DEATH
ROW WHO ARE CRIMINALLY
INCOMPETENT THE SUPREME COURT.
ESTABLISHED THAT THE EIGHTH
AMENDMENT PROHIBITS THE
EXECUTION OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
MENTALLY INCOMPETENT AND AS THE
POPULATION ON DEATH ROW AGES AND
CIRCUMSTANCES HAPPENING IN
PRISON THERE ARE MORE AND MORE
FOLKS WHO ARE. DETERMINE TO BE
PERMANENTLY INCOMPETENT AND
WOULD THEREFORE BE PREVENTED BY
THE CONSTITUTION FROM EVER BEING
EXECUTED BUT YET THEY SIT ON
DEATH ROW THERE'S NO STATUTORY
MECHANISM TO REMOVE FOLKS FROM
DEATH ROW AS THEY REALLY SHOULD
BE. THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IT IS HUMANE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN A SITUATION. THAT IS BEYOND
THEIR COMPREHENSION THAT COULD
NOT BE EXCUSE SHOULD NOT BE ON
DEATH ROW AND IT IS FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE AS IT IS INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE TO HOLD PEOPLE
UNNECESSARILY ON DEATH ROW. AS
WE ARE WORKING TO. HOPEFULLY IN
MY VIEW THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS
DOES BUT GET RID OF THE DEATH
PENALTY IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S NOT
REALLY THIS BUT THIS IS. TRYING
TO MINIMIZE THE POPULATION
ESPECIALLY POPULATION. WHO
SHOULD NOT BE THERE AND ACROSS
IN THE STATE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF MONEY. SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES- I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES. AMENDMENTS AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE YEAH WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE WITH YOUR STAFF
RESEARCHER WITH THAT I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. AND I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES ASSISTED FEDERAL
DEFENDER DEFENDER HARRY SIMON I
BELIEVE IS ON THE TELEPHONE AND
THEN WITH ME HERE IS NATASHA
MINSKER. WHO WILL ALSO. I GUESS
ANSWER QUESTIONS IF NECESSARY.
OKAY OKAY ASTRONOVA THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO I GUESS WE'LL GO TO
THE WITNESS ON THE PHONE FIRST.
THANK YOU- MEMBERS ARE COMMITTED
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TIME AND-
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SIX FIVE SEVEN. I AM AN
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING PEOPLE
SENTENCED TO DEATH IN CALIFORNIA
AND I REPRESENTED SEVERAL
INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE PROFOUNDLY
MENTALLY ILL IN CONNECTION WITH
CLAIMS THAT THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD ADDRESS. THAT PART OF ITS
DEFINITELY REPORT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE ON REVISION OF THE
PENAL CODE RECOGNIZE THAT THEIR
PEOPLE ON DEATH ROW.
INTELLECTUAL FUNCTIONING OR
PSYCHOLOGICAL CONDITIONS. RATED
COUPLED FROM. SUCH AS FROM AIDS
RELATED DEMENTIA DURING THEIR
INCARCERATION. THEY HAVE LITTLE
LIKELIHOOD OF GAINING COMPETENCY. THEY RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MODIFYING THE
EXISTING STATURE REGARDING
COMPETENCY PROCEEDING. TO CREATE
A CLEAR PROCESS RETURNS THESE
PERMANENTLY INCOMPETENT PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT BE LEGALLY
EXECUTED. PENAL CODE SECTION
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED AND FALLING
. TRANSPORT GREAT PROCEDURES
RESOLVED THE ISSUE OF WHETHER
PEOPLE COME TO DEATH ARE
MENTALLY INCOMPETENT ON THE EVE
OF EXECUTION THESE STATUTES WERE
LAST REVISED IN NINETEEN FORTY
ONE. KERN THE CALIFORNIA'S NEAR
THE U. S. SUPREME COURT HAS
ISSUED OPINIONS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX AND CORD PERSONAL
LINE RIGHT. AND AGAIN IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN INFINITI PERSONAL
PORTMAN SETTING COURTS CLUBS AND
HAVE BEEN PROCEDURAL PROTECTIONS
AGAINST ACCUSED A MAN LAYING
COMMON PEOPLE UNDER THE EIGHTH
AMENDMENT. THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO PULL FIRST IT
MODERNIZE IN CALIFORNIA LAW CAN
WARM WITH. MODERN FEDERAL
CONSTITUTIONAL. SECOND IT.
AUTHORIZED THE CALIFORNIA COURT.
TO ACT IN A TIMELY. AREN'T UP
BRO FROM INCOMPETENT AND FOR
THAT REASON NEVER BE A GOOD. THE
U. S. SUPREME COURT INCLUDED IT
IS ON. KILOGRAM IN. THE LAW OF
ONE WHO MENTAL L. PREVENTED CALM
THE REASONS FOR THE DEATH
PENALTY OR THE IMPLICATIONS
BANKAMERICARD MORE THAN
AWARENESS OF THE STATE. REASONS
FOR AN EXECUTION THE PERSON THE
STATE INTENDS TO PUT TO DEATH
ALSO HAVE TO HAVE A RATIONAL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE FACT OF
THEIR EXECUTION AND THE REASONS
FOR. WHAT DO. OUR LOWS WITH
MODERNIZE PEOPLE SECTION THIRTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE AND FALLING TO
CONFORM TO THE REQUIREMENTS THE
U. S. CONSTITUTION BUT IT WOULD
ALSO PROVIDE EXPLICIT
AUTHORIZATION FOR CALIFORNIA
COURTS TO CONSIDER PETITIONS
RAISING CLAIMS OF PERMANENT
INCOMPETENT TO BE EXECUTED IN
ADVANCE OF THE DAY THE NEXT WEEK
USE NO CONTRAST. AS THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
NEPOTIC REPEATEDLY IN LITIGATION
OVER THIS ISSUE. COMPELLING
REASON TO EXIST FOR REACHING A
CLAIM A PERMANENT INCOMPETENCE
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER. FOR A
PRISONER CAN NEVER BE EXECUTED.
THEN ALL OTHER TECH KNOWLEDGE IS
THE DE PENALTY ARE MEANT. AND
ANY JUDICIAL INQUIRY INTO THE
VALIDITY OF THOSE OTHER
CHALLENGES WOULD BE POINTLESS.
ENACTMENT OF THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD PREVENT FUTURE OBLIGATION
OF. CONVICTION PROCEEDINGS IN
CAPITAL CASE APPEALS MAY BE A
CASE- IN STATE AND FEDERAL
COURTS WHEN A PERSON SENTENCED
TO DEATH. BECOME PERMANENTLY IN
COP AND IT WOULD SAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SIGNIFICANT PHAM IS DEVOTED TO
SUCH POINTLESS LITIGATION. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES DID YOU
ARE YOU LOOKING AT RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON ATTACHMENTS FOR HERE
FOR CALIFORNIA'S ANTI DEFINITELY
COALITION I JUST WANNA MAKE
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT THIS BILL
DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE EXECUTED
BECAUSE IT'S ABSOLUTELY CLEAR
UNDER CURRENT LAW THAT THEY
CANNOT BE EXECUTED THE BILL ALSO
DOESN'T CHANGE THEIR HOUSING
SITUATION BECAUSE THESE FOLKS
ARE HOUSED IN SECURE CDCR
MEDICAL FACILITIES AND THAT IS
WHERE THEY WILL DIE. AND FINALLY
THE BILL DOESN'T IMPACT THEIR
AWARENESS OF THEIR SENTENCE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW THEY'VE
BEEN SENTENCED TO DEATH OR THE
REASONS WHY OR EVEN WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE EXECUTED THAT'S THE
VERY DEFINITION OF BEING
INCOMPETENT FOR EXECUTION THIS
BILL SIMPLY ADDRESSES THE
ABSURDITY THAT WE KEEPPEOPLE ON
DEATH ROW WHO HAVE SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS AND ADVANCED
DEMENTIA TO THE POINT THAT THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT DAY IT IS OR
WHAT YEAR IT IS OR WHERE THEY
ARE. AND IT WILL PUT TO THE END
THE CURRENTLY ENDLESS LITIGATION
IN THESE CASES ALLOWING US TO
DIVERT THOSE RESOURCES TO BETTER
USE WAS THAT ACTUALLY IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU THANK YOU OR ANY
OF THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME
AN ORGANIZATION. FRED WILLIAMS
ON THE HAVE A CD CAL ACTION IN
SUPPORT. MARCO GEORGE FROM
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ADD WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. EIGHTY SPEAKING SUPPORT
ON A. B. TWO SIX FIVE SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THAT'S ONE ONE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS MOLLY
SHEEHAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU ALL. I ONE MORE THAT'S
JUST QUEUED UP ALLOW A MOMENT
FOR US TOGETHER THAN THEIR- MY
NUMBER.
WELL GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN THAT'S
ONE ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON LIVING BE AGAIN
AND I WOULD LIKE TO READ A LIST
OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT ASKING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
TWO SIX FIVE SEVEN. I WAS SMART
JUST OF CALIFORNIA INITIATE
JUSTICE ELEVATOR CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS- CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS.
DROPPED A LOT COALITION ADVOCATE
FOR FRIENDS ON DEATH ROW
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE OF FAITH
WORKING. AT ALL THE INTERFACE
NEW THESE UNITED FOR JUSTICE AND
PEACE ELLENBERGER. PROJECT NEXT
CALIFORNIA. DEFINITELY FROM
HUMANE PRESENT PROJECT PHASE IN
ABOUT EIGHT NOT TO AND A LOT.
JANET COLLEGE FRIEND COMMITTEE
ON. AND CAL. IS A MEMBER PROJECT
THE NATIONAL CITY OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CHAPTER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WHEN WE HAVE ONE MORE THAT
YOU WILL GET A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN ONE ONE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT
LOOKS LIKE IT ACTUALLY REMOVE
THEMSELVES FROM THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OF.
OUR OPPOSITION I'M SORRY. ANY
OPPOSITION. CNN IN A ROOM. AT&T
OPERATOR OPEN UP PHONE LINES TO
ANY OPPOSITION. LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ON AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
SHERIDAN AVENUE IN QUEUING UP IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. BUT THE
RIVER OPPOSITION CLAIRVOYANT
THAT WAY- BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS
CONCERNS CNN YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS I ASK
HER ABOUT THANK YOU AND CHEERS
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE VISIBLE.
SECOND. ON AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBERS DOWN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY LACKEY NO BONTA BONTA HI
BRIAN BRIAN I WORK. SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO I SEYARTO THEY ARE TO KNOW
THAT. MEASURES ARE CALLED ONE
MORE BEFORE WE GO WITH MR
MCCARTY I'D LIKE TO READ
CALENDAR BURKE ITEM NUMBER ONE
A. B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY ARAMBULA
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT TRAFFICKING UNIT
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY FOUR BAR K. ON
CRIMES AGAINST PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY ILLEGAL DUMPING. I DON'T
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX COOPER INCARCERATED
PERSONS HEALTH RECORDS ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE GREAT PEACE OFFICERS
DEPUTY SHERIFFS I DON'T NUMBER
TEN AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN
MAIENSCHEIN. FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS AND ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY THREE
MULLIN. PEACE OFFICERS TRAINING
. IS A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OF. MOTIONS
COULD YOU CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR JONES SAWYER
CHEN SO YOU HI LACKEY LACKEY I'D
- BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN I WORK.
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO HI THEY ARE
TO THEATER I. TO TOP IT THAT
PASSES ARE NOW WE HAVE A ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE IN OUR LAST TIME
FOR TODAY AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
TWO MCCARTY- FIREARMS GUN SHOWS
AND EVENTS. MISTER MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MCCARTY. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT A BILL TO HELP CURB-
UNNECESSARY GUN VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA AND PREVENT GUNS FROM
GETTING IN THE WRONG HANDS THIS
IS UNFORTUNATELY A VERY TIME
TOPIC HERE WITH THE ISSUE OF GUN
VIOLENCE AND- GUNS IN THE WRONG
- I DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS OF
WHAT HAPPENED JUST A FEW. BLOCKS
AWAY- FROM JUST TWO DAYS AGO WE
DO KNOW THERE WERE. YOU KNOW
FIREARMS IN THE HANDS OF THE
WRONG HANDS YOU KNOW YOU LEGALLY
MODIFIED FIREARMS. AND- ONE
ISSUE THAT COMES UP IN
CALIFORNIA IT TOO OFTEN HIS
INDIVIDUALS GO TO GUN SHOWS.
PURCHASE GUNS. LAWFUL OWNERS
GOOD AGAINST LOT LAWFUL
CALIFORNIANS GO TO GUN SHOWS ALL
THE TIME. BUY GUNS FOR THEIR OWN
PERSONAL PROTECTION FOR HUNTING
FOR TARGET PRACTICE WHAT HAVE
YOU FOR SPORTING. BUT THERE ARE
PEOPLE SLIP THROUGH THE CRACKS.
AND AND- YOU KNOW ON THIS
COMMITTEE HAS TALKED ABOUT GUN
SHOWS AND OTHERS NEVER EXAMPLES
OF PEOPLE WHO GO THERE IN A
PROPERLY JUST ABOUT TWO WEEKS
AGO. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA. ANNOUNCED THE ARREST
OF AN INDIVIDUAL AND ARMS ARE
PROHIBITED FELON POSSESSING
ILLEGAL FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION
INCLUDING A. R. FIFTEEN. THAT HE
BOUGHT THE- THE MATERIALS TO
MAKE A GHOST GUN. AND HOW THEY
KNOW THIS HAPPENED BECAUSE THEY
WITNESSED HIM BUYING IT AT A GUN
SHOW. WITHOUT PROPER OVERSIGHT
OF THAT SO THIS BILL WOULD I
THINK PUTS SOME REASONABLE
REGULATIONS ON GUN SHOWS NOT TO
SHUT THEM DOWN. JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE PROPER-
SIGNAGE AND INFORMATION OUT
FRONT TO KNOWING WHAT THE LAWS
AND REGULATIONS ARE IN THE
EXPECTATIONS FOR BUYERS. AND-
AND SELLERS AND CAN ALSO FOCUS
ON THAT ONE ROUGHLY ONE HUNDRED
GUN SHOWS THAT OCCUR EVERY YEAR
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT THE GUN
SHOW- PRODUCERS AND VENDORS OF
ABIDE BY THE REQUIREMENTS HAVING
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
PROVIDE- INSPECTIONS- FOR THESE
FOR ABOUT HALF OF THEM ONCE A
YEAR. AGAIN THIS WOULD HELP MAKE
SURE THAT GUNS STAY IN THE RIGHT
HANDS AND CONVERSELY STAY OF THE
WRONG HANDS AND YOU KNOW
REGARDLESS WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
THE SECOND AMENDMENT WE ALL
AGREE THAT THERE'S ONE WAY TOO
MUCH GUN VIOLENCE I JUST ALLEGE
. WALK LITERALLY THE CRIME SCENE
AND SALAS MARKINGS WHERE THERE
ARE SIX BODIES FROM JUST TWO
NIGHTS AGO. AND IN THE TO WE ALL
AGREED THERE'S GUNS IN THE WRONG
HANDS SO THIS I BELIEVE IS A IS
A FAIR PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
ATTEMPT. TO MAKE SURE THE GUNS-
STAY IN THE RIGHT HANDS IT
CONVERSELY STELLAR ON HANDS. HOW
WOULD YOU- WITH ME TODAY ARE THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN. AND NEVER SAY
AGAIN CALIFORNIA ASKED HIM TO
TESTIFY AND CONVERSE ASK THE
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR EIGHTEEN OPERATORS A
WITNESS. WHEN THEY FIND OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON ALL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
STEPHEN LANG I HAVE YEARS LONG
FOR SERVICE AND WITH THAT SHE OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE FARMS FROM TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I
AM HERE ON BEHALF OF AND
REPRESENTATION OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
LAST YEAR MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED AMERICANS WERE VICTIMS
OF GUN VIOLENCE AND MORE THAN
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND WERE KILLED
. AB 25% YOU MAY SPRAYED HIS
GOLD PRODUCED VIOLENCE THE CIVIC
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTATIVE UPDATE
TO CLOSE SOME LOOPHOLES AND THE
SOUTH OF FIREARMS THE GUNMEN
DEVELOPED INCREASE SALES AND-
THIS BILL REQUIRES CONTROL TO
CERTIFY THAT THEY WILL NOT
DISPLAY OR OFFER FOR SALE IN THE
ANSWER LIES FRAME THE RECEIVERS
INTO POST MISSION NOTICES-
REGISTER. HANDLING PURCHASE IN
FACT OF FIREARMS AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY TO STOP THE SALE GOES GOOD
KIDS. WHICH BEING REASSEMBLED
AND HAVE NO ZERO. FIFTY HAVE
DOMINATED SO AGAINST WHICH IS
HOW FUEL THE REVEREND FIRE BY TO
CALL AND NO. THOSE GUYS ARE TO
BE A LARGE THREAT LAUNCH IN
THEIR ABILITY TO SOLVE CRIMES
TELL GUN SHOW FROM AND GO SPEND
BENDERS- OR WHERE OF THE FEEL
BIGGEST WEAPON. YET THEY REFUSE
TO DO ANY COULD BE SO AGAIN.
THERE COMPLICIT IN THE DEATH AND
MISERY BROUGHT TO OUR COMMUNITY
SUPPORT USED IN THE PRODUCT. AB
TWENTY FIVE COULD YOU ALSO
ADDRESS THE NEW TREND OR
LOOPHOLE AND DANGEROUSLY COMING
FROM ANOTHER. IF YOU CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA GUN SHOWS. ANGGUN
CONVERGE KIT FROM NINETEEN
SIMILAR. CAN LIKE THE POPULAR
GLOCK PISTOL A FOR PEARL.
ASSAULT WHY. WHICH IS A IN
CALIFORNIA CONVERTING OR SO IN
BRIGHT COLORS. SIMILAR TO FOR
YOUR GUNS I CAN BE- THIS CAN. AS
GUNS NOT DEADLY FIREARMS
OPPONENTS STATE THIS BILL IS ARE
DONE CONVEYOR LAW IT IS NOT
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT FALL BELOW.
SO THAT IS WHY WE ADVOCATES- FOR
DEER DURING. HI HAVE TO GUIDES
WERE ARE NO ADVOCATES ABOUT
LEGAL STORE. HEY PANELING THEY
PURCHASE OR THE EMPIRE AT A NEED
INTEREST IS A SHOWS MORE. THERE
ARE MARKED JUST LIKE HIS SPEED
LIMIT SIGN ABOUT THE PERTINENT
LAWS SPECIFICALLY WITH WERE.
CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE FUNDING TO
CONDUCT INVESTOR INSPECTION OF
CALIFORNIA GUN SHOWS THAT THE
FUNDING HAS NOT INCREASED IN THE
DOJ HILLIMAN RESOURCES. AND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN REPORT
ATTORNEY GENERAL BECERRA WROTE
THAT OUT OF SUMMER THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN HERE STOP THE DOJ'S.
INSPECTION OF CALIFORNIA GUN
SHOWS MOREOVER LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN IN YOUR
SHOPPING AGAIN SHOW RATHER THAN
ENSURING THAT SALES AND- WITH
CAL LAW. IN MY LIVING WITH THE
BUREAU FINER IN THE NINE YEARS
AT CHIEF I CAN PER ATTEST TO
HAVE WITNESSED COUNTLESS
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. A CALIFORNIA
GUN SHOWS WHICH LED TO ARRESTS
AND PROSECUTIONS THIS INCLUDES
TRUCK PURCHASES LEAGUE FIREARMS
SO AND OTHER WEAPONS SALES.
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY AT THE VET MEN
OVERSIGHT. YOU CAN SHOWS WERE
COMPLY AND PUBLIC IT CONTROLS
AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA ONE IT WAS A LEADER
IN THAT IS A LINGERING GOODBYE
PROVENCHER AND DENTE. WE CANNOT
GUNS TO WITH THE STATE
PRECAUTION WE INCREASED FINES.
WILL BE MORE- IS ABOUT DIDN'T.
AND GRANDCHILDREN OF WILL LIKELY
BE SAFER. AT ONE TIME CAL HAD
THE REGULAR AND SCHEDULE IN THE
NATION. WE NEED TO RETURN TO THE
STATUS FOR THE THREE BRADY.
BRADY CALIFORNIA SO. BILL TWENTY
FIVE TWO THANK YOU I'M AFTER I.
YOU WITNESS. THANK CHAIR. JONES
GOOD AT. HONORABLE MANY. MY NAME
ROSE SHOW AND I AM A FOUNDER OF
NEVER AGAIN CA. OUR NAME
REFERENCES THE HASH TAG CREATED
BY PARKLAND STUDENTS. ON
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OUR PURPOSE IS ALIGNED.
THE AUGUST BEFORE. BEFORE MARK
TWAIN PARKLAND MASS SHOOTING I
ASKED HER TEN YEAR OLD GRANDSON
WHAT WHAT HIS GOALS FOR THE
SCHOOL YEAR AHEAD. HE SAID
COMPUTERS TRANSPORTATION AND
STAYING ALIVE WE SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY TWO BECAUSE
THIS LEGISLATION WILL HELP US.
STAY ALIVE THE REQUIREMENT TO
POST SIGNAGE AT GUN SHOWS ABOUT
SAFE STORAGE OF GUNS AND
AMMUNITION. WILL SAVE LIVES JUST
LIKE A LABEL THAT SAYS DANGER
THIS PRODUCT IS POISON YOU CAN
NEVER REMIND PEOPLE TOO MANY
TIMES ABOUT LIFESAVING MEASURES.
LIVES WILL BE SAVED I TAKING
GHOST GUNS OFF THE MARKET. THESE
COSTA AND KIDS LOOK LIKE A GUN
SHOOT LIKE A GUN AND KILL LIKE A
GUN. IN SAN DIEGO NOW MORE THAN
20% OF THE GUNS RECOVERED AT
CRIME. ARTICLE DOWN. BY WILL BE
SAVED IF WE SAY NO TO GUN MENU.
TRYING TO EXPAND THEIR MARKET BY
SELLING CONVERSION KITS TO MAKE
A HANDGUN INTO A FASTER. RIFLE
LET'S NOT WHEN GUN MANUFACTURERS
MAKING. KITS INCLUDE. THEY ARE
LOOKING GLORY SHOOTING PASS. TO
A YOUNGER MARKET. GUN DEALERS
DURING THE BUSINESS TO MAKE A
PROFIT ONE OF THE MAJOR
PROMOTERS OF GUN SHOWS IN
CALIFORNIA IS A CONVICTED. ONE
PROVISION OF THIS BILL REQUIRE
THE- AND FEC. OF HAPPY GUN SHOW
PER YEAR. THE WILL TAKE THE K.
ALREADY HAS THE TO GUN LAWS IN
THE- YET WE HAVE GUN CRIMES THE
NRA KNOWS THE O. J. DOES NOT
ADEQUATE ANSWER IN REGULAR THE
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED GUY SHOWS
THE YEAR. AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
TWO WHAT SHOT THIS HUGE A GUN.
IN THE HANDS OF CRIMINALS ON. OF
ALL CHILDREN WE ASK FOR YOU YES
VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB. TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY TWO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. WILL NOW GO TO
THE- INTO. AT&T ARE OVER A BLIND
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER TERRY DO NOT
EVER ON CHEWING UP AT THIS TIME
SIR PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU.
FOR ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. IN THE ROOM. YES YEAH ATTESA
ROY GRIFFIN RPA YES YES MISTER
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN.
BERMAN OKAY SIR GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN FOR THE RECORD ROY
GRIFFITHS LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA RIGEL BIBLE
AND POSTAL SOCIALIZATION HERE
TODAY AND BEYOND- SHARPIE ALSO
REPRESENTING THE NRA AND GUN
ARMS A CALIFORNIA REMEMBERS DRUG
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING STRONG
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY TWO THEY
ENTIRE GOVERNMENT WOULD LIKE THE
PUBLIC TO BELIEVE THAT THESE SO
CALLED GUN SHOW LOOPHOLES WHICH
ARE ALL OPERATED PERSONS TO
ACCESS FARMS IS BY TAKING A GUN
SHOW THEIR LIKE THE GENERAL
PUBLIC TO BELIEVE THAT THE LIVE
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION ARE.
FREELY TRADED TO PERSONS
ATTENDING GUN SHOWS WITHOUT ANY
TYPE OF LEGAL RAMIFICATIONS FOR
YEARS CENTERS ASSEMBLY MONTANA
RETIRE DOJ WITNESSES HAVE
TESTIFIED IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
OTHERS TOO NUMEROUS VIOLATIONS
OF GUN SHOWS IN THE PARKING LOT
HOWEVER WHEN THE CRB ABOUT THE
DOJ TO GOVERNOR'S COUNTY
SHERIFF'S COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND REPRESENTATIVES
BROUGH SEVEN INCH. TO SUPPORT
THESE CLAIMS. NOTHING HAS
PRESENT. MAKING SOME CLAIMS THE
TOOL FOR IS MAKING. FOR LUNCH.
AND THOSE WHO MAY THESE AS A HAS
BEEN BASED ON UNFOUNDED CLAIMS.
THE ONLY ONE REDEEMABLE ACTION
IS PIECE OF LEGISLATION THE BILL
WILL FINALLY REQUIRED DOJ TO
POST THESE VIOLATIONS ON THEIR
WEBSITE. FINALLY WILL HAVE A
RECORD OF WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT. IF THE TESTIMONY PROVIDED
TODAY WAS TRUE THE DOJ THERE HAS
BEEN IN VIOLATION AT LEAST THREE
PUBLIC INFORMATION REQUEST WHAT
WE'VE ASKED THE DOJ DIRECTLY.
VIOLATION EVIDENCE FROM HIS GUN
SHOW. PROMOTERS IN ABU. DOESN'T
CUT IT MUST READY COME WITH
NORTHWESTERN SIX SECTIONS OF THE
PENAL CODE. CONSOLES ARE HIGHLY
REGULATED CALIFORNIA RULES ARE
NO LESS STRINGENT FOR THOSE
VENDORS AT GUN SHOWS. FINISHING
PARTICIPATING GANDULES. MAY NOT
DO SO UNLESS THEIR LICENSE HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED TO DOJ BEFORE THE
EVENT FOR ALL PURPOSES OF
DETERMINING WHETHER THE VENDORS
POSSESSES A PROPER. LICENSING
COMPLY WITH ALL RELEVANT LAWS.
HE ALSO DOES NOT CONSIDER THE
PRACTICALITY WILL NORMALLY OF
THE TASK WHICH IS REQUIRED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THEIR
CAR WAS POSSIBILITIES INCLUDE
TRACKING ALL BARBARA BUSH HE
PURCHASES THE REGISTRATION OF
ALL THESE PURCHASES AND PURCHASE
BACKGROUND CHECKS WAITING
PERIODS PLUS SIMILAR PROCEDURES
NOW FOR AMMUNITION. PURCHASES
AND THE PRODUCERS ALREADY WHEN
AB EIGHT SEVEN NINE IS
EMPLOYMENT IN TWENTY TWENTY BY
THE DOJ WILL BE TASKED WITH
RECORDING A STAGGERING NUMBER OF
TRANSACTIONS AS FARMS ARE MADE
LITERALLY DOZENS OF PARTS. NOW
ADD TO THAT LIST
RESPONSIBILITIES PATROLLING GUN
SHOWS ALL OVER CALIFORNIA FOR
PROPER SIGNAGE AND PARKS THAT
ARE NOT EVEN CLEARLY DEFINED
YET. ALL OF THIS ONE OVER TEN.
PARTS PROHIBITED FELONS CONTINUE
TO GROW IN CALIFORNIA. CONTINUES
WITH THE AUTHOR'S INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION. IN JULY TWENTY
SIXTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED A
LAW SHOULD WE BILL EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN THE GOES CONSTELLATION
REQUIREMENTS AB. THAT ALREADY
MAKES IT ILLEGAL TO TURN ANY.
PRECURSOR PARKING REQUIREMENT ON
PROPER. READ SEVERAL DAYS FROM
THE J. WHICH BEGS THE TO INTENT
OF SUCH BE A BAN THE SALE OF
FARM. PART LP. TO HOWEVER AB
FIVE FIFTY TWO CALLS THE
PROVISION OF FURTHER CALL THE
ORDER DOJ WE'RE SO WAITING FOR
DEATH WITH THESE PARTS ARE
ALREADY BEING CALLED. PRECURSOR
PARTS. ALSO UP SHOULD BE TO HEAR
THIS MESSAGE EVENTS ARE YOU TO
MISS LARGEST NOT BEING THIS BILL
CAN OPERATE IT WOULD HAVE. WHAT
WE NEED ARE STRICTER LAWS. ON
FELLOW AND GET ON BOARD DAHLE.
STREET FOOTBALL TO RESPECT THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU CAN PLEASE
VOTE NO ON THE MICHIGAN LET.
THANK YOU WOULD ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN A ROW. AND
OPPOSITE. WELL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES WITNESSES ENOUGH. IF
YOU TO SPEAK UP OF A TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
ONE ONE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE PROCEED. MR CHER NO AUDIO
ON THAT LINE WILL MOVE ON THE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THAT'S ONE TWO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RON LANDER
AND CHAIRMAN OF THE RIVERS STATE
CHAPTER. S. C. R. PA. ALREADY
HAPPENING OVER THREE HUNDRED
FAMILIES AND MEMBERS OF.
RIVERSIDE DOES THIS LEGISLATION
. THANK YOU. WHAT A LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND ONE THAT'S ONE
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU THIS IS CARLENE ELLIS
AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. I AM ALSO A
VOLUNTEER AT GUN SHOWS AND OF A
COMPETITIVE TOTAL SHOOTER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY FIVE
TWO TWO TWO THANK YOU. YOU
POLITE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE ONE TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
TAMMY BOND BACK A MOTHER OF TWO
AND I OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELL I
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO ONE TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DISASSOCIATION I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY TWO THANK YOU.
GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN ONE ONE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SH HI MY NAME IS LISA
MCKENZIE FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I'M A MEMBER OF THE
NRA. ARMED WOMEN OF AMERICA AND
I'M A CERTIFIED RANGE SAFETY
INSTRUCTOR I OPPOSE AB TWO FIVE
FIVE YOU IT IS REDUNDANT AND
THERE ARE ALREADY. WILL I NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT NINE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RESEARCHERS
DEMOCRAT ON THE CHAIR OF THE
SOUTH SACRAMENTO CHAPTER THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. GROWING
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
THAT'S ONE ONE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS YOUR IN THE
FROM THE FALLS IN NORTH
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA RIGHT WING
COASTAL'S ASSOCIATION WITH
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. GROWING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE ONE TWO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PAT HURDEN
I AM THE CHAIRMAN OF THE TAMA
COUNTY GUN OWNERS CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. RETIRED SERGEANT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL AND IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO FIVE FIVE TWO THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT ONE TWO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS PAUL
CABS I'M A RESIDENT OF
INTERCOUNTY FATHER OF THREE AND
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
RECALL. IN STRONG OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY TWO THANK YOU
. GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE THREE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THURMOND ENTROPIC
LAYING ON THE CHAIR OF THE WHOLE
FROM NORTH- SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION CHAPTER. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWO FIVE
FIVE TWO THANK YOU. GROWING
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THREE ONE
ZERO THREE YEAR LONG AS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS JIM WESTFALL I'M
A MEMBER OF C. R. PA AND THE NRA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINE ONE ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS TERRA HUME
I'M AN NRA MEMBER AND IF YOU
HAVE A MEMBER ALLY STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO FIVE FIVE TO GIVE.
GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE ONE THREE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
NICOLE RETIREMENT BY MY MOTHER
SEVEN INCLUDING TWO MARINES AND
ONE ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION
. THANK GROWING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN ONE ONE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JOHN HICKMAN I
AM WHICH OF THE NEVADA COUNTY
GUN OWNERS A RESUME OF GRASS
VALLEY NUMBER OF THIS CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
MEMBER OF THE NRA. MEMBER OF GUN
OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA AND- IN
REPRESENTATION OF THOUSANDS OF
NEVADA COUNTY GUN OWNERS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. WELL
GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN IT'S TRIPLE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JAMES
FRAZIER VENTURA COUNTY RESIDENTS
AND I OPPOSE EIGHTY TWO FIVE
FIVE TWO THANK YOU. GROWING
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN THAT'S ONE TWO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GARY
LUNDBERG. AND I'M A VENTURA
COUNTY RESIDENT. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWO FIVE FIVE TWO.
THANK YOU. GROWING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX THAT'S
ONE TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT MY NAME IS MIKE FRANCO-
CALLING FROM IRVINE I AM A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER I'VE ATTENDED GUN
SHOWS FOR THE LAST FORTY YEARS
AND BEEN OCCASIONAL VENDOR AT
GUN SHOWS. AND I'M IN OPPOSITION
AB. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY TWO.
GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO THAT'S ONE THREE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS JEFF TURNER
I AM A RESIDENT OF SEASIDE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRAT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY TWO
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE ACCORDINGLY
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
THAT'S ONE THREE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BY MAN'S BILLION
CENTERS CAN I RESIDENT. ANSONIA
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
TWO. AND WITH AMATEUR WE'VE
EXHAUSTED ALL COMMENTS IN Q. AND
YOU BRING ABOUT COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OF RESPONDED THAT MR
LACK. BUT IT THANK AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FORWARD THIS BILL AND
JUST KIND OF TO GIVE US OF THE
SCOPE THAT YOU'VE SHARED WITH
US- WITH THE HUNT GUN SHOWS.
ANNUALLY IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
OVER THOUSAND FIREARMS CAN BE
SOLD ON ANY SINGLE WEEKEND TO
MEANS THAT WE HAVE A HUNDRED
GUNS PASSING- THESE FARES AND I
JUST WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE YOU ARE
PROMOTING. THAT THE ADVERTISING
OF SAFE STORAGE OF BEING CLEAR
ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCES
ASSOCIATED WITH- EXPOSING GUNS
TO MINORS. AT HELPING PURCHASERS
BE CLEAR ON THE SAFE USAGE. OF
THAT ENDS AND ALSO ON THEIR
WRIST. TO REPORT THE LOSS OF
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM- AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT FORWARD AND ALSO GIVE YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY TO. ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT THE SCOPE
AND RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. I HAVE IT
ON GOOD AUTHORITY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CARES VERY
DEEPLY. ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
WE REDUCE THE USE OF GUNS. GUNS
AND GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR STATE.
IF YOU CAN DO THAT IN YOUR
CLOTHES IF YOU DON'T. MR LACKEY
YEAH I THINK CLEARLY ALL OF US
ARE AGAINST THE VIOLENCE OR THE
VIOLENT ACTIONS WITH A GUN
ESPECIALLY THE TRAGIC
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT. ABOUT US
AWARE OF THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
NOT MANAGING VERY WELL. BUT I
WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU THAT ARE
APPETITE NEEDS TO BE MORE
FOCUSED. TOWARDS THE BEHAVIOR
WITH THAT WEAPON ARE NOT THE
WEAPON ITSELF- I FIND IT.
ALARMING THAT WE ARE SO FOCUSED
ON CREATING MORE AND MORE
PARAMETERS FOR LEGAL PURCHASERS
THOSE ARE NOT THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ENGAGING IN THESE VIOLENT
ACTS AND- I CLEARLY PREVENTION
OF PRECAUTIONS ARE. SOMETHING WE
ALL SUPPORT BUT I THINK THAT
THIS BILL PROVIDES A VERY
ARBITRARY AND UNNECESSARY
ACTIONS FOR EXAMPLE. I'M
CONFUSED WHY THE LANGUAGE
DOESN'T SAY AT LEAST ONE HALF.
BUT IT SAYS LITERALLY ONE HALF.
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S MAYBE A
MINOR THING BUT SOMETHING YOU
SHOULD PROBABLY CONSIDER-
AMENDING- BUT THIS POINT I'M NOT
IN A POSITION TO SUPPORT THE
BILL BECAUSE I THINK IT HAS THE-
THE PROPER FOCUS OF THIS IS
TRUE- ARBITER. THANK YOU ANYMORE
COMMENTS MISTER. CLARK SO- IS
PART OF THE BELLI LIGHT CAN SO
I'LL BE VOTING FOR IT THAT I
DON'T BELIEVE IN GENERAL
INCREASING PENALTIES AND THAT IS
PART OF YOUR BILL. I DO LIKE THE
INSPECTIONS MY CONCERN THAT
THERE IS DO YOU HAVE- THE MONEY
IN THE BUDGET TO ACTUALLY ALLOW
FOR THESE INSPECTIONS THEN YOU
CAN ANSWER THAT AND CLOSE. IF
ANYONE ELSE. YOU MAY CLOSE UP
MISSED SANTIAGO ONE OF THE-
COOPER AND I'M PLANNING WORK HI
MY- THE MAN WHO NUMBER OF PEOPLE
RATHER THAN THE BOTTOM LINE MORE
GUNS ON THE STREET MORE LIFE.
HELLO MATHIS WORKING AWAY.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING. MORE GUNS
ON STREET REFLECT. I WANT TO SEE
HOW WORKS- BUT WHAT ABOUT ALL
THAT HAPPENED. I WILL BE IT'S
NOT A ONE SIZE I KIND. WHAT THE
ARTICLE. THE TEREMOS. SEVEN THE
YOU MOTION ERIC SECOND OKAY WITH
THAT SAID YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU I THINK THERE IS THREE FOUR
MAYBE FIVE OR SIX THINGS HELLA
TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS THE FIRST IS
I WONDER THE AMENDMENTS THE- THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH
ADDRESS MISTER QUIRKS KIDS
ABOUT- THE- PUNISHMENT. OF IT TO
SO WE TAKEN A JOB THERE- IN MR
SANTIAGO YEAH I AM VERY ANGRY
AND SAD AND UPSET BUT I YOU KNOW
BELIEVE THAT THE MORE ANGRY YOU
ARE THE LOWER YOUR VOICE SHOULD
BE. AS I'M TRYING TO BE
REASONABLE HERE I DON'T THINK.
THAT THE CALLER IS DEAD WRONG I
DIDN'T SAY THIS WOULD HAVE
PREVENTED BUT WE HAPPENED OVER
THE WHAT HAPPENED BUT IT JUST
SHOWS THAT. WE KNOW THAT ONE
GUNS GET IN THE WRONG HANDS
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS WE CAN
LOOK AT THAT. AND TO EVEN OUR
OWN IT EVEN OUR OWN DISTRICT
ATTORNEY ANNE MARIE SCHUBERT WAS
QUOTED AFTERWARDS SAYING THERE
ARE WAY TOO MANY OF THESE GHOST
GUNS ON THE STREETS THAT ARE
SOLD ILLEGALLY. INAPPROPRIATELY
WHETHER THE INDIVIDUAL. LET
DRIVES TO NEVADA TWO HOURS FROM
HERE AND BUYS A MEDIC AND SHOW
ZERO REGULATIONS I RIDE THAT
THAT PART WE HAVE. A HUNDRED
PLUS LAWS ON THE BOOKS HERE. BUT
THEY DON'T MEAN A LOT UNLESS WE
HAVE A FEDERAL POLICY THAT HAS A
UNIFORM STANDARD SO. HAVING
NEVADA IN OUR IN OUR NEIGHBORING
STATES HAVING STRONG LAWS IS
IMPORTANT BUT WHAT CAN WE DO
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN STEP
IT UP TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE DON'T
LOOK THE CRACKS OF. LITERALLY ON
THE DAY. THAT THE LETTER WAS
SUBMITTED BY THE- RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND MY
UNDERSTANDING RESTED PC WAS
DELIVERED BY I MISS LYNCH- THEY
QUESTION HERE WHETHER OR NOT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ANYBODY HAS
EVER. FOUND SOMEBODY BUYING ANY
LEGAL GUN AT A GUN SHOW THAT
SAME DAY OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL.
ANNOUNCED THE BIGGEST ACROSS
SOUTHERN. WHERE THEY WILL
LITERALLY WITNESSED AT ARMS ARE
PROHIBITED PERSON. INDIVIDUALS
THIRTY YEARS. IN IN STATE PRISON
. WAS PROHIBITS FROM OWNING AND
POSSESSING FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION GO TO A GUN SHOW IN
SAMBAR DINO. AND THEY WATCHED A
BY GOES CAN GET. AND SO WE DO
KNOW THAT TERE WASN'T PROPER
BACKGROUND CHECKS TO MAKE SURE
THIS PERSON SHOULD BE BUYING
THIS FIREARM. SO FOR PEOPLE
SAYING THIS IS GOING TO INFRINGE
UPON THEIR SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHT THAT'S BALONEY. THAT'S B.
S. YOU CAN STILL GO TO A GUN
SHOW THERE'S BILLS THIS
LEGISLATURE TO BAN GUN SHOWS.
I'M NOT DOING THAT TODAY MAYBE I
DON'T FOR THAT SOMEONE ABANDONED
ITS STATE FAIRGROUNDS AND COUNTY
FAIRS YEAH BUT THEIR GUN SHOWS
THAT ARE LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS SAYS IT IS GOOD
SHOWS THAT IT THIS THAT THE-
MUST PUT SIGNAGE UP THERE WHICH
WE HAVE IN MOST GUY READ ANYWAY
FOCUS ON THE BASICS OF GUN
OWNERSHIP BUT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE IF YOU
LOSE. YOUR GUN IS STOLEN- AND
SAFE STORAGE- WE HAVE A LOT OF
BUSINESSES WHETHER CAR CLUBS
CASINOS THE L. SALONS WE'RE
GOING INSPECTED ONCE A YEAR FOR
GOVERNMENT WHAT WE'RE SAYING
HERE WE SUSPECT THEM EVERY OTHER
YEAR. AND WE'LL LOOK SET MISTER
LACKEYS AMENDMENT SAYING THAT IT
WILL BE PRECISELY ONE HALF WILL
BE AT AN INSPECTION ONCE EVERY
OTHER YEAR FOR GUN SHY DON'T%
THINK THAT'S AN OVERLY.
BURDENSOME REQUIREMENTS ON GUN
OWNERS AND SECOND AMENDMENT UP
RIGHT FULL LEGAL INDIVIDUALS
WILL HAVE NO PROBLEM GOINGAND
BUYING THEIR FIREARMS AS THEY
WISH AND SO THIS JUST BRINGS A
LITTLE BIT MORE. SECURITY AND
SAFETY TO- THE SHOWS IN
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFULLY. ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN.
AND IT'S- GOOD WHICH DAVID. ON
TOP OF THIS- CORPORATE IT'S
CALLED GUN BY NOT BE BY THE SO
WE REDUCE TO STEP UP OUR EFFORTS
TO GET THE GUNS OTHER
INDIVIDUALS HANDS THE SHOULDN'T
HAVE SODA. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY. AND EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY. GREAT CALDERON ON AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY TWO BY SOME MEMBER
MCCARTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER IRAQI LACKEY NO BONTA HI
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN HI CORK.
CORK I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I SEE
ARE TO THE ARE TO KNOW THAT
MEASURE PASSED THE MEASURE
PASSES WITHOUT TO ADD ONS-
LIFTING THE CALLS IN BOTH
CHANGES. THAT SECRETARY PLEASE
GO THROUGH ALL THE MEASURES
TAKEN UP TODAY. ON THE CONSENT
QUIRK QUIRK I DON'T NUMBER ONE
WAS ON CONSENT. I ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE BONTA
. I BONTA I A NUMBER TO THE
NETWORK USE ME O AB TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE BONTA I TO NOT
VOTING. ITEM NUMBER THREE WAS ON
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL BONTA. I
MEAN I NEVER GET PLEASE AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT BY THE
MEMBER BARRICADE CAN IT'S
REGARDING JUVENILES. BONTA HI
THAT MEASURE PASSES. ITEM NUMBER
SIX WAS ON CONSENT ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN WAS ON CONSENT ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. I'M GETTING A NUMBER
SEVEN WITH FULL BY THE AUTHOR
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR BY SEVEN MEMBER
HOLDEN THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER HI
QUIRK. QUIRK I SANTIAGO. YES SIR
SANTIAGO I SEYARTO SEYARTO KNOW
THAT MEASURE PASSES ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I SEE OUR TO SEE OUR TO
KNOW THAT MEASURE PASSES. I AM
NUMBER TEN WAS ON CONSENT. ADAM
ELEVEN BY SEVEN MEMBER MATHIS
SANTIAGO. IT'S ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN BISON
REMEMBER MATHIS. SANTIAGO
ABSTAINED. I DON'T NUMBER TWELVE
IS JUSTIN SPENDS WITH ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN WAS ON CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR. I DON'T NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ
BONTA. BONTA NO SANTIAGO. AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIDGE REGUS. I REMEMBER
FIFTEEN ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN.
THAT'S ALRIGHT. SANTIAGO NO I.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE QUIRK I
WORK HI THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN THIS IS AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS. AT.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
LACKEY NO BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN
BRIAN HI QUIRK QUIRK HI SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO I SEYARTO SEE OUR TO
KNOW THAT MEASURE PASSES. I
DON'T NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY ONE BY SEPTEMBER
BONTA THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL
QUIRK HI QUIRK I SEYARTO THEY
ARE TO KNOW THAT MEASURE PASSES
. THE ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR BY SOME
MEMBER BRIAN THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL QUIRK HI WORK AYE SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO I SEYARTO. THEY ARE TO
KNOWTHAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS
TO THE BUSINESS JUST A MINUTE
CAN I MAKE SURE THAT- ITEM
ELEVEN AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS
GRANTED GENERATION. THAT WAS
ABLE TO WORK CONSIDERATION BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT BY THOSE IN
THE ROOM THANK YOU. FOR
REPORTING. WE KNOW IT IS NOT
WORKING WITH BOTH OF THE AB ON.
I EVEN PARKING. TWENTY SEVEN.
NOT OF. COURSE ON AB TWENTY SO
TEEN BY SUMMER MATT SANTIAGO
UPSET TO VOTE. THIS CONCLUDES
BUSINESS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.